coming up a panel discussion on zora
neale hurston's novel their eyes were
watching god the discussion revolves
around the novel's characterizations of
black men and women in the early 20th
century
they said three minutes
you ready
welcome to the county color regional
branch i'm phyllis mack the regional
librarian for central harlem a warm
welcome
to those first-time visitors and welcome
back to those who use us frequently
we're happy that harpercollins selected
this library
for the celebration of zoro neil
hurston's their eyes were watching god
county cullen regional library that's
county c-o-u-n-t-e-e
has quite a history it was formerly the
135th street branch our carnegie
building
it outgrew its space
on 135th street and a new library was
constructed in 1941
on 136th street adjacent to the old
building it was renamed in 1951 for
county cullen
harlem renaissance poet teacher neighbor
and friend of the library
this particular library is known for its
rich collections of african american
books
circulating and reference collections
and materials for all ages on just about
every subject you cannot miss seeing the
first floor wall of books
as described by one of our users
at this time
i wish to introduce to you marcia spiros
coordinator of adult services who will
continue with the program and before we
go on we are asking that you please not
use any flashes it interferes with the
program and please take your pictures
after the program marcia
good afternoon
my name is marcia spiros and i'm the
coordinator of adult services for the
branch libraries of the new york public
library and i would like to add my voice
to that of phyllis mac in welcoming
welcoming you to the county colin
regional library
before we
begin today's program i would like to
mention um in case you haven't noticed
the small print
that due to family illness edwards
dantikat will not be here today and
we're very sorry about that
and also before we begin i would like to
thank
acknowledge and praise
cecil hickson
who is sitting in the corner
[Applause]
the adult programming specialist in the
office of adult services and i have two
things to thank him for
one is his incredible work in organizing
a brilliant program last week
to celebrate the publication of a
bibliography of over 900 titles on the
black experience no crystal stair and
that will be available within a couple
of weeks in the branch and we hope
you'll come in and get a coffee
and also for his work
on today's program with virginia stanley
of harpercollins
today
we are engaged in a happy conspiracy of
publishers writers
artists librarians and you the reading
public
to celebrate a new edition of the
landmark novel by zora neale hurston
their eyes were watching god
it is incredible to think that a book
which
from its first sentence
rises to the ranks of the best ever
written
could have fallen into obscurity
it provides a lesson to us that even as
we celebrate today
we must pledge to new generations of
writers
support for their most daring work
concern for their well-being
active interest in doing our part
to be the kind of readers because of
whom
publishers respond by publishing the
unique
libraries respond
by acquiring the literary
it is a great but joyous responsibility
as we celebrate zora neale hurston's
great accomplishments and let me mention
that we celebrate them with the presence
of her niece lucy hurston who's sitting
in the side here
[Applause]
let us fold into the celebration the
child writing first words and sentences
the first sparkling paragraph the first
story first manuscript first tentative
steps to a success in which we
participate
we are strong and smart and as readers
we have influence
we're having also a slight reversal
in the program our first speaker is
going to be
asha
bandalay
who is the editor at large for essence
magazine
she holds a bachelor of arts degree from
the new school for social research and a
master of fine arts degree from
bennington college
over the course of the last 10 years
asha has performed her poetry on
campuses and in community centers across
the united states
in the united kingdom and in south
southern africa
she's also taught and lectured on
writing
as well as on various social issues in
venues as diverse as columbia law school
the university of michigan
the black and puerto rican legislative
caucus and juvenile detention centers
prisons and in numerous churches
asha has been published in several
poetry anthologies including catch the
fire and in the tradition
and in addition her byline has been seen
in several periodicals whose primary
audience is the hip-hop generation
including the source
honey and rap pages magazine
asha's first book
absence in the palms of my hands a
collection of poems received much
critical acclaim
the prisoner's wife a memoir about her
relationship with a man incarcerated for
murder
is her second book
of the prisoner's wife booklist magazine
wrote her writing soars with emotion and
the reader's emotions soar as well
not because of a shared experience but
because her highly polished and skillful
writing
makes one feel her pain and joy please
welcome asha bandula
thank you very much marcia and to the
audience and to the staff of the library
lucy hurston virginia stanley of harper
collins and victoria sanders literary
associates who represents the state i'm
very grateful to be here with you
and thank you all for your work and
putting this together i'm overwhelmed by
the number of people who are here
so all that said getting warmed up
taking a deep breath let me just begin
one faces a a considerable challenge in
trying to say something that's both new
and relevant about zora neale hurston's
classic work their eyes were watching
god
certainly that's no fault of the text
which to my mind remains one of the
greatest and most inspirational works of
fiction ever written
rather it's that there's been so much
study of hurston in her work that i
don't quite know where my voice fit into
the discourse and i would be lying if i
didn't tell you i wasn't both humbled
and overwhelmed by uh this incredible
panel of scholars and performers and
thinkers and writers all of whom have
played a role in my own development
but what i came to finally in the
nervous horrible weeks leading up to
this afternoon
was at the one place of authenticity
which i could occupy
was that place of a lone reader the
person who comes to a novel hoping it
will provide a language and context for
the often incomprehensible maze that is
my own internal landscape i am the
reader who seeks in the literature a
commonality with another being in the
world a sharing of experience a turn of
a phrase that brings light crystallizes
vision touches at the core encourages a
wholeness to my humanity a story that
tells a truth that is undeniable perhaps
difficult but at last useful their eyes
were watching god brought all of that to
me in a way i was not prepared for when
i picked it up and read it again in
preparation for today
when i first read it 15 years ago as a
teenager as a girl who still confused
whirlwind romance with real love what i
took away from the book then and what i
carried with me all of those years was
the soul of tea cake that free-spirited
man who cherished janie crawford and who
played the guitar and who gambled too
much but in who in the end gave his life
for the woman he loved yes tea cake who
after saving janie from the rabid dog
and her thanking him her telling him if
it hadn't been for him the man turned to
his wife and said you don't have to say
if it wasn't for me baby because i'm
here and then i want you to know it's a
man here
i swooned with teenage fantasy over that
line spent endless days and nights
looking to have me a man here so i
thought when i sat down and began to
read the text again a few weeks ago my
remarks would be framed around tea cake
and janie's love and how it was okay
that he wasn't perfect because finally
perfection is not our requirement our
requirement is that we do the best with
what we have been given and surely tea
cake and janey met that requirement so
yes their eyes were watching god is and
will always be for me an epic love story
between these two characters but what i
found this time around reading is that
it's an epic love story for quite
another reason
this time around what i discovered was
that it is above all a love story
between black women
we see this first in nanny's care for
janie her granddaughter even as we
cringed and disagreed with nanny sending
the girl off into a marriage with logan
killix a man of property and some wealth
who among us in particular those of us
who are mothers couldn't understand that
nanny was guided by love albeit a love
that had been shaped or perhaps
misshaped by slavery and the
continuation of horror and limited
choices that followed black people off
of the plantation and into the feudal
state that was the south and nanny who
told a frightened young janie who didn't
want to marry logan killix you know
honey us colored folks is branches
without roots and that makes things come
round in queer ways i was born back and
do slavery so it wasn't for me to
fulfill my dreams of what a woman ought
to be that's one of the holdbacks of
slavery i didn't want to be used for a
workhorse and brood style i didn't want
my daughter used that way either it sure
wasn't my will for things to happen like
they did i even hated the way you was
born but all the same i said thank god i
got another chance
i wanted to preach a great sermon about
colored women sitting on high but there
wasn't no pulpit for me and janie maybe
it wasn't much but i've done the best i
can by you i raked and scraped and
bought us a little piece of land so you
wouldn't have to stay in a white folks
yard and tuck your head before other
children at school i wanted you to look
upon yourself
and i can't die easy thinking maybe men
folks white or black is making a spit
cup out of you
have some sympathy for me put me down
easy janie i'm a cracked plate
and so despite how
janie came to resent
perhaps even hate nanny for that
decision it was those words that she
ought to never become a spit cup that
she ought to be a colored woman sitting
on high which eventually directed janie
throughout all of her life
those words that those ideas and that
vision allowed janie to leave logan
killix and later after her second
husband the one who wanted to lock her
up like an ornament forever after he
died it is the notion of sitting on high
that stops janie from living out her
life as a middle-aged widow mourning for
a man who did not earn her love
and so to the shock and even the disgust
of her fellow townspeople amid rumor and
controversy janie left that town her
dead husband had helped to create and
went off into the horizon with the one
man who just loved her for who she was
he didn't seek to cage or change her in
the great expanse of that love that
janie experienced with tk she came home
to herself which of course is the peace
all of us are seeking in this life a
space of freedom a space where we can
stretch ourselves and our souls all the
way out with no fear of rejection or
reprisal in short
janie fell in love with herself she fell
in love with herself enough to honor
that which she needed to make herself
whole it was love is an inside thing is
it all in your bones feel it when you
walk when you work when you sing when
you ache when you pull the horizon in
like a great fishnet that kind of love
and it grew so complete inside of janie
that she was able to share it with those
who are willing to accept the gift like
her friend phoebe who never judged janie
who didn't turn her back on janie even
when others sat on porches and whispered
about her no phoebe said i don't grow 10
feet just listening to you girl and so
because we know
that the way we survive through the
worst of our times is not with money or
any of the things that money can buy we
survive by sharing with others the very
best of who we are the lessons and the
stories that have brought us to a new
way of seeing and being in the world the
truths out of the mouths of our mothers
ultimately
i experienced their eyes were watching
god as a love story between zora neale
hurston and the black woman reader
re-entering these pages and this story i
thought about zora furiously writing the
book in an unbelievable six weeks in
haiti much in the way i think about the
writer nawal el-sadawi who was formerly
a political prisoner in egypt sadawi
wrote her memoir while imprisoned and
the guards would not give her a pen
because they said a pen in her hands was
more dangerous than a gun so she wrote
her words on toilet paper with eyeliner
and lipstick that other prisoners had
secreted to her that unflappable need to
get a story out to people people to say
this is where we are but if you can just
imagine where we could be is the energy
i felt from zora reading this book zora
there in the first free black republic
in the western hemisphere sitting and
trying to create a picture of a free
black woman who desperately desired to
end the cosmic loneliness and get to her
horizon
i thought about how she must have loved
us to create such a character i thought
about it in the way i think about the
women in my own life who have at varying
times pushed and pulled raked and
scraped to encourage a vision for living
in me that went beyond the bitterness
and the hurt and the oppression i have
known i thought about what i would be
willing to do for my own daughter the
woman i want to be in her presence
courageous and fair and open and willing
and the fact that zora neil hurston
created janie in 1937 has to be in a
word stunning who were her role models
who were her mirrors
we barely have them now
working for a black women's magazine in
the today of our lives reading letters
speaking to black women from all over
this country i know without a doubt
that so many of us continue to live our
lives parceling out the joy lest we lose
what we believe to be our ever shrinking
ration
so many of us are still out here just
making do
in my heart i will never believe that
that is what we are here to do
to live life only in the tiny and
difficult details of it rather than in
the place of incredible promise
it's a hard thing to think about and
remember when there are so many bills to
pay
and diapers to change when there are so
many losses to suffer when there are so
many ongoing battles both internal and
external
but zora
did her work for us
as a writer as an artist as a sister as
a home girl
because she reminded us how much more
possibility there was and most
importantly that we had only to rely
upon ourselves and our own strength to
make that possibility manifest she once
said that all of us ought to jump at the
sun
we might not touch it but at least we'll
be off the ground i know i'm one of many
women who needs to be reminded more
often than i'll ever admit to reach for
grab at and jump at the sun
what a gift of love
to have their eyes we're watching god to
go back to again and again and again
in the hard and mean times of my own
life in the moments i most need to be
pushed to stand up girl to get off the
ground to jump at the sun
thank you for listening
[Music]
it's almost impossible to speak after
that it was so overwhelming thank you
very much asha i know
valerie wilson wesley
is the author of the um tamara hale
mystery series
her latest mystery the devil riding was
released in hardcover in
june of 2000
easier to kill no hiding place where
evil sleeps devil's going to get him and
when death comes stealing are all now
available in paperback and have placed
highly on several bestseller lists
they've also been published in germany
great britain france and poland and tv
and film rights for the first three
books have been purchased
miss wesley is also the author of the
novel ain't nobody's business if i do
which one the black caucus of the
american library association literary
award for fiction in 2000
other works by miss wesley
include freedom's gift a juneteenth
story which is a picture book for
children
and the young adult novel where do i go
from here for which she received an ala
best book for reluctant readers citation
she is formerly executive editor and
currently a contributing editor of
essence magazine
and you can tell from those two awards
from the american library association
that she is much beloved of librarians
please welcome valerie wilson wesley
[Music]
i'm really delighted to be here and
thank you for that warm welcome and for
you for that marvelous presentation
about about so how do i follow that
um
and thank you virginia
and cecil and for remembering me and and
really helping to celebrate one of my
favorite writers
i discovered their eyes were watching
god
in 1976.
in those days i was the mother of two
young daughters
and writing a book was something i
fantasized about between making peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches and plaiting
little heads
my husband richard
was the writer
he'd written two blockbuster films
uptown saturday night and let's do it
again
and had about four critically acclaimed
off-broadway productions
i was the playwright's wife
or timbi and andy's mother
or burton skip's daughter
and it always seemed that i belonged to
somebody else much like jamie crawford
did
becoming a writer was a dream i kept to
myself
the day i found the book i'd met a
friend for lunch in the village
a rare excursion for me from the suburbs
of new jersey
and she took me to a small bookstore on
9th and broadway right down from the
strand
it's specialized in african american
books i don't think it exists anymore
but it was a marvelous marvelous store
it's a little hole in the wall
very dusty
and poking through the mess of books
that were kind of strewn everywhere
i came upon their eyes for watching god
i'd never heard of zora neale hurston
much less of her books
i didn't subscribe to ms i was at that
point parents magazine and red book was
what i mostly read
so i missed alice walker's famous essay
about finding zara neil hurston that
appeared in the
70s but it really didn't matter
when i finally found the time to read
their eyes are watching god
i couldn't put it down
for one thing i love the language
it was the language of my family my
grandparents my great-aunts and uncles
i think the dialect in the book is
difficult for some people today
particularly for younger readers two or
three generations removed from the south
but it made me feel at home
i could actually feel my grandparents
and their roots when i read passages
aloud which i did then and still do now
i could feel the south
where they were
and where i would visit during the
summer
i could hear the cadence of their voices
in the expressions that i read
the american south was still segregated
in the 1950s when i was a girl
still is but people don't talk too much
about that
and reading the north too for that
matter and
and reading the book brought back the
nuance and rhythm of a culture that was
absent from the predominantly white town
in connecticut where i grew up
it's a book that is steeped in
african-american folk tradition
some which i recognize and some which
only my mother or her mother would but
they all played a part in making who me
who i am
i also enjoyed the book because it was a
love story and as asha so perfectly
pointed out it's not only about tk can
janie but about phoebe and her love for
her sisters
for janie and also about nanny's love
for for jadie and that i think is
something that we we sometimes forget
it's truly a love story
and for me it was one of the first i'd
read featuring black men and women
today it seems that relationship books
are easy to find like i've written one
myself and i'm writing one now
but back in the 70s books about black
women and men loving passionately were
few and far between
so when nanny says to janie
lord have mercy that's the very prong
all us black women gets hung up on this
love
that's just what's got us pulling and
hauling and
sweating and doing from can't see in the
morning until can't see at night
[Music]
i laughed out loud much as i am now
because i could hear those words coming
from my grandmother's mouth making the
very same observations
the book also dealt very frankly with
some other aspects of black culture
which weren't being written about too
much then
color class and the infraracial
antagonisms
that are tackled by zora neale hurston
was out with observations that still
unfortunately ring true
when ms turner's whose lips were an evil
delight to her eyes according to zara
makes her crazy as things statements
about black people
all you can do is just shake your head
and sigh and say my people my people
anyone who's read the book knows what
i'm talking about
is there a black person in america who
has not heard some variation of this
theme from some poor misguided soul
stay out the sun you don't want to get
too dark don't wear red that girl's got
some good hair
so zora neal got that right too
but yet she doesn't play the color card
janie is a light-skinned woman
she's but she's not a tragic mulatto in
any sense of the word
she is tough in her own way and not
afraid to take chances
tea cake with his ebony skin is the most
beautiful man she has ever seen
let there be no doubt about that and as
i read it he was one of the most
beautiful men i'd ever fantasized about
zora neale hurston definitely gives us
her people all of us
are due with all of our warts and all of
our beauty
i reread the book recently and although
much of the magic remained
i was very disturbed of course by the
scene in the muck when tea cake hits
janie basically to show the other men
who the boss is
and i was appalled by sop to bottom's
observations about beating women
tkq sure as a lucky man top to bottom
says a person can see every place you
hit her
what i said what's it what's this what's
going on
i don't ever being so shocked about
those words when i first read the book
as i am now
these days i simply don't read a book in
which violence against a woman goes
unpunished
i hurl it up against the wall
i often tell readers of my mysteries
that my books a woman beater is never
the murderer he's always dead by the
third chapter
but 20 years ago i finished this book
and i finished it recently despite my
reservations about you know in some ways
some of the
of the um the violence against women
the book still touches me
and i think it's because it's about love
passionate love that knows no bounds
and that's always a lot of fun to read
about
but it's also about taking chances and
about growth
and janie grows at the end of the book
to a strong and self-reliant woman who
insist upon defining herself in the
world of men
which is what we as women all must do
so as much as anybody else in my life i
think i have to thank janie and zora
neale hurston for my growth
versus a woman
and finally as a writer
and it's a debt that i know i will try
to repay
with every word that i write
thank you
thank you valerie
bell hooks is going to have the briefest
introduction
but she has the longest list
of books
and she also has a wonderful
relationship with the library that's not
included in this which was written
not by us
she has been generous with us in coming
to do programs for us um
she's a part of the library family
and um we love her very much that's the
operative word today it seems but it's
extremely appropriate
and i know i speak for for cecil
wherever you are where are you hiding
cecil in saying this
acclaimed visionary
writer
intellectual
feminist theorist and cultural critic
bell hooks is first and foremost a
seeker on love's path
[Music]
most recently distinguished professor of
english at city college and the graduate
center of the city university of new
york
she was professor of english at yale
university and oberlin college
dr hooks finished her undergraduate work
at stanford university and completed her
doctorate at the university of
california santa cruz
currently she spends her time writing
and lecturing around the nation and
abroad
and we're so pleased that she is not
around the nation and abroad today and
that she is here with us
salvation black people and love her 20th
book
was just recently released in hardcover
please welcome bell hooks
[Applause]
i always
have to give praise to libraries because
if there were not libraries there
wouldn't be a bell hooks and all praise
to cecil for how much he affirms
our need to read as black folks how much
he works to bring
exciting people to libraries to black
people
the last time
i was with lucy hurston the niece of
zordo hurston who's over here in the
corner some of you can't see lucy we
were in eatonville
and we were looking at
a town really ravaged by
all the forces of of greed and
capitalism and real estate speculation
and we were staying up in the late night
talking about our lives our our longings
our search for love
i want to start with a quote
from their eyes we're watching god
if you can see the light at daybreak
you don't care if you die at dusk
it's so many people that never see the
light at all
i was fumbling around
and god opened the door
i've spent the last four weeks
going around this nation talking to
people about black people and love
and the important thing about their eyes
we're watching god is that the love that
janie seeks and
the the force that guides her
is not the idea of romantic love
but the idea that divine love
is made present and manifest in our
human relationships
so that what jamie's journey to
is a journey
to back to her own essential goodness
in christian tradition we hear i have
loved you with an everlasting love
and what janie goes through in this
journey
from not loving herself because as i've
gone around talking about salvation and
of course hurston is mentioned in the
first five pages of salvation black
people and love because when the debates
were going on with richard wright
um and other people about whether we had
been so dehumanized by racism that we
couldn't know love
there was zoronel hurston's their eyes
were watching god standing as testimony
that love could be created in the muck
among the poorest of the poor
that one could find that love that
jackie wilson would write about a love
that lifts you higher but the
interesting thing is that
she's constantly letting us know that
that love is not embodied in a human
being first and foremost but that it's
embodied in a divine spirit and that we
we are allowed through human interaction
to reach for that divine
when i think about people talking about
coming to the novel their eyes were
watching god
you know i love the novel but i was
interested in hurston because i wanted
to be a writer
and i used to make this joke that i
didn't want to live out the zorro neil
hurston syndrome
and that syndrome to me was that you
would die broke
unforgotten
unappreciated by your peers
i mean i i just have to evoke that
because i don't want us to just not
remember truly how we treated hustler as
a writer because you know black folks
that's part of our issue around love
that we did not in the day that she was
writing uphold her strengthen her make
it possible for her to write her twenty
books
and so jo zorno hurston has been like a
light to me both guiding me into the
kind of writer i wanted to be but also
guiding me further because i have wanted
to live so i want to tell you that
that's the most important lesson that i
learned from their eyes were watching
god that at the end of the day janie
wanted to live
and she wanted to live her life more
abundantly
so that when she went in her search of
herself she found tea cake and tea cake
was fun he had the alternative
masculinity the masculinity that was
about play and and having a good time
and he was not about domination and even
though you have that scene where he hits
rehearsing is so clear
that
he's doing this for other men that he's
not doing this
because that's his his way that he feels
he can't be true to himself
and one of the things that i've been
saying all around this nation right now
about black folks in love we can't have
love if we can't be true to ourselves
so it's it's it's
automatically understood that they're
not going to make it
we know janie and tea cake are not going
to make it no matter how much fun he is
because at the end of the day tea cake
cannot be true to himself
but hurston
isn't really that concerned with whether
tea cake is going to be true to himself
she is concerned with whether janie
is going to be true to her journey
but through her relationship with tk
she gains the power to imagine to dream
to create i don't know if you remember
and if you haven't read the novel tea
cake is a musician and a composer
art is an integral part of his daily
life never separate or fetishized
remember that she buries him with his
new guitar and she imagines that he will
be in heaven thinking of new songs to
play to her
the important thing is that writing
their eyes were watching god at a time
in her life
when she was struggling with the issue
of will i be committed to art or will i
be committed to romantic relationships
i don't think hurston could have made
janie a writer because it would have
seemed too much like autobiography but
janie is not an artist without an art
form her art form is storytelling
and it is significant that when she
comes back
from her journey
i always love that phrase my tongue is
in my friend's mouth because when she
comes back
the first things that she does is tell
her story to phoebe
the story begins with uncertainty about
who she is
alphabet is what she's been called as a
girl she doesn't know and cannot know or
name herself ultimately
her triumph in womanhood
is that she acquires the ability to name
and define her reality you know
sometimes when you hear about their eyes
we're watching god you get the image
that the the book kind of stopped when
tk got died when janie has to kill tea
cake but in fact it's at the trial
because it's not enough that she's found
herself inwardly she has to be capable
of going out into a public world and
being true to herself
janie can survive the courtroom scene
and teach death because she has acquired
an ontological that is a sense of being
a framework on which to base the
construction of self and identity
while tea cake has enabled her to
fulfill her longing for romantic love
and her quest for self-realization at
the end of the day she has to be true
to her quest to learn how to tell a
story to tell it publicly and privately
phoebe tells janie after she hears her
story adam growed
ten feet higher just listening to you
and as asha pointed out the primacy of
female bonding
is valued here and it's based on shared
knowledge and that seems so important
for us to remember at a time where black
women are suffering so much inability in
this nation right now to love one
another that's something i've been
talking about throughout the we're
seeing all kind of levels of
viciousness among black women you know i
say the other day a woman came to my
reading i said you look so beautiful
well i know i'm not beautiful
you know i know i'm not i mean i'm not a
dog but i'm not beautiful and i was like
sister let's talk about why you couldn't
receive
that that compliment to yourself
so that she offers us a vision where
women need not be rivals
where we can share power reinforcing one
another's autonomy
janie can share her liberation her story
with phoebe and phoebe can go back as
you recall to her husband sam and have a
new take on things
you know i've always seen these two
books their eyes were watching god and
virginia woofs a room of one's own as
the books that sort of ushered me into
being a writer because at the
heart of both these books was an
insistence that women have to find the
words and we have to write
wolfe said that women had to face that
at the end of the day no matter how much
friendship you have and every woman
writer on this stage knows that you go
into writing by yourself and wolf says
you have to face that there's no arm to
cling to but that we go alone
and that our relation is to the world of
reality and not only to the world of men
and women
hurston ends their eyes we're watching
god with a fictive mirroring of this
prophetic declaration
it's an ending that celebrates a woman's
capacity to face life alone janie isn't
cut off from life at the ending of the
book she has a key memory and a powerful
liberated imagination she can create and
be a world for herself
she's last described as you recalled in
the act of reflection thinking
remembering imagining
even though she's a woman in mid-life
like myself she's rebellious
she refuses to accept anyone's idea of
what she should do and be
and it is this revelation
that she witnesses at the end of the
novel and she calls as you recall her
soul to come and see
as the novel ends she's inside her house
but interiority is not depicted as a
space of enclosure she's not restricted
or confined janie opens windows letting
in a light and air
transforming her inner space so that
it's expansive she transforms her safety
she has more than a room of her own
which is what virginia woolf said we
were going to need to write
she has the capacity to live fully in
that room
to reconcile
to reconcile to resurrect and to renew
one of the things that we have to
remember
that virginia woolf
this room of her own did not keep her
alive
hurston not only saves janie's life
she gives her space to rest
and renew her spirit
a space of infinite possibility
a space where she can create
such a space is essential for the growth
and the development of the female
imagination
the quest for women writers then
is a search not just for a room of our
own but for safe private space
for non-toxic air
for a place where the self can really
breathe
hurston spent most of her life
trying to find such a place
and we have to bear witness today that
she didn't find that place that she
didn't find that safe
celebratory place that kept her alive
without stones in her pocket like
virginia woolf who sank into the abyss
and drowned
person sank into the abyss of poverty
and misfortune
in their eyes we're watching god however
she creates
an emblematic woman character for all
women
a character who has a safe place
a wide transformative space
in which janie can create and call home
thank you
[Applause]
thank you bill
it's really overwhelming to have to come
up here after hearing each of you speak
uh the um
the depth and the quality of what we are
hearing today is is um is so
overwhelming and and it speaks to us on
on so many levels as readers as writers
as human beings
and um
i'm just trying myself to absorb and i
know the audience is too and taking a
minute in between to just give us some
time to absorb what we've been hearing
it's really quite an exceptional day
we continue
our program today
with ossie davis and ruby d
and i'm going to read you
bios which contain probably a lot of
things that you already know
but
which are so wonderful to be reminded of
and we will do that
aussie davis's career began while
attending howard university
where his first interest in the dramatic
arts was as a writer
encouraged to investigate the theater as
a playwright davis came to new york and
joined the rose mcclendon players a
harlem theater group
he debuted as an actor on broadway and
jeb and has performed on stage since
then
in such productions as green pastures
anna lucasta wisteria trees a raisin in
the sun
i'm not rappaport and his own satirical
farce pearly victorious
other writing credits include the plays
alice in wonder
the big deal
curtain call mr aldridge
sir
langston and escape to freedom for which
he received a jane addams children's
book award
and just like martin a children's book
about young people in the civil rights
movement
mr davis's most recent film performances
include the client
grumpy old men
i'm not rap a port with walter matthau
and spike lee's school days
do the right thing
jungle fever and malcolm x
other movie credits include the cardinal
the hill the scalp hunters let's do it
again and gone are the days
in addition mr davis has directed the
films cotton comes to harlem
gordon's war
black girl and congi's harvest
he has appeared on a number of
television shows including evening shade
bl striker the stand
and alex haley's roots the next
generation
davis earned emmy award nominations for
his work in teacher teacher in 1969
king in 1978 and miss evers boys in
1997.
ruby dee earned her bachelor's degree
from hunter college and began her acting
career as a player in the american negro
theater in harlem
some of ms d's favorite roles on stage
screen and television include looty
belle and pearly victorious
lena in bozeman and lena for which she
received an ob
julia in wedding band for the new york
shakespeare festival drama desk award
mary tyrone in the glass menagerie
ace award
queen haley and roots the next
generation and ruth in a raisin in the
sun
she also appeared in james baldwin's go
tell it on the mountain
cat people do the right thing and jungle
fever
other treasured experiences include
working with her husband and son guy
davis
in a storytelling folklore and musical
review
two hahas and a homeboy
a program compiled by miss d which draws
on her own writings the original
writings of davis and son
as well as zora neale hurston
d won acclaim as both an actor and
writer for her play
zora is my name on american playhouse
she is also the author of a musical
entitled
take it from the top
and
my one good nerve a compilation of her
short stories humor and poetry
she has adapted two african folk tales
into books for children entitled tower
to heaven and
two ways to count to ten
literary guild award
glo child another children's book
authored by dee
presents poetry for and by young people
ms d received emmy award nominations for
her work in the nurses in 1964 and china
beach in 1990
in 1991 she won the emmy for her work
and decoration day
aussie davis and ruby d have
collaborated on more than 30 projects
for stage screen television and radio
including their recent work as producers
for pbs of martin luther king the dream
and the drum
a walk through the 20th century with
bill moyers
and the critically acclaimed series with
ossie and ruby that explored the major
social and political events of the late
20th century
aussie davis and ruby d are both members
of the theater hall of fame and in 1989
received naacp image awards for their
work and do the right thing
in 1994
they were honored with the silver circle
award by the academy of television arts
and sciences
and in 1995
they were the recipients of the
presidential medal for lifetime
achievement in the arts bestowed at the
white house by president and mrs clinton
what else
can be said and now i'm speaking for
myself finally
of two great hearts
to paraphrase walt whitman
they contain multitudes
artists actors writers activists library
lovers members of the community
neighborhood country world
national treasures but still very far
from being relegated to a museum
please join me in welcoming mr ossie
davis and miss rabbit
this is
please do
thank you so much
for that extended version
of our life and our lives together
we found
after many years
how to survive with such a burden
[Music]
of accomplishments on our shoulders
we've learned to act as if every word is
a damn lie
and do you know what
as time goes on it gets to be more and
more
not quite true
[Music]
it's of course a great pleasure
to be here
at this place
on this occasion
and you might be asking yourself how is
it that aussie gets
to uh
show up on
the dais with all these lovely ladies
we're surrounded by ladies and we are
honoring the accomplishments of one of
the greatest of us all how did olasey
get involved in that
well somebody has to speak up for dk
so we thought a little type casting
might be an order
however as much as
tk is
a hero
in our family
uh
beating women
was never an option
in our family as tk headed
my mother's
102
she's still capable
and ruby
ruby got her basic training in the
streets of harlem so she's quite capable
our two daughters are very authoritarian
in their outlook
so in my family
we negotiate a lot
zora neale hurston has meant of course
as much to us
as it has meant to all of you and her
value her fame her worth
grows more and more every day
her particular challenge to ruby and to
me
was that
in addition to making us
lovers
and appreciators of her works
even at the time when a lot of
us had not yet been introduced to her
we ourselves were storytellers
now how do you present
the works of zora neil hurston who was
herself a master storyteller
as storytellers
one of
the problems you have to deal with
is that
some of the dialogue some of the
language
appears to us in a form that we call
dialect
what does the performer what does the
storyteller do
when you come to that passage
which we all recognize is dialect
and ruby and i
had said
talk to ourselves ask ourselves
how did we resolve this problem
it took research it took consultation
it took common sense
it took
extending
through our own imagination
the conditions out of which
dialect
of the language that we're talking about
grew up
in the first place
we have to understand
what dialect is
why dialect is
and why dialect as applied to the black
experience
poses such a problem for us
well
in my research
i
decided
that i would
do a little research of my own
and uh
out of my investigation i came up with
some very
very
startling
uh
details here uh this
that i'm reporting to you now
is the preliminary results of my
investigation
i have forwarded this to the
library of congress and
all of the big encyclopedia people
i haven't heard back from them but
i'm sure it's taking them a long time
to get it but
let us get into it
the english language i said is my enemy
ruby hates the title i think she also
hates the work but we do have a marriage
to maintain so
we negotiate
all right a superficial examination of
rosie's thesaurus of the english
language reveals the following facts the
word whiteness has 154 synonyms 44 which
are favorable and pleasing very pleasing
to contemplate as for example purity
cleanness immaculateness bright shining
ivory fair blonde stainless clean clear
chased unblemished unsolid innocent
honorable upright
just straightforward fair genuine
trustworthy
only ten synonyms so whiteness appear to
have negative implications and these
only in the mildest sense gloss over
white wash gray one pale ashen etc
the word blackness
has 120 synonyms
six of which are distinctly unfavorable
none of them even mildly positive among
the offending 60 was such words as
blood blotch smut smurge sully be grime
soot becloud obscure dingy murky low
tone threatening frowning for bowdoin
foul
forbidden sinister painful dismal
thundering evil wicked malignant deadly
unclean dirty unwashed foul etc
not to mention 20 synonyms directly
related
to race such as negro [ __ ] nigge
blackamore etc
when
we consider the fact
that thinking itself is sub-vocal
speech
in other words one must use
words
in order to think at all
we will appreciate the enormous heritage
of racial pre-judgment that lies in
weight for any child born into the
english language
any teacher good or bad white or black
george gentile who uses the english
language as the medium of communication
is forced willingly to teach the black
child 60 ways to despise himself
and this white child
60 ways to aid and bit him
in the crime
who speaks to me in my mother tongue
damns me indeed
the english language
in which i cannot conceive myself as a
black man
without at the same time
debasing myself
my enemy with which to survive it all
i must continually be
at war
now
but
not only
when we came from africa invited to come
over and participate in the great
democratic experiment
it cost us a great deal we had to leave
much behind our identity our language
our heritage
and you know the nationality
the tribes of which we belong
and
so
this is
a language which didn't like us in the
first place as you can see
but in order to make sure that we got
the point
the slave communities passed laws
forbidding
people to teach us to read
and write
and uh therefore
we not only were at the mercy of a
language which didn't particularly like
us
but we couldn't
by law do any better to thoroughly
understand what our options were
and then there was a third way that we
were punished
not only did they pass the laws to keep
us from becoming educated and
understanding
they waited to see what we did with our
own
linguistic necessities
they waited to see
as we created
our own creole
or our own yiddish
or our own
language of inner communication
and as we created that they was there to
prove that the creation itself
was a prime example of how stupid we
were
and this creation this language
language creation
which as i said before we had like all
peoples constructed to serve our needs
as we spoke it as it was heard was met
with derision
and in many instances we
responded
by being ashamed
of the language that
we used even to communicate one with the
other
now language is not
the only
uh way by which
we were
deprived of a sense of self-importance
and value
the other ways
we call stereotypes those are
images
and
the very stereotypes we created
to conduct
our own spiritual
business
we needed to create a language
that sometimes white folks couldn't
understand
and
some of it's come down today
a lot of you know what pig latin is and
even in the house there's some old phase
in here
and uh
but
by that
oh faith
it's just a word
but what it meant for us was that white
folks were the full you see and you put
the oh
you use the the input of a on the
innovative a sound and then you talk
about ophe and the rifles wouldn't know
you were talking about
you know another way this interior
language that we needed
for our own purposes uh was used
but these very stereotypes that we
created
what co-opted by the powers that be
you know our dances and our language and
our singing you know what were taken
over by the white establishment
brothers who went out and put black on
their faces and went around before the
world
saying to the world hey i can be blacker
than the black folks look at me and
daddy rice and all of those who created
jim crow and a whole tradition
minstrelsy grew up and was one of the
foundations of the theatrical experience
in america
based on laughing
at our incapacity to express ourselves
in the king's english
we were clowns we were fools with
buffoons and there were white
authorities on stage
who put it on there put black on their
faces to prove
that point
so what i'm saying is
that zora
and langston and all of us
who write truly about the black
experience
have to write in the language that
already discounts
that experience how do we rescue the
truth of our experience
from the stereotypes which have been
imposed upon with those negative values
we have to
go back to the original intent to the
idiom
to
determine
what was trying to be expressed
and then we as performers must come up
with fresh ways
to express that truth
without at the same time
denying it or destroying it we have to
give it a new validity a new way of
expressing what it was
i
met the challenge in my own way when i
wrote really victorious
by taking a lot of the set stereotypes
instead of denying them
i feel them as full as i could
of the truth and the energy and the
humor you know
that god had given us as a laughing
people
and presented to the world
not the negation of the stereotype but
the affirmation to the point where
the stereotypes serve dysfunction to
remind us
that there's a lot of our human
activities that are absolutely
ridiculous
and sometimes quite dangerous
segregation being one
and so
our authors
you know in representing what we truly
are
must include language that we sometimes
use you know to deny ourselves to deny
our own validity
a lot of jokes that we tell ourselves
when white folks are not around
listening to describe our condition why
because we found
you know that cowardice you know is a
good survival strategy sometimes you
know it's nice to confront the enemy you
know and die like a man but sometimes
you don't feel like dying that day
so
you have to front the enemy in a
different kind
of way and so it is
when we
read
zora
when we project her words
we try and do it in the spirit in which
it was conceived
and
we we
we would hope that those of you
who love to read and read aloud and want
to share these with your children will
not back away
from the so-called dialect you know but
we'll put the idiom the true meaning
back
into it because
even the dialect even those negativities
that they use to punish us sometimes
have sparkle have humor and have truth
now
[Music]
zora
was among other things
one of the world's
great
storytellers
and
she left us
with many of those stories she honored
them she respected
the the quality of them she went south
on a journey
you know to bring them to the fore
to save them for us
and she reminded us that
if we if we forgot
those stories and what they truly
contain we would ultimately forget
who we were
and ruby has come up with a concept
where she has a tribe
of people
and and with a storyteller
and the storyteller
loses his memory
and the tribe doesn't know
who it is
until the storyteller is restored to his
full
function
so
we've had
much fun much success
we produced at howard university
uh a
play
uh based on
the works of zero new harrison that
ruby gathered together and put into play
form it was called zora
is my name
and was ultimately done on pbs
uh that's our
way of
caring of sharing with the word with the
world the words of zora neale hurston
and though some of them those words may
sound strange to us at first may still
elicit laughter from us at first and
maybe some of those words elicit the
laughter of self-derision
remember
that means that there's still a problem
of communications that we
have got to resolve
we can't count on we shouldn't count on
zora to do the whole thing her job was
to save it to cherish it to put it there
for us to deal with so we who are
writers now we who are creators now must
accept the language as she gave it to us
with the playwrights
and the writers authority and mandate
to take this and make it true to the
people
as they are today
and now
i'd like to bring forth
the other part of the team
i think ruby's going to
share with us
some of zoro's
own words and
nobody can speak
zora neil hurston better than zoro
herself
oh my
thank you
oh
thank you aussie i i really did learn i
i really did learn a little something
just now listening to you
and i learned a whole lot listening to
the ladies
and um
uh and i'm delighted to be here this
afternoon part of this
this gathering to talk about zora neale
hurston
um i i i
i grew up in this neighborhood i came
started theater in this very building
what in another part used to be called
the american negro theater so i feel
like i'm home
and i um
i
i went to
school and college here in new york city
went to hunter high school then i went
to hunter college you know
struggled to to get there to stay in
there you know because you had to have a
certain average to stay and hunt a high
school and go to hunter college
and i decided to major in
theater and acting but then i changed my
mind because
i feel well that i might not get enough
it occurred to me while i was in college
that uh
i don't i didn't i couldn't be a starlet
and go to hollywood and do great b
movies and then you know grow up and do
grade a movies and be a movie star in
those senses it occurred to me one day i
mean racism occurs to you
because
bottom line fact is you're human and
then suddenly
but it occurs to you what being
a little black girl means and you don't
get in the movie magazines and the
stories are not about you and you get
hints even in harlem where you know it
was a great place to grow up i think
that things are different when you are
black
and so i decided what i would major in
literature and uh
a major in english so i and during the
course of that i studied
studies and literature
english spanish
um
uh
italian
literature
everything but african-american
literature the term really wasn't part
of my vocabulary even though i'd done a
few plays i've begun to work in the
american eagle theater it didn't occur
to me um you know literature for black
people
uh books about us it wasn't until i
graduated from college and really got to
working with the american naval theater
but the the the field opened itself that
i discovered writers who wrote about me
and the people i knew about blackness
about being black and in america about
about being about slavery and how
the whole world of blackness came
reached another dimension after i get
got out of college and i felt like a a
like a kid in a candy store who never
had tasted candy which way do i jump
which which way to go
and uh
as as luck would have it i began to
discover black authors i'd heard about
langston hughes and and i'd and i'd read
some things of paul lunch dunbar my
mother had been
an elocutionist and she wanted to uh be
an actor she worked with richard b
harris and and in in and one of indeed
in green pastors
when he was playing the lord
to make a long story short
i eventually discovered
zora neale hurston
and
i i have to skip around because life is
so peculiar i had no idea
that i had known this woman all my life
in in a sense and and and in reality
because when my house burned down our
house we had a fire it didn't burn down
we just had a bad fire about in 1988 and
our son was helping us to
gather some precious papers
and he comes across programs he says and
he brings me he said ma
you were on a program with zora neale
hurston
it was said so in the literature these
were things that had been my mother had
saved for me because she used to send
all our poetry to the amsterdam news and
the people's voice and everything we
wrote she sent somewhere
my sister and myself
and um
and then she belonged she's part of the
james weldon johnson literary guild and
they gave
prizes and and so there were a couple of
occasions where i had once
he showed me showed me two programs
where i i had shared
uh i've been on a platform with zora
neale hurston and i hadn't remembered
that i hadn't known that
it hadn't occurred to me so
so one great big hole in my life is that
i might have known this woman and i
didn't
the circumstances prevented me from
knowing her
and and from and and from and knowing
who she was and knowing all about her
that because i had started on platforms
of course when i was around 11 9 10 11
years old my mother she thought of that
we we um the church gave a program and
we were on it we the library had a
contest
and we were in it
[Laughter]
the elks the elves are rhetorical
contests she hired people to train me to
be part of that
so so i was constantly you know in these
contests
but what i'm trying to say about zora is
once i discovered her uh she it it was
like um
she liked something with it just latched
into my life and she she never let go
and i became and she led me to all the
other authors including these ladies who
sitting here i fell in love with her on
television not long ago and i came in
the middle of a program that is uh that
is um asha because
uh and she she she was talking about a
book
that she had written and i said oh i see
i heard this this author on on on
television last night but i don't know
who she was they didn't repeat her name
valerie wilson we she helped us we we
worked together too on something so i
mean
um
uh
also um john oliver killens became one
of our dear friends we tried so hard to
and i began to seize everybody i could
think of to say oh you must there must
be a film about this work
that's how roots got on by the way i
have to brag about that because i met a
man uh uh
um
in in in the soviet union where they
went to buy films and the union sent a
lot of people there
and i was one of them and i met at david
walper who was a documentarian among
other things anybody
everybody i suppose knows who he was i
didn't
but when
and so we he began talking to me and i
uh about films and about books and i
talked started talking about books and
authors and of course i started talking
about zora and margaret walker and jono
and i had i have also i have a
collection of
screenplays that i write from these
books nobody asks me
i'm hoping that someday somebody will
i'll have a screenplay just
just in case
just in case so i i had in my mind i
began to tell
um
so uh i when i asked david walper
what did he do
never will forget that
and he told me that he was a filmmaker
and that night it's in my room came a
packet of material about like that he
was his brochure or something
the next i could hardly face him
what had he done i mean the question was
what had he not done
and so therefore we got around to roots
and uh and some months later he called
to ask about that book i was telling him
about
that um
that um
um
alex haley had written i said well it's
not written yet it's um
it is not written yet it is he's still
talking about it
and uh so so i only mentioned that to
say zora has
in all the authors i've fallen in love
with
so many of them have been inspired have
written in the introduction inspired by
zora zora neil hurston
um
and then when i went to
um
went to my first
um
no
i was thinking about
lucy i've been there no three times i've
i've been there
to the uh lorna hurston festival i have
my ver i have my zortonia hurston room
now
which which is which the
most dominant thing in that room is a
flag from the first zora neale hurston
uh festival
but i came across in my reading not only
material written by alice walker and
mary hill in washington and oh
many authors began that i began to read
over through the years about zora
presenting her works her these stories
that she told
and um i met
i came across this biography by robert
hemingway
and at one of the festivals i met rob
i met professor hemingway
he had he was a doctor him in way he was
the president of the university of
kentucky i think that's
and he
and he was a professor of literature
uh an english professor i think that was
his field
he he happened after he had gotten his
degree
before he no i don't know if he'd gotten
his phd by then
he happened to hear about zora neale
hurston
he said he here he was he was indignant
i had studied literature from
artists writers all over the world i had
never heard of zora neale hurston and he
couldn't forgive himself for that he
spent the next years eight years of his
life
researching zoro neil hurston and wrote
an absolutely stunning biography
the most definitive one i think in the
in the whole of those that i've read
certainly far more um
far more far deeper than
zora permitted us to see and the one she
wrote about herself
and of course we as we do books with
legs
but anyway
i won't go on with that
just to say that we we share
we share a love
zora took us to other authors zoro
of all the things i've been asked to um
to put on tape i do books on tape i'm a
word worker i call myself
and i read books on tape i've read zoran
their eyes were watching god twice once
in a bridge version
thanks to my very dear friend
a woman who had heard me doing one of
her stories
and some other work on a platform and
suggested me
uh when they when it was being talked
about in the publishing world of putting
zora neale hurston on tape i got to read
the abridged version and then just this
last year i was asked to read
this unabridged version
what what an exciting assignment it's
one of the proudest things i've ever
done
also i discovered something about myself
uh all the the the dialect the ca the
the characters the men and the women all
of them
one of the joys of being an actor is
when you can
open
yourself and permit all these people to
come through i knew these people
and i knew i know and i know that the
dialogue dialect she made us appreciate
i love the way she made us appreciate
the musicality of words
and she she she taught us about rhythms
of people
i i could go on and on about zora even
the things that we're about which we're
not aware i also recorded mules in men
but there was i had another feeling
about mules in men i didn't select the
stories
and as i look back on it i was sorry
because there's some of the stories
zoro let it all hang out
and i i wasn't ready for it all to hang
out
[Laughter]
and and so i i i often wished i had um
edited
chosen the stories that best most
appealed to me
when you're not accustomed to this
dialogue of oppression
you know to this dialect of of a denial
this the that mirrors um uh um
with withheld education
when but but zoro
the concepts she showed us
and the imagination of the people that
about which she told the stories we see
these in their stories and we see these
stories in the broken tongue
we see minds we see genius
we
we see joy we see
tremendous
capacities in terms of language the
capacity to use to invent a language so
i came gradually to love the dialect
and to unders because the the dialect
showed me who the who the person was
so i i had a marvelous time
uh in terms of um
of of the dialect after
uh
after a while and and
the nuances and in the the insights and
into character
and um capacities of all kinds we've i
was planning to read something here but
everybody referred to the last chapter
and um
and i um
i i i
any any any place you touched or you
could just
live
you could go and set up housekeeping
thank you
and so i i'm going to to um
just share a little bit
um
about
after she has killed tea cake
and those men
who feel that she must be guilty you
know
uh and they go to court
and um
they become convinced
that she did not
that they come to believe after a while
why
they come to believe in the love to put
it um
um
that to put it mildly
and they and she is acquitted
and uh and one of the men said oh you
you know they weren't them white men
wasn't gonna i'm gonna do nothing to no
woman that looked like her
she didn't kill no white man did she
but long as she don't shoot no white man
she can kill just as many [ __ ] as she
please
yeah
yeah the [ __ ] women can kill up all the
men they wants to but you bet not kill
one of them the white folks will show
hanging if you do
well you know what they say
a white man and a naked woman is the
fresh thing on earth
they do as they please
and then zora takes us back to um
um
i'm good
i i just
you know janie buried tea cake
in palm beach
she knew he loved the glades but it was
too low for him to lie with water maybe
washing over him with every heavy rain
anyway
the glades in its waters had killed him
she wanted them out of the way of storms
so she had a strong
vault
built in the cemetery at west palm beach
janey had wired to orlando for for money
to put him away
tea cake
was the son of evening sun
and nothing was too good
the undertaker
did a handsome job and tea cake slept
royally on his white silken couch among
the roses she had bought
he looked almost ready to grin
jamie bought him a brand new guitar
and put it in his hands he he would be
thinking of new songs to play to her
when she got there
and something his friends had tried to
hurt her
but she knew it was because they they
loved tea cake and they didn't
understand
so she sent sop word and to all the
others through him
so the day of the funeral
they came with shame and apology in
their
faces
they wanted her quick forgetfulness so
they filled up and overflowed the 10
sedans that janie had hired and added
another to the line and then the band
played and tea cake rode like a pharaoh
to his tomb
no
expensive
veils and robes for janie this time
she went on in her overalls
she was too busy feeling grief
to dress like grief
well i'm going to skip to the end of
this
and she's got her feet in the pan
soaking her feet in some water she's had
a hard
and she's had a hard
a journey
and
jenny stirred her strong feet in the pan
of water
the tiredness was gone so
she dried them off on the towel
and she's talking to phoebe she says now
that's how everything was phoebe
just like i told you so
i'm going back home again and
i'm satisfied
to be back
again and i'm satisfied to be here
uh
he says
i was satisfied to be away and i'm
satisfied to be
back home
i don't bend to the horizon and and back
and now i can sit here
in my house
and
live by comparisons
this house ain't so absent of things
like it
used to be before tea cake
it's full of thoughts
especially that bedroom
i know all them sitters and and talkers
that's people on the porch
don't worry they their guts into the
fiddle strings till they find out what
we've been talking about that's all
right you can tell them they're going
they're going to make my ration because
my love didn't work like like they love
if they ever had anything
then
you must tell them
that love ain't something like a
a grindstone
that's the same thing everywhere and do
the same thing to everything it touched
but love is like a sea
it's a moving
but still in all it takes its shape
from the shore it meets
and it's different
whatever show
no
go get
there was a finished silence after that
so that for the first time
they could hear
the wind
picking at the pine trees
it made phoebe think of sam
waiting for her and and getting fretful
think about that room
phoebe hugged janey real hard and
cut the darkness in flight
soon everything around downstairs was
shut
and
janie mounted the stairs
light in her hand was like a spark of
sun stuff
washing her face in fire
her shadow behind
fell back and headlong down the stairs
now in her room
the place tasted fresh again
the wind through the open windows
had broomed out all the fetid feeling of
absence and nothingness
she closed in
and sat down
combing the road dust
out of her hair
thinking
the day of the gun
and the bloody body
and the courthouse
came and commenced his to to to to sing
a sobbing sigh out of every corner of
the room out of each and every chair and
thing and commenced to sing commences
sob and sigh singing and sobbing and
then tea cake came prancing around her
with where she was and and the song of
the sigh flew out of the window and lit
in the top of the pine trees
cake
for the son for sure
of course he wasn't dead
he could never be dead
until she herself had finished feeling
and thinking
the kiss of his memory
made pictures of of love and light
against the wall
here was
peace
she pulled
in her horizon
like a great fish net
pulled it
from around
the waist
the waist of the world
and draped it over her shoulder
so much of life
in its meshes
she called in her soul
to come and see
sora
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
we have a few minutes for questions and
answers and before we do that i want to
tell you
that there is going to be a cocktail
reception on the mezzanine and you are
invited to join us i want to thank
harper collins
for this event but
especially i want to thank harper
collins for publishing this wonderful
addition um with a brilliant um
introduction by edwie stanticup
uh there will be copies of the book
available for sale on the mezzanine at
the
party so
do you have a question
see
if you do please
okay
okay
[Music]
hi first of all i want to say thank you
so much this was just a beautiful event
and i appreciate all of you coming out
and celebrating zora neale hurston's
memory and i just want to give you a
hand definitely out those lovely
um
i just i want to ask a question um
because right now in my studies i go to
university of virginia and we're looking
into the harlem renaissance and i've
heard of um something that i i'm not
positive but i think hurston and hughes
uh were involved in called the niggerati
um
have you all heard of that suppose that
she i wanted us to know more information
about that actual organization and
things have you all heard of that
organization
i think it was just
it was just a term they used wasn't it
you know they didn't
they had a magazine you know that they
had i forget then it wasn't making the
fire fire because they had a magazine
that's why first they had a magazine
called fire i imagined i managed to get
a couple of issues by the way
uh
and i that's where i first heard that
about the negarati yeah
but um
there was that defense of that you know
um
there was um
uh
the the purity of language and
expression i think was a something that
was very
much talked about during during lengths
langston during the time of langston and
uh zora and miss mason you know
uh
um
zora believed in they
i just have to say this because azor ah
believed in
the people that she wrote about she
didn't want to clean up the clean up
clean it up or straighten it out or she
wanted it to be just as they spoke it
and she was that felt that way too about
music
you know she said she had a
slightly in the blue hat yes
that's what
one for asha
and one for bell hooks the first one for
asha i read the prisoner's wife
and how is rasheed
i think that uh he's doing as well as
can be expected it's a it's a difficult
time for him right now
people in prison can often be um
they live at the hands of prison
administrations
and there's virtually no due process
for those incarcerated and so he's
dealing with that now but he is as he
always has been a very strong and
resilient man thank you for asking
the second question is for
bell hooks
i read sisters of the year
nobody should read that book
because
uh
it shows you should respect yourself
you should care about yourself and other
people will care about you before you
even go out you should look presentable
and um you talked about your family
forgiveness and love
and i enjoyed it thank you very much
question
question yeah
just i just want to say i was very very
inspired i'm visiting from london i feel
very privileged to be here and i know my
girlfriends in london are going to die
the panel of uh i mean just in terms of
some of the points they touched on
um
gave me a lot of food for thought and i
just want to ask everyone on the panel
individually i work um with young people
in london
in particular um
young black men and young black women
um
bill you spoke about the lack of love
that we have for ourselves as women
and for each other um
and that's something i fight against on
a daily basis in terms of how the young
people i work with treat each other um
any kind of words or you know
kind of
wisdom if you like to take back
to try and reach home because sometimes
it feels as if you're knocking your head
against a brick wall and thank you all
for what you said
do you mean that specifically in dealing
with the question of us not loving
ourselves
properly
i mean i think that that's a very big
question and how you sort of
encapsulated uh for for the time here i
know that one thing that i've learned as
an organizer
and an activist is the most effective i
always
was was when i embodied the spirit i
wanted to see other people
display
and so if somebody was ugly or
unjust or
in any way you know brutal
toward me
or toward other people
i never won the battle
being ugly brutal and evil toward them
and so what i've learned is that no
matter how people try to be i have a
path i have a way i want to be in the
world in a way i want to live in the
world
and i and i try to personify that you
know in in every moment of course i
break i try to do it privately
and curse them out at home or whatever
but
for the most part
no matter how i'm being treated i try to
remember
you know how i want it how i want to be
treated and i think it especially
works well with young people and i think
truly if young people know that they are
respected just like us
you know if they know they're respected
and cared about
time because it's taken a lot of time to
put all the hatred there
but it works itself out
i think there's no question oh do you
want us all to answer that briefly is
that or i think there's no question that
you children do respond to love and that
if you if you treat them with respect
and you really do
empathetically under listen to them
first of all i think also it's important
for children to read and understand
about their particular history to write
their own experiences i think can be
very very empowering for many children
and to have those those experiences
appreciated and understood
and but i think that what you're saying
in terms of giving particularly young
people children what you want to show
show them what you want of what is good
and they
more often than not will respond in the
same
i agree with that and way what i do and
that's what i say but when you're in a
school system that is racist inherently
and you have teachers that are not yeah
i think how do you get how do you say to
kids
even though it's bad even though they're
racist even though you get a real deal
you've got to hold on to that and still
be true to self i used to be a teacher
and i think sometimes if children are if
you can teach children about the nature
of racism um and from a very early point
and help them understand what is
happening to them and why a particular
teacher is treating them this way then
if they know about it then it doesn't
affect them and it doesn't take the give
the body blows that it would ordinarily
again it's always about
helping children understand who they are
in the system and the not in the nature
of the bee so to speak
well it seems like there are a lot of
people with questions so i don't think
we all need to address this one because
we'd be saying similar things so um
maybe
over there
you have your hand up
i just think we're so honored to have
lucy hurston here today
i just wanted to emphasize while we're
embracing this new release that the
cover that's on this book is the
original 1937 release
so in that respect it is very special
all right we're not sure on who the
artist you know who the artist
were that were involved in this but this
is the 1937 this is the closest we're
going to get to the to the original uh
creation that embodied the work of
sauron
thank you
um
question
i also want to thank you all it was
amazing saturday afternoon i have two
quick questions the first is
orlando patterson writes
a lot about the 400 years and so many
years of hatred and depression and how
it affects especially the black male
in america i wonder
um
if
to what extent it affects
the black male more than the female and
in light of that or
directly certainly and indirectly and
secondly
to what extent august wilson
speaks to the relationships of
that men can have among men in earlier
plays and
how that will raise up
uh where sort of
assuage that
oppression and hatred
i don't really think it's very useful
for
us as black people to talk about
whether something has affected us more
what's more meaningful us for us is to
talk about what we need to do for our
healing as black males and females and
how that healing has to be specific to
what our particular wounds are because
we know that black males have specific
types of wounds that have to do with
masculinity which have to do with what
it means to have a penis in a
patriarchal society that's very
different from being female so we're not
interested
in terms of love we're interested in
what connects us
not in sort of having this hierarchy
because that's really something white
supremacy has always imposed on black
men and women to divide us this whole
question of who is suffering more rather
than how do we tend to the suffering
that we have
[Applause]
one more question
yes
hi i also just wanted to thank you guys
for a really enlightening
afternoon um
i'm a filmmaker and i
i had a friend who was doing a
documentary about zorniel hurston
and she was telling me that a lot of
zora's papers were actually
um
you know controlled by this white patron
charlotte mason that zora had and that
she was actually having trouble
getting access to a lot of the writing
that zora had done because all of her
papers were actually still
within
the family of this this white patron
which completely blew my mind and it
just made me really
question
you know the the type of control
that this white patron had in terms of
how zora got published when she got
published what
what was allowed to be published and i
was just wondering if any of you could
sort of speak to
um
could speak to that
and could speak to sort of like the
effect that that had on zora as a writer
and in the actual
work
in terms of what was actually written
um
the controller observes work rests with
her family
the control of all of her work is here
okay there is no white patron the state
or control or
implications of them in the estate okay
so number one number two realize that
zoro was um gifted enough crafted enough
if you will to straddle the line to
right to survive and to right to
persevere
okay so what she did for mason right may
have been and in fact was accepted than
what she did for the legacy right but
everything that's penned by zora is in
the control of the estate
right
[Applause]
oh yes
and also in those when zoro wrote you
know there were no grants you couldn't
go
you had a patron
am i right you you didn't you couldn't
get a a fellowship or things like that
so this was how she could could live to
that's how she could make enough money
do you know what i'm saying so that she
could she could write there was one
other thing
uh
um anyway
that's all i wanted to say
thank you
i have another wonderful bit of
information that's just been handed to
me and that is that this fall harper
collins is publishing a collection of
folk tales gathered by zora neale
hurston that has never been published
uh this will be the first news or neil
hurston title in over 50 years so um i
know that you will watch for that
and you'll find it
in your local library
as well as in bookstores
i would like to
thank this extraordinary panel
for this afternoon's
discussion
i i just have one more i have one more
thing to say i have just one more thing
to say i find it incredible that a film
has not been made
that their eyes are watching god is not
uh has not been a film i i i i i maybe
i'll leave that alone
but you know if but i'm but i'm thinking
if it's it because it is a unique and
and beautiful book in american
literature
yes yes
first trust that our film is in the
works okay oh great great great
and second if there are questions about
uh publications or permissions um the
estate is well represented in the hands
of victoria sanders literary agency you
can go to victoria sanders.com you can
go to um harpercollins.com you can go to
hurstonresearch.com
um but the estate is well represented
and and permissions and requests have
been coming through the agency so i know
that in general the public knows uh that
the works of zorovia hurston are
represented and controlled appropriately
oh great thank you
i just want to thank by name once more
miss ruby d mr ossie davis
miss bell hooks
miss valerie wilson wesley and miss asha
vandali
thank you so much
thank you for being here and join us
upstairs
[Applause]
[Music]
and on book tv
[Music]
bell hooks is a writer professor and
cultural critic
she's the author of over 20 books on
topics ranging from feminism in
ain't i a woman and feminist theory from
margin to center
to racism with killing rage
and class in where we stand
bill hoax has also written books for
children including happy to be nappy
the recently published communion is her
third inquiry into the meaning of love
and for the next three hours bell hooks
will be taking your phone calls and
emails as our guest on book tv's in
depth
bell hooks i want to go all the way back
to the very first sentence you wrote in
the very first book you got published
1989
this is what you wrote at a time in
american history when black women in
every area of the country might have
joined together to demand social
equality for women and a recognition of
the impact of sexism on our social
status
we are by and large
silent
is that true 13 years later absolutely
not we have found our voice
and how have you found it well a lot of
it has to do with people like bell hooks
michelle wallace lots of people who help
people to recognize that we didn't have
to remain silent audre lorde pat parker
i mean audre lorde's incredible poem
where she told us that you know we may
be afraid to speak but if we're silent
we're still afraid we have to speak
we see all the writing coming out of
those early years of feminism from black
women
often focused on the question of having
a voice
you know angela davis coming into voice
as a person speaking on behalf of ending
sexism it was almost like a kind of
swell of not unlike you know what maya
angelou describes in her i know why the
caged bird sings when she begins to find
the words to say what she needs to say
and and that's happened and now it's
it's we've got to say more and
differently um but we're certainly say
having our say
how many of your most recent books have
been about love
three three i'm the high priestess of
love and now my new children's book on
love will come out in a few months but
so you've gone from 1989 to a book about
feminism to to 2002 now to books about
love in the last couple months
where are we moving in there how has
this transition happened or is there a
transition i'm always organically moving
with the culture as a whole
in the sense that you know the themes
that are coming up both in my life
among the students that i teach among
the neighbors that i talk to
and partially you know the question of
love kept coming up in lots of ways i'm
single my own search for love my hope to
find love and partnership
the struggles with my ex-boyfriend that
sort of you know
inspired the first all about love book
and you know the obsession with love
i've had for a long time like many
writers i often hold an obsession for a
long time
and then i began to to write about it to
explore it
what do you mean an obsession well you
know something some kind of something
that has obsessed you since you were a
kid or like i mean
all about love new visions begins with
me talking about how i felt about love
as a child and how that thinking about
love um sort of you know like a little
thread woven through your life i think
all of us
have those threads that are woven
through our lives and um you know james
hillman the wonderful
union psychoanalyst has written a lot
about
life maps and how
there's a real different life map for
people who know
what they want to be in childhood and i
think because i decided as a child that
i wanted to be a writer
holding on to those threads and those
obsessions and seeing them grow has been
very much a part of making me who i am
i'm looking for this uh the area the
book on what you where you talked about
waiting for the decision on whether you
were going to get tenure at oberlin
college do you remember which book you
wrote about that in that's a hard one
connie yeah i know i have it but i'm
asking the question because you said you
knew for a long time that you wanted to
be a writer and yet you talk in that
book about how waiting for the decision
of whether you were going to get the
tenure and the reaction that you had
after you found out you got tenure and
how your sister talked to you about it
you want to tell that story
i can't tell that story connie because
all of a sudden i can't remember it i
mean this is one of the hazards of
having written
more than 20 books is that
things come and go in terms of how i
felt about it but i i know that when for
me
when i was about to get tenure i felt
really
trapped and i've been struggling for a
long time with the question of how free
can we be as writers in this nation
when we're in institutions and so that's
an ongoing
another ongoing question issue for me
how much when you're in an institution
does it silence you does it
frame the nature of your voice and what
you say
and that has always been something that
has haunted me and of course now i teach
a very small amount so i can be free to
write whatever in the times that i'm not
teaching let me refresh your memory i
found it it's it's in teaching it's in
teaching
yeah this is this book right here but
i'm gonna have to open it because i
gotta read uh in the weeks before the
english department at oberlin college
was about to decide whether or not i
would be granted tenure i was haunted by
dreams of running away of disappearing
yes of even even of dying these dreams
were not a response to fear that i would
not get granted tenure they were a
response to the reality that i would be
granted tenure you go on to talk about
um the fact that teaching was one of the
three
things that your mother would have
accepted for a black girl to become and
that your sister tried to tell you that
this was why you were really turning
your back on teaching right because i
was never meant to be a teacher but a
southern black girl i think that's
really the point because i think that
particularly in the south of the 50s and
and the south of my mother's girlhood
you know one a black female could
especially from a working class
background could either be domestic
worker or
a teacher but there wasn't a lot in
between and what my sister told me
reminded me and that's what why it's so
great to have sisters of which i have
five is that
you know you you
i never really wanted to be a teacher
and it's been an interesting thing
because i've been such a exciting and
and good teacher and yet it hasn't been
what i what i initially thought as my
central vocation
here she is folks what age
49 49 now you'll be 50 in september yes
and what's when how old were you when
this picture was taken
oh the teeny tiny one but
that's me what
maybe nine months or maybe yeah yeah
that bald headed cute baby where were
you
sitting on mama's bed in hopkinsville
kentucky
what was it like growing up in
hopkinsville
well you know i think that there was
something really special about growing
up in you know hopkinsville kentucky i
consider myself a southerner and part of
uh what i like about growing up in a
small town where you were known and in
our town um you know a segregated black
world where many black people
were achievers is that
that whole sense of of having a sort of
central
relationship to the environment um i
write a lot about the the sensory
landscape of my growing up you know
vegetables mama's cooking my
grandmother's house all of those things
that were so
deep and i
live part of the time now in new york
city and in the south and i'm reminded
of that on hot
humid days where
you feel that you can taste and smell
you know the world around you the kind
of south that tony morrison writes about
in the bluest eye having an effect on
your senses and your capacity to
experience color
who are these people if you look up
there
that is bell hooks
my mother's mother's mother
and people forget and then there's my
grandfather this is your grandfather
here daddy gus
whom i write about in bone black i say
his smells fill my nostrils with the sin
of happiness with him all the broken
bits and pieces of my heart come
together again
my very very very favorite person from
childhood
daddy gus
my mother's father and the woman you
were named after yes well
you know bell hooks is a pseudonym and
it's more that in fact as a child when i
would speak harshly back to adults talk
back
um they would say to me you must be bell
hooks's granddaughter you know
and
um
that sense you know i've written so much
about that that sense of coming from
a legacy of outspoken women because
certainly my mother's mother was a very
outspoken
woman
and that sense of that being a natural
part of of who i am
how old were you here
oh there i'm in my 20s
i think i'm about 25 or 26. and you
chose this as the cover for one of your
books i chose that as the cover for one
of my books because it was around
the time that i was writing that book
and um it's a retrospective
you know it was a reissue of a bell
hooks classic is what they called it
feminist theory from margin to center
and um you know i've always liked that
picture because of the dreamy eyed
nature of it you know here i was writing
this sort of hard-hitting provocative
you know
feminist theory but for me it was all
about dreaming i've i often have seen
myself as almost you know like a
scientist in a lab i'm very much a fan
of madame curie and of the way that she
worked and i've always studied the
biographies of women who do exceptional
things and so there i like that photo
because it has that dreamy element and
of course it has the militant afro look
um that
i was so into in those times and so
you know it it's it
took me a long time to want to be
um
you know on the cover of books to have a
photo of me but i liked i liked having
that cover with the eyes
now tell me about your hair does your
hair
i want to say mirror you because you've
written about happy to be nappy
i mean how is how does your hair change
over the years reflected you i guess i
think my hair uh changes just really
reflects the moods
of the moment i tried to bring a photo
of my sister angela
who is the person who braids my hair
most often and
and she braided it for the show today
and i said to her you know i wish that i
had had a photo because she's such a
wonderful braider and um
for me hair is about loving ourselves
just the way we are you know when i
signed the book happy to be nappy my
first published children's book
um
i always sign it to loving yourself just
the way you are
um people
here's the cover of it
tons of money you know black americans
all americans trying to change ourselves
especially females
uh often to be something other than what
we are so you know for me it's been a
great thing in life to be able to
enjoy having natural hair and different
shapes and different styles
and to see you know little children
having that that sensations through
reading happy to be nappy
when you well
do you remember when you wrote this or
this was your first published children's
book you said right but that that
implies that you had written others i
had written other children's books
before you know happy to be nappy just
sort of came to me
you know out of nowhere you know it
starts my mother
miss roosevelt
is a wonderful cook
and just the other day i called her and
she was making the fried pies that she
used to make you know in our girlfriend
that we would come home from school and
there'd be these incredible smells
coming from the kitchen and mom would
you know
call us her girl pie so that one of the
things that you see in almost all my
writing is some fragment from my real
life experience like girl pie the fact
that this was a sweet name that mom had
used and that i now she's the star of my
children's books for for girls you know
girl pie and um so that there's always
that sense of something about the
organic life that i've lived
coming through
in the books
you set your mother's picture next to
you i absolutely did can i take it and
show it to our viewers absolutely tell
us about her
tell us about mom yeah
well i just said that she's you know an
incredible cook
which i think is really um i i don't
know i'm still one of those people she's
still alive she
she informed me however that she would
not be looking at
book tv at its regular time because
she's a church going woman
mom and dad they've been married 50
years
and
mom is
someone i think who really
you know tried hard to be
the embodiment of the perfect 50s woman
and um you know
i think that she and i were always at
odds
because i always wanted to be more like
my grandmother whom i couldn't find a
photo of mom's mom baby whom i truly
write a lot about and um you know i
think sometimes in families things go in
weird cycles like i am very much i feel
my grandmother's child in the sense that
my grandmother was very very um
into her opinions and into her um you
know
way of seeing the world kind of an
outsider and a renegade and that mom is
much more of a of a person who likes to
conform to the status quo and um who
likes you to be more feminine in the
traditional sense and all of those
things
we're going to open up our phone lines
and invite our viewers to join us bell
hooks is our guest for in-depth this
month and she's going to take your calls
for the next two hours and 40 minutes so
the phone lines are open here's how you
can join us
202-585-3880 if you live in the eastern
or central time zone and
202-585-3881 if you live in the mountain
or pacific time zone you can also email
her a question we'll get on as many
emails as we can today at booktv
cspan.org
one email came in early and this is i'm
sure question you get every time when
and why did you decide to use all
lowercase letters in your name well i
before we start with the email i said um
if we're going to show mom's photo we
have to show dad what happened today
okay i got to get i'll give you guys dad
and i'll talk about okay that's why i
you i wouldn't leave your father out in
the london case sure um bell hooks
you know is my great grandmother's name
and early on in feminist movement we
used to talk about it's not important
our names it's important what we're
saying and so we often chose pseudonyms
and as many people know women chose
pseudonyms in the 19th century but for
me i chose the lower case as a way of
kind of de-emphasizing
the sense of of
who's speaking but often it hasn't
worked that way because it's made people
obsessed with the lower case
you weren't able to find dad's photos i
think is this it
no that's me and my brother from my
children's book about boys is dedicated
to dad his picture is him um in the pool
hall oh of course i can i've got that
that handsome guy as i went through him
i didn't know which one it is i know
because he he looks so young and
handsome i would have said this was your
brother
like that dad is an incredibly handsome
man
he was he is 80 years old we had a
wonderful 80 birthday party for him my
dad
was and is a reader and he is the person
that i write about having so much
inspiration both mom and dad were
readers but my dad had his shelf of
books and you know he was a boxing fan
and a boxer and one of the things i felt
very strongly that my father came up in
that generation of working black men who
were thinkers who felt that
even though no matter the job you did
you really needed to read and think and
be politically aware
so i tie that love of reading to dad
and where did he help you out in terms
of your decision to write a lot about
feminism
by being a real patriarchal man i mean
that's that's that's the downside of dad
you know dad is like so many men in
america who are patriarchal that as he's
aged he has become more mellow
more loving and you know i think that
when we have
that tremendous revolution of feminism
that really affects men men will not
have to wait
until they are getting close to death
to be able to explore their feeling
sides and to be more emotionally aware
first call for bell hooks is lexington
kentucky
hello sister
hey peace and blessings you had
opportunity to see you in lexington in
kentucky a few years ago
and i had a marvelous experience there
and i wanted to say i appreciate your
books which i'm certainly infusing
myself with at this moment a very
beautiful sister and a very wonderful
writer
i'm the proud father of three children
one son jimmy and two daughters joslin
and jasmine and i'm curious as to how
the i can infuse them with strong
feminist theory and i can i can sort of
get out of their way as a father and and
make them to know and understand what
what strong feminist theory is and i was
curious as to whether you could answer
that question
that's a wonderful question
any man can help his children
be strong in terms of opposing sexism
because what feminism really is is a
movement to end sexism sexist domination
and oppression so when children have a
dad who shows his respect for himself
as a man not as a sexist man but just in
his love of himself
and his respect for for the women around
him
not dominating non-violent
mutually engaging in partnership
you that's the best example any man can
give and of course to add to that the
reading and study of feminist theory of
women writers all of those things
let girls and boys know the kind of
non-sexist world we want to be in
lafayette indiana
are you saying lafayette louisiana maybe
no oh okay is it louisiana yes thank you
go ahead well i'm jacqueline cevas i'm
president of the veteran feminist of
america last week at barnard college we
honored we had a salute to feminist
writers who changed the world i looked
all over for bell hooks
phyllis chesler everybody gave me her
name but you know we do the work of 10
women or 10 men at one time and we just
can't reach everybody and now i see her
on television she's so beautiful and
wonderful and we'll just have to give
another one to it
to honor her and i tell her that
bill
will be calling you and but we need your
address so we can get in touch with you
easily thank you so much one of the
things that people forget is you can
really get in touch with any writer by
writing to the address that's in any
book like if you write bell hooks care
of harper collins
i know i write some of my writers you
know when i read a writer whose book i
love
i
try to write to them to tell them what
this book has meant to me
because i think all writers feel good to
know that that we have readers who are
moved by our work and i do that the same
way i'm telling audiences i go to the
book and write care of the publisher and
we have this the address of your
publisher at the bottom of your screen
if anybody wants to write to you next
call is olympia washington
hi bell
i'm listening
and i met you recently at the evergreen
state college i'm the one that walked
into the auditorium and you waved me
in any event after reading your book um
sisters of the young black women and
self-recovery i've since taken with me
the notion that
of course um as students and as you
attest to in your book um
black females haven't
peculiar struggle in terms of the
academy my experience has been no
support in graduate school can you tell
me a little bit about
what sustained you i mean you talk about
how you had this how you created a sense
of self in your home
in terms of keeping community with you
living in a predominantly white
community but at the same time expecting
of the academy market
some sort of support what would you
advise
i think in any environment we're in
there's always someone in that
environment who will nurture us and one
of the things i constantly advise
students of of all races but
particularly black female students is to
search out those people who can be that
light for you that guiding light and but
you have to be willing to look in
unexpected places because often
i've been helped or guided by someone
that if i had been following you know
set notions of who could be a person who
helped me i would not
have have been with that person or
followed that person
and i think that we have to be radically
open is the phrase i use a lot in
teaching to transgress and looking out
for who will be our support you know
throughout
our time together today i'll probably
talk about my own spiritual practice
because that's been something that has
sustained me
from girlhood on into the present day as
when
in moments of trial in moments
particularly during graduate school when
i felt all the constraints and conflicts
of a racist sexist environment you know
being able to to look to divine spirit
as a place where
those things of race and gender fall
away and then we can we can
dwell
in a sense of pure spirit so i
feel like whether you're a believer or
non-believer to recognize the value of
cultivating a spiritual practice
whether you know you're as alex walker
says a worshiper of trees or or or what
have you but to know that
spirit matters when it comes to
sustaining ourselves through difficult
times
has your
spiritual path paralleled with your
political
path oh absolutely i mean in my
spiritual path
um you know has always been one of of
searching for a way out of what i often
call western metaphysical dualism the
idea of good bad um you know inferior
superior those that kind of western
metaphysical dualism that's the root of
domination and for me it led me first to
you know
islamic mysticism the sufi poets because
i started as a writer as a poet to rumi
to kabir and then you know to buddhism
as i met poet gary snyder
when i was 18 years old and he
turned me on to buddhism in a whole new
way i had been interested in buddhism
from reading jack kerouac and the beat
poets and so you know buddhism was so
much
about the whole question of right action
as opposed to good and bad and
a notion of punishment about a notion of
how
how do we center ourselves so that we
can be guided
to bring peace and harmony in the world
and to to confront and end suffering
i want to show the cover of the upcoming
book what is it
my new book is called rock my soul
black people and self esteem
because as i went on the road with the
second in the love trilogy salvation
black people in love many many people
would say to me you know we can't even
get to the question of love because we
are grappling with
the issue of basic self-esteem
and i think that you know this is one of
the ongoing struggles collectively
african-americans confront
you know within a context of cultural
context of white supremacy how can we
build a healthy self-esteem that is
essential to well-being
this is the book salvation that you
mentioned tell us about the covered art
that cover art again is a picture that i
saw years ago
and i loved it and i i had it in a
postcard
and then when i was getting ready to do
this book
i thought that immediately of this image
the title of it was seek what is true
and it was a photograph taken by a young
white woman photographer constance
larabee she died
just
shortly before the book came out and i
was so sad that she didn't get to see
her photo but this but her work is at
the smithsonian she was an incredible
young woman photographer who came here
to this country from south africa
and lived until her death but i love
that image of journeying of walking down
a road
that sense of
of the trajectory of african-american
experience because you know philosopher
cornell west has written a great deal
about the idea of african-american
experience as an experience of exile
that we are an exilic people and so i
love this cover because it has that
sense of the diaspora that black people
have traveled and that our psycho
history encompasses so much south
america central america brazil
africa so many places that are part of
the the the interstices the makeup of
what we think of as african-american i
want to
ask you to explain some more of your
covers but let's get to some more phone
calls we'll come back to that lexington
kentucky again go ahead hello i'm a 27
year old black female who grew up in
glasgow kentucky which is also a very uh
rural place and i had the benefit of
knowing that there were
there was a bell hook to it you know
made it out of kentucky and done such
amazing things and it's been a lot
easier for me of course even growing up
with that little background what
specifically for you kind of i guess
inspired you or just
gave you that inspiration to
make it out in a way well i have to go
back again to the church and i want
connie to show again the cover of rock
my soul because sure on it is the image
of another kentuckian that is
muhammad ali's fist
on the cover of rock my soul
and um who was then cassius clay and you
know there were the clay family in
hopkinsville kentucky and we we were
often grow grew up hearing that
you know he was a distant cousin but i
think that for many kentuckians
the church black kentuckians
particularly for me my church was a
place that not didn't just
teach religion but also cultivated
creativity i wrote my first poems to be
published in you know the church
magazine
so that
i see
for many many people in small towns like
hopkinsville kentucky our church was not
just you know about learning the bible
it was a kind of cultural center of
learning about self-development and
self-actualization
so i can see that as a central part of
of my aspiration it was not so much to
get away from kentucky or from my
community but to to become someone who
would have
much to give back to that community and
to give back in the arena of racial
uplift san francisco you're next
greeting bill hey julie i just wanted to
tell you that i'm absolutely inspired
and basically in love with your work and
your spirit and simply because
because i believe that
you simply tell the truth about where we
are in the world and there are two books
in particular that have just
served as a guiding force in my life and
that's sisters of the young and real to
real and basically they've helped me
shield myself from the way that white
supremacy tells our story or at least
the distorted version of it and i wonder
about
how
we as black people and basically people
of color in this world can deal with how
the world is being covered right now
through
the american media system i mean i feel
like i get drained and watching how you
know stories tend to be one-sided and
based in white supremacist ideology i
wonder how you would advise me to
basically protect my spirit from that
one basic advice that i offer all black
people and i i think women of all races
none of us can watch television all the
time
especially you know standard television
and be self-loving because the messages
that we receive
from it often are negative messages
about race about gender so that i really
encourage people to explore alternative
media you know earlier today i was
talking about what i like about c-span
and not just because i'm on it but
because it gives us a voice like today
to be a writer who can really talk about
what you're doing as opposed to little
sound bites and i think that part of
what we have to do as african-american
people within the context of imperialist
you know white supremacist capitalist
patriarchy is be vigilant
about the kinds of images that we
take in you know when i went to the
store to buy books for my nieces and
nephews and i found that a lot of the
children's books oriented towards black
kids i thought were negative in their
values they were sexist they were overly
didactic they weren't playful and cute i
thought well okay let me see what i can
do here so i think that it's not only
that we be vigilant about the images
that we allow ourselves to consume but
we allow our imaginations to make us
cultural producers so we produce the
images we want to see the caller
mentioned real to real it was published
in 1996 what was it about real to real
is a analysis of film a lot of my work
has has looked at the cultural critical
work is the impact of media on how
people love how people think how people
change themselves
it you know i
really have
written a great deal about spike lee's
work and and that's in real to real it's
one of my favorite books because of its
sort of
juxtaposition of that whole sense of
media not only being something that
portrays culture but that makes culture
you have to tell us who's on the cover
here now who on the cover is me that was
the first time i allowed myself to be on
the cover and i thought i was being
clever because i had on my shades and i
had my hair out and many people really
didn't recognize it as me because they
were used to me wearing my hair more
like it is on communion where it's just
pulled back
baltimore you're next hello hello you're
on the air thank you
bell hooks my name is lornell catches
butler and i want to tell you you have
such joy on your face and i don't have
that joy
and here is a
short form that i want to dedicate to
you is very short black woman show some
joy on your face by l'oreal custis
butler
right now black woman you are worthy of
your earthly presence
in the beginning of god's earthly
paradise
the snake of satan deceived the black
mother of all humanity
but did not kill her in defeat
rising from a fallen moment
black eved eva dispelled her gloomy fate
and showed some joy on her face
joy endurance
reigns assurance
of life survived
in the downtime of poverty and spiritual
despair
right now black woman
you are worthy
of your earthly presence
i want to thank you bell hooks for
having that because so many of us black
sisters are walking around
in urban america with such pain and
despair that we don't look happy
absolutely i write about this
particularly in rock my soul black
people and self-esteem that's coming in
a few months from simon schuster i'm
very concerned with the question of what
it means to be positive and affirming
and lots of black women you know are
besieged my students used to say to me
well why do black women look so harsh
and yet when i have them go out and do
the work of finding about the statistics
about our health the impact of heart
disease the fact that we're more likely
to die of breast cancer
disproportionately to our numbers we
have hiv and aids so many statistics
that when they gathered those statistics
they could begin to see you know how
much money we don't make
as a collective group all of those
things they begin to think differently
about why when they would see black
women on the subway or on buses or in
menial jobs people weren't smiling
but you know of course i say in my work
is that we have to smile i mean techno
han the vietnamese buddhist monk who
influenced me is constantly saying how
we have to smile to our pain because it
it we have to think of that joy as a
space of resistance
a place where we are not allowing those
forces to dehumanize us so thank you for
the poem and you know i think we have to
to let our light shine constantly and
see that as an act of political
resistance and spiritual affirmation
from elizabeth gayley this email would
you comment on the general reluctance of
black women to become involved in
feminism
many black women fear
losing
the what little connection we have with
black men as it is and and white women
too i mean we have to remember that
white women on mass haven't been that
engaged with feminism either but
certainly there have been more white
women involved in the movement but there
are many more white women in our nation
i think that black women have been
reluctant to critique
sexism
uh and engage the movement but i would
change it
because we really do want to be in
harmony and struggle together with black
men and many people see feminism as
something that immediately cuts you off
from black women but from black men but
what i find is more and more black women
recognize is that the forces of of male
violence male domination i urge people
to you know think about the new works
that are coming out that talk about
black males being
more violent often times
more anti-gender equality in their
emotional lives they maybe think it's
fine for women to go out and work but
then want to dominate in the home these
are some of the forces that are
really in compelling black females of
all ages to think differently about
gender
and
as a consequence about feminism
next call san diego hello hello good day
hello you're on the air hi bill huck's
pleasure to talk with you
uh it's a wonder to talk to a living
legend uh my question is what was your
inspiration for writing uh happy to be
nappy my inspiration for writing happy
to be nappy was that i would first of
all like african americans to stop
spending the millions that we spend on
hair care products to straighten our
hair and spin it on think tanks and
spend it on public education and reading
and literacy but we can't begin to do
that until we start loving ourselves
just the way we are you know there's a
line in happy to be nappy where it says
um you know it starts off saying girl
pie hair smells clean and sweet
it's soft like cotton
flower petal billowy soft now when i
wrote those lines and then little girls
come up to me and little black girls and
they say you say our hair smells like
flower petals
no one's ever said that you say our hair
feels like flower petals and you can see
how a book can have a transformative
impact it's very different from a kind
of book that will say oh your hair is
ugly but you should love it which i
thought the other nappy hair book was a
very to me a very anti
child affirming book because it starts
from a negative i think we have to start
from an a positive that we have to not
be overly didactic and the children will
get the message as as i get so much
feedback from children for happy to be
nappy it's all about self-love and
self-esteem
i can't remember which book it is but
you you write in one of your books about
people coming up to you and wanting to
touch your hair
absolutely and i like it once a day you
know i like nothing better than the the
people i love and the men in my life and
my male partner when i have one to enjoy
my braids touching and caressing because
that's all part of black people loving
ourselves loving our bodies and rock my
soul black people and self-esteem you
know i just talk about the intense body
hatred that continues to be a part of
black people's reality in the united
states do you think it's only black
people
absolutely not but i think that when you
add race to it and then we you add the
fact that we don't control
the production of our images and that so
many of those images are negative i mean
i think black people suffer more within
white supremacy i mean in andrew hacker
in his book two nations and
all the writers who've written orlando
patterson's work clearly there is a
special hatred white supremacy reserves
in our nation for black people and it
comes out in what we expect and how we
view black people how the images are
created so i think that that's why black
people have struggle you know i mean
when i finish my dissertation
and was going on the job market i was
encouraged by my my white
advisor not to wear my hair in braids to
the interview i mean more black females
have people tell us what we should do
with our hair so that it's not natural
when we go for jobs so clearly there is
a whole way in which being black within
a white supremacist culture and i i want
to tell audiences that i use the phrase
white supremacy often instead of racism
because white supremacy allows us to
encompass our own internalized racial
self hatred because
black folks who are growing up in
completely all black environments where
they're being told they're not light
enough their hair is not straight enough
that's that's white supremacy but it's
not coming from white people so um i
think we have to think about that
overall concept and how it frames our
nation very few i think it's one in 20
people are born blonde but look at all
the people that are dying their hair
blonde and many of us used to know that
commercial is the true blondes have more
fun well studies show that it is because
in a white supremacist culture blondness
stands for all those sort of nazi aryan
you know ideas of superiority and women
find you know white women that if they
die their hair blonde even if it doesn't
look that great they get more attention
their scene is more more interesting and
that's white supremacy at work in our
daily lives next call flint michigan
hello hi professor hux uh pleasure to
talk to you i've enjoyed your writing
teaching to transgress in particular
i had a question about standardized
testing with that phenomenon becoming a
national issue could you speak to the
whole question of standardized testing
and our ability to
touch upon cultural diversity and and
respect that in the classroom well i
think that first of all i want to just
give praise to all the teachers in flint
michigan my sister is a teacher in flint
michigan and in fact it's coming there
and going into her public school
often that i talked with kids about love
so flint always has a special place in
my heart my sister gwenda who's one of
my biggest supporters and
for me
the issue of education starts you know i
don't think we just can come in and
challenge standardized testing first and
foremost we have to stand on the right
of every child to learn how to read and
write because
a lot of kids from
you know disadvantaged backgrounds do
poorly on standardized tests because
often they have not had the basic skills
to begin with so it's not so much that
the test is the problem it's the the way
they've been prepared from the very
beginning so i i'm really ready for a
revolution in public education that
wouldn't make standardized tests
unnecessary because all children would
be adequately prepared here's a picture
of you on the subway in new york city
that was me going to work at city
college where i worked before i took my
more recent position i loved riding the
subway up from the west village where i
live
to city college and i often would ride
home with my students and we would have
our books or be discussing on the subway
and i just love that sense of education
moving beyond the classroom moving from
you know uptown to downtown i'm a
tremendous you know fan of langston
hughes and my whole sense of moving from
you know the west village up to harlem
and i hear his poems in my head that
whole sense of movement and rhythm of
black life you know that was there in
his dream deferred poems you know when
he says i said to my baby baby take it
slow he said i can't i can't i gotta go
a certain amount of traveling to a dream
deferred so that image of me on the
subway captures my my own journeying and
my traveling from the world of the west
village to harlem to
uptown to city college um and i like
that image very very much let's show
people where you live maybe this is a
good time to kind of get into where you
right
in the west village where so many
writers where baldwin
has lived
where um
you know margaret mead and norman mailer
and eudora welty for a time i mean
i feel that i'm in the midst of this
whole sort of psycho history of
wonderful uh writers in in the west
village and i've sat there with amina
and amiri baraka and talked about that
history and
it's it's a wonderful place to live in
the city i always feel like people say
how can you be without nature and of
course my street in new york is
tree-lined and pretty wonderful
this is the inside of your home where
you are these are these are sculptors on
the floor
made by
a buddhist artist in upstate new york
buddhism is important to you yes it is
and they have the heads have different
things on them questions like who what
when where why there is my buddhist
altar with orchids i'm a big orchid fan
in my other my home in in florida i have
many orchids
growing they are such a hearty and
beautiful
plant and i think of them when i think
about african-american
culture the the beauty of something that
endures and sustains and and
re-resurrects itself so what's it like
to write in the place where you live
well
when
people want to come and see my study
it's the world's smallest study
i say i've always written it in very
enclosed spaces
and so um i think that i i kind of like
to shut out everything i say it's almost
like a monk cell
that i write in um you know and i just
sort of sit there i hand write a lot
um you know when when i
knew that uh c-span was coming and gonna
take a look at my writing world i
thought well there won't be a huge
computer you know i handwrite and then i
use a small laptop to put things on um
so there's your writing area there it is
coming from another room because it was
so small it's i said it's about the size
of a big closet
um
and i sit there and work is it
enveloping kind of feel it totally is an
enveloping kind of feel it you know i
think about you know i wanted so often
as a child i fantasize being a nun or
you know that sense of contemplation
because i feel that first and foremost
in my life
i'm a contemplative you know when people
ask me how i would define myself i
always say that i'm a seeker on the path
that that sense of spiritual
journeying is the core of my identity
and being
so that space of enclosed space of
contemplation of silence has been
tremendously important to me as a
thinker it doesn't look like a very
comfortable chair bill
you know i've written about having great
sex in that chair and many people have
said it's not a very comfortable chair
that red chair i love the color red
in fact um
you can show people my my latest book
that just came out when i remember i see
red
and it's all um
you know about memory and um
the paintings that i did for a show in
san francisco
but that little chair is is quite
comfortable i've written all these many
many books sitting in that chair for me
but people are always telling me it's
very hard but maybe that's part of that
whole sort of would-be saint part of my
personality that likes the austerity and
the rigor of it
so
asleep in the dream house of red heavy
with memory caught in the gap awakened
shrouded silk what are you trying to do
with this book well in this book
let let me let you let me uh read
something from it sure in this book i
try to infuse the whole idea of personal
and political memory um i just i
i um
particularly for example have a painting
in here that's in honor of the four
little girls who were killed in
birmingham
cynthia denise
addie
um
because i feel that so often people
forget those little girls and they
forget their martyrdom so i wanted to
have
a piece of art
that would show their images
denise carol addie and cynthia and it's
1963 so it kind of shows
something about my own development as a
thinker and a writer the the merging of
the personal and the political
there are images of me as a girl and
then there are the images of these
little girls who were really martyred so
that people like me could be free let me
see if i can read the text that went
along with
this particular image it says sin is red
not black
not the color of forgetfulness
we remember in red that will not come
clean or wash away
red bleeding into pure space
changing the tenor and tone of our lives
and i wrote about that because this was
one of the experiences that galvanized
angela davis politically the bombing she
just couldn't believe she was in europe
at the time that in her country the home
of the free
that anyone would bomb churches and when
we talk about terrorism many people
forget about the you know white
supremacist terrorism that we've lived
within and
the end of this book has a long passage
about memory that says this due in
remembrance and it says we are born and
have our being in a place of memory we
chart our lives by everything we
remember from the mundane moment to the
majestic we know ourselves through the
art and act of remembering
memories offer us a world where there is
no death
where we sustain loss
by rituals of remembrance
so that informed my my
my whole sort of love of the color red
and you know connie you've just sort of
shown
the audience how the bell hooks mind
kind of works that we went from that red
chair
which the writing place but i also
defined it as an erotic space and then
we took that color red into
my own creating of art and this book and
that's kind of how i think of my mind i
always didn't tell people i'm like
michael jordan
as a basketball player that i make these
leaps
big leaps big jumps and i'm all over the
place
moving
my mind and in fact i've just done the
bookmark for next year's
national children's book council and my
poem on the bookmark is all about the
mind moving leaping across the page
leaping through a book being changed and
transformed by the art and act of
reading bell hooks is our guest let's
get some more phone calls san francisco
you're next hello hello my name is
vanessa and i'm calling from san
francisco i just want to let you know
how important your books and your
writings and your words have been in my
personal journey through white supremacy
i mean sisters at the m helped me
survive
college in oppressive new haven
connecticut
bone black helped me understand kind of
my relationship with my mother in a
context i kind of felt your words when
you spoke of your mother in that book
and teaching to transgress is actually
something i'm
really exploring and going back to right
now because i'm going to be a teacher
this fall an elementary school teacher
and i'm sitting here thinking about how
you said
that white supremacy reserves an
absolutely special hatred for black
people and i think that that is one of
my motivations for getting into
education because i've been working with
prisoners for the past two years and i'm
wondering if you can tell me some things
maybe three things that you think we as
black people should be working to
instill or reawakening our children i
love that you're talking about personal
and political memory and i think that's
part of
my idea of how i want to go into the
teaching profession
well thank you for reading all those
different bell hooks books and i think
you embody what i think is the ideal uh
way to approach a bell hooks the other
day at the l.a book festival someone
said to me which book should i read
first and i said that you should choose
a bell hooks book according to your need
and you just articulated how different
books satisfied certain needs three
things i would instill i would say first
of all positive thinking
the belief that everything is possible
and third
the constant you know
giving and receiving of love
because i think that if we can love if
we can create if we can use our
imaginations we can not only endure we
can triumph and we can resurrect and be
born again in whatever we need to be
born again
into we'll come back to this a little
bit after we take some more calls but
this is your the memoir
and you'd been writing a long time
before you dug into this well you know i
began to write bone black and there's a
picture of me i always say if you know
you could see that hard forehead i said
here is the intellectual thinker at work
i'm looking at some kind of red
background toy
i mean constant red background i mean
i've been telling connie that i'm always
involved in the design of my covers
because you know i think to have this
little black girl on the cover is
important when tony morrison wrote the
blues eye and i should tell audiences
that i wrote my dissertation my phd
dissertation on toni morrison
one of the things morrison said was that
she had not she looked around her and
there were books with little black girls
at the center of them when she wrote the
blue side which i think is one of the
great all-time
books
that we can read and
for me putting those images and writing
this story one of the things i found
connie as i was go getting older
writing and thinking i i read a book a
day
was that i was beginning to forget
memories and so i thought well i want to
write a memoir of this time in my life
because i don't want to forget those
memories and anyone who's read bone
black knows that it's written really
in terms of powerful memories i always
tell my students that if you meet
someone and you want to get to know them
what we usually do is we share memories
and we share the powerful memories that
have shaped us as i do in bone black the
memory of my grandfather
the memory of
you know
things that happen as a girl
a little boy accidentally shooting
another little boy the things that stay
in our minds
both that and wounds of passion have
been important memoirs for me i'm a big
fan of memoir writing precisely because
i feel there's so much about women's
lives in general and african-american
female lives in particular that we have
yet to fully understand and we've had so
many black writers die like for example
zornell hurston we don't know why zora
nels hurston did not have a child we
don't know if she was infertile we don't
know anything about that aspect of her
life and we will never know and that's
for those of us who are literary
historians who are you know
literary critics that not knowing is
incredibly painful
we want to know about her choices in the
way that we know about virginia woolf's
choices and yet we'll never have that
information you know i'm waiting to see
in biographies of lorraine hansberry
you know audrey lord these are women who
have both been you know powerful
influences in my life they're also
lesbian women writers um we really need
to have more
of those stories tony kate bombard
incredible black woman writer who died a
friend of mine and comrade you know we
there's so much about her life that we
don't know and if we're not willing to
speak the truth i mean early on a caller
said that my books are very important
because they tell the truth and i
thought about
when she said that how much i've
emphasized openness and honesty is part
of healing in the love books and sisters
of the yam and in the new book rock by
soul
another call swat swarthmore
pennsylvania
hi um i was wondering if you could speak
briefly to the rise of third world
feminism and
possibly where you see a space for
solidarity between
women in the west and women who are
involved in the feminist movements in
other parts of the world
and where you see that space possibly
without
sort of an imposition
into
different cultural understandings of
what it is to be a woman
well first and foremost if we want to
stand in solidarity as women in the west
women and men in the west committed to
ending sexism and patriarchy with other
countries we have to be willing to
genuinely learn about those countries
and what's happening in them as opposed
to
bringing our assumptions about the lives
of people
to those countries i'm really a big fan
of the work of zela eisenstein who has
written a lot about
our
engagement with women in other cultures
where we impose western cultural
imperialism and i think it's really
really vital for solidarity of any kind
that you go to people where they are
that you listen to what they have to say
about their experiences and that become
the place where you bond
you know one of my really good friends
is the writer filmmaker theorist
feminist theorist
trinity menha
vietnamese woman and when we first met
again we shared both the experiences
that we have in common but that also are
different and are different
positionalities because whenever we talk
about bonding cross culturally we have
to talk about what does it mean to open
yourself to different ways of thinking
um to allow that what we think of as
freedom
might not be freedom for someone who who
has a different sense of the dailiness
of their life what does it mean to learn
how to respect
those differences i think that
international feminism third world
feminism requires of us a larger
understanding of what it is to be
working against sexism in the world
because you know the truth is if you're
in a country
where masses of people are starving
the feminist issue that you may be more
concerned with is how to feed people
rather than how the guy in your life is
treating you
and so i think that part of that respect
of other cultures comes in being able to
put things in a holistic perspective
here's this email from alicia turman in
new york city she writes this i am a
black woman in my mid-20s and am
developing as a poet and a writer my
first question to you is do you feel
that you are sometimes preaching to the
choir i try to talk to my contemporaries
about self-love self-respect and doing
the business of the black community and
it seems to fall on deaf ears do you
have any of the same issues and how do i
get them to hear and feel me well first
of all
i want to go back to what buddhist
teacher pima children says start where
you are and we have to go to people
where they are i think whenever we're
talking about how can i get people to do
something we are usually
um
you know
starting out from a wrong positionality
it it really has to be how can we
connect with people where they are and
if we want to share something that can
help people change
then that's what we have to
do not not feel that we can change
someone or that we have what's right i
mean you have to know someone to you
have to know a situation to know whether
you have the answer for it also i think
one of the hard things of life that i've
had to grapple with is that you may
share knowledge or information with
someone and they may be resistant at one
point in time and it may actually come
back to them and help them at another
point in time i can't tell you how many
readers say i threw that bell hooks book
in the trash can or i threw it against
the wall but then i came back to it
later when i felt a particular need and
it opened up something for me so i think
that we have to remember that that the
work we do may not manifest in a reward
reward immediately but it can have
positive impact down the road we may
never even know that memphis tennessee
you're next with bell hooks
hello you're on the air ma'am hi um
miss hooks i was this channel surfing
and i saw you um talking about black
hair
there was this wonderful book called
napoli ever after i think the artist's
name was wright johnson who just
she was the first one to introduce this
topic um i'm a 30 year old mother and at
the age of 28 i was diagnosed with
breast cancer and of course i went
through all the chemo and everything and
i lost my shoulder length hair but what
was so odd about that was i wasn't upset
um about the cancer
i was upset about losing my hair and
i mean i just i was upset about losing
hair of course after reading that book
that kind of put things in perspective
we hold as black women we hold so much
of our self-image on our hair and i have
a daughter who's going to be six on
thursday and already she's starting you
know to look at the old little girls the
ones with the long silky class because
of course she had my rich my original
hair you know very thick hard to manage
and hard to control but now that i look
at it um
losing my hair was the best thing for me
because that's the only thing i
connected is
you know as being a woman i didn't like
anything else about you know about
myself but my my hair was proof that hey
i was a woman never mind the fact that i
had a daughter and other things to show
it and i um i just totally agree with
you i mean the media bombards us with so
many images of you know long silky hair
blonde hair you know they're selling
contacts and this that and the other
thing memphis thank you very much
well i think first of all we have to not
talk about our hair as difficult to
manage as difficult to control because
you know i look at many of my white
women friends what they go through and
dying and and but they don't talk about
their hair negatively even though they
may spend hours getting that dew that
comes out looking pretty natural i think
black females have to change how we talk
about our hair we have to see talk
differently about the hours it may take
to comb out hair that's nappy but we
those hours can be seen as joyous they
can be seen as time as a kind of
meditation it's how we talk about it and
frame it that has the impact on children
if you're telling a child any parent
that they should want to have their
natural hair when you're then talking
about it negatively you're creating a
space of contradiction we have to come
up with new ways as malcolm x says new
ways to see ourselves we have to look at
ourselves with new eyes yeah colt
washington
good afternoon miss hooks i used to
enjoy reading you in z magazine i was
wondering if you could uh tell me what
what's going on with your relationship
with the um also
uh
i wonder what in your opinion are the um
eurocentric and patriarchal limitations
of marxism but at the same time
could you explain what in your opinion
the relevance of marxism is today in the
light of the recent enron scandals and
just the basic alienation i think that
most people feel going through the work
day as far as being completely separated
from any kind of humanity in their lives
thank you well you just named the
relevance of any kind of critique of
capitalism today
that it invites people to think about
how we're living our lives how
materialism is affecting us and as far
as z magazine i simply stopped writing
for different magazines for a while i
you know writing for magazines is a much
harsher thing because you have to meet
deadlines and so you know i'm teaching
i'm writing i'm trying to finish my book
so there are times that i just take a
break from magazines but it doesn't have
any deep
significance beyond that
and this question about marxism
i i answered that in saying that marxism
like any critique of of capitalism and
materialism is fruitful for our times
because these are times of grave
hedonistic ways i myself am very in
concern with ecology and the environment
and what we're experiencing around
electricity and water and so all of
those issues you know that i write about
certainly in where we stand class
matters i think affect us today and the
patriarchy i mean the fact is every
christianity is patriarchal
marxism the fact is we're all smart
enough as women and men to be able to
separate off
those aspects of any given thought that
are useful and leave behind that which
simply perpetuates the same old
domination i i say that about any book
we read because there are writers i love
to read but i may find that there's
racism and sexism in their work but that
doesn't stop me from
learning what i need to know from them
if you're interested in the craft of
writing bell hooks has two books
that she's written with essays about
about writing one is remembered rapture
the writer at work and the other is
wounds of passion a writing life we'll
talk more about them as the program goes
on next call is new york city
hello you're on the air sir hello
you're on the air sir go ahead with your
question hello how you doing mr my name
is akin moses i'm a student at nyu and
um i took a class last semester called
black women's rhino or clyde taylor
and um and we were talking about you
know feminist movements in all aspects
of um
of um of black culture and we
specifically talked about um
female movements and hip-hop and i was
wondering if you could speak on that you
know specifically like lil kim and queen
latifah and stuff like that and the
relationships and significance of um of
coming kind of having a rugged raw um
kind of like ghetto a little bit just um
rap sentiments that have um relevance in
this this whole feminist movement and
what it's doing for little girls um and
what it's not doing what what the
do you know what i'm saying well the
positive aspect of some female-oriented
rap for little girls is again the power
of the female voice speaking openly
about topics like sexuality or or
violence and the negative side is when
that's just done in a traditional sexist
patriarchal way and it seems like little
kim
embodies that you know i interviewed
little kim she actually her responses to
my question about love very much
inspired me
to write about all about love and what i
see is she told me years ago that she
wouldn't be
in a porn film she wouldn't do certain
things and of course we see her doing
all of those things the the boob job the
blonde hair the over sexualized image
and so i think clearly
far from being a powerful representation
for young black girls she is a negation
of of young black girls of herself
little kim in person is just an
incredibly beautiful
thoughtful young woman but that's not
how she can make her money in the
machinery of white supremacist
capitalist patriarchy so you know i
think that someone like what queen
latifah has been
a strong counterpart to that overly
sexualized sex object but you know all
women in entertainment industry today uh
fall prey to having to work that sexual
tip
and as long as we are objectifying
ourselves in the interest of economic
whoredom
we're not positive representations for
it for young girls of any race so is the
answer walking away from it the answer
is creating more interesting cultural
products and demanding
that people you know
i always say to my students when was the
last time you seen a boycott of a movie
you know when when have we left seen
people stand outside a movie and say see
this movie but
pay close attention to the sexism or the
racism you know see this movie but
remember that these aren't real black
men you're seeing that you're seeing
some racist white person's idea of black
masculinity i think of movies for
example like traffic or other movies
where black men are portrayed in
degraded and dehumanizing ways and and
black females but you know what are we
doing to counter those images to create
different kinds of images
that's the most important thing because
just
critiquing something isn't enough we
have to have new and exciting images
liberating images speaking of images
let's take take just a moment and go
through a couple of your books and ask
you about this cover art that you say
you're so involved in first here's the
one that we that we talked that we
talked about before with the picture of
you in the front and the what did you
call it dreamy eyed yeah
the dreamy eyed look on your face well
it's my rodin it's my version of myself
as the thinker
i mean as audiences can see i'm
frequently putting my hand in that
position here that it hasn't changed a
whole lot have they
and you were how old then um in my late
20s
and this one from art on my mind visual
politics now this is a monotype
and it is of my grandmother's house
my mother's mother
house baby and um i had gotten a grant
to do this project about her house now
the image in my
the actual image has a writing at the
end of it it says my heart is burning in
this house
where love was where i dreamed in the
dark my deepest dreams because shortly
um
before i did this artwork the house
caught on fire
um and my mother
had because it's a small town had been
able to go over and see the house of her
childhood burned to the ground and she
because that's really just the shell
that you're seeing
in the in the picture
and um
on the phone my mother kept repeating
that it was such a hurting thing
so out of that i created this particular
image of the house and you know the the
writing under it that said you know my
heart is burning in this house where
love was where i dreamed in the dark my
deepest dreams
this one wounds of passion wounds of
passion are those are my hands
um
there was this riff on stigmata in the
book itself because as i've been talking
about my interest in spiritual life i
read a lot about the saints and
saint teresa of avila
is a guiding mentor for us i always feel
like i have these dead mentor people
saint teresa vavilla you know thomas
merton henry now and the the spiritual
teachers and writers whose work guides
my vision and that really informed
wounds of passion
you said uh that
the photographer didn't like this no not
the photographer but one of the
publishing people that worked on it felt
that it was that it was sacrilegious and
satanic
the
fake stigmata next is richmond virginia
back to the phones
hello
you're on the air sir go ahead
yes uh how you doing miss hooks i'm a
returning college student in my 40s
here in richmond
and studying film
with an aspiration to be a film producer
and and perhaps change some of these
images for so many years i've heard
you know all of the complaints many of
which
i really feel are legitimate about our
portrayal in film
but my my question is
don't we have as as black men and women
more responsibility
to take control of these images i mean
i'm the i'm the son of a black female
and
growing up a lot of things a lot a lot
of women in my family have really been
the strong ones and i really
do my best to be
the best man that i can possibly be
but we hear so much and it's very very
very um
sad in in my college classes i'm twice
as old as most of my classmates and it's
just nothing but complain complain
complain and it seems like the pendulum
has swung the other way
and this big tent that everyone wanted
to start it out with just inclusion to
include the black man to include
all females to include the black female
and i tend to have some fairly
conservative ideas and
now i'm not included and so uh when when
in the course where we studied your book
it's a film course on black images and
we studied your book called black looks
and the instructor goes on and on about
i mean he's a great guy
don't get me wrong an excellent
instructor but there's so much about
white supremacy and
you know when i ask the question well
what about that counterpart that you
have to have when you discuss
white supremacy which is black
inferiority why can't we focus on doing
away with vet
and
not have this pendulum swing the other
way to the point where we become
almost worse than
those who have oppressed us to the point
where we want to exclude everyone who
doesn't think just like we think thanks
richman well i personally don't actually
find that to be the case in my own
classrooms or other classrooms that
blacks students want to exclude everyone
but i think people who are wounded and
oppressed frequently want to hunker down
with their own kind whether we're
talking about gypsies in the world
different jews in the world at different
times whenever people are feeling
oppressed or imposed upon they tend to
want to hunker down with their own kind
i hear that some from my white male
students who feel like they're not
getting the attention that they feel
they're entitled to as white men
within white supremacist capitalist
patriarchy you know before you came on i
talked about the fact that we can't ever
just critique images we have to talk
about the images we want to see and
create them and i gave the example of my
own self doing that with my children's
book
for example
the new children's book i have about
black boys i feel that there's
particularly
degrading dehumanizing images of black
males everywhere in our culture and
frequently in black homes so for me my
answer to that is not just to make that
critique but to start you know from the
bottom up and to try to create
new images of black masculinity
images where we can talk about what does
it mean to be loving
of black boys and to to not have a
hostile image of black boys so i think
that you're right on in saying that we
have to constantly be
re-imagining
imagining a new creating the the
different context as far as you know
critique is useful
in helping people
see
to know that what their experiences is
real you know oftentimes people will say
to me i went to that movie and i felt
bad but i didn't know why and an essay
you wrote illuminated something but
critique is never enough we always have
to imagine the world that we really want
to live in and i think that you know any
kind of dogmatism
whether from the left or the right keeps
us from that re-imagining because we
really need as i talk about in in
yearning which is one of my favorite
books on race class and gender we need
that space of radical openness
in order not just to critique what is
but to create new ways of seeing
thinking and being
you know you have so many books i am i'm
sitting here juggling back and forth
making sure that as you mentioned one i
can show to our viewers here is yearning
we haven't shown this one yet
and why is it one of your favorites
yearning is one of my favorites because
it's one of the first books on cultural
politics that i did and i feel that it
covers a lot a range of things and as
this particular gentleman
caller was talking about one of the
things i proposed at the very beginning
of yearning is rather than taking looks
at what divides us as people whether
racial divides or gender that we might
look at you know what brings us together
so one of the things i suggested at the
beginning of this book is that we're we
share yearning in common you know i
believe everyone yearns for love that's
one of the reasons i also wanted to
write about love i was interested in
topics that cut across
race gender class
that bring people together that have us
have common senses of our experiences
and how would we work from a place of
commonness to settling differences that
we might have so that i think that
that's why yearning continues to be one
of the books i love the most um
connie here's another one of them
another one of her books where we stand
class matters take a look at the cover
of this as we take the next call from
dana point california hello
good morning uh bell hooks it is a
pleasure to watch you today
you are just a light of wisdom and
spirituality and i think such a confused
world and it's just been great watching
you today
i do have two questions for you the
first was one that um just kind of
popped out and i heard another caller
talking about you know the victim that
fell to cancer and lost her braids um
i've always viewed
the braids as a symbol of strength and
as a symbol of progression
and i'm i'm not african-american i'm
actually mexican-american and i've
always wanted to to get braids and
actually made an appointment i'll be
getting braids next week but i'm
wondering if i'm treading on a territory
that that maybe i shouldn't be treading
on understanding now just um how
important those braids are to the
self-image of an african-american woman
well i'm always thrilled when i see any
woman wearing her hair and braids
any girl wearing her hair in braids and
i don't think of them at all as the
special turf of african-american women i
think in fact that as we see more you
know
different women wearing their hair and
braids it just affirms for black females
that this is a wonderful way to
to be in your natural hair with your
braids
and i i think that when i talk about
braids i'm not talking about people
going out spending their last money i
mean connie held up where we stand class
matters on artificial horse hair so they
can have long braids i'm talking about
really enjoying whether they're you know
as i say and happy to be nappy those
short tight naps or plaited strands all
let girls go running free you know um
it's all about self-love and you know
there are many people who have natural
hairdos that don't have self-love um so
we mustn't make it seem like how you
wear your hair
becomes the all indication of what you
what you feel in your inner self and in
your inner life it's the beginning i
mean self love is crucial
um connie held up where we stand class
matters and i think that's the book
there's a little white girl from west
virginia wearing the kind of little
nighties that i used to wear growing up
and i mean part of what i think is
important is that as our nation
we need to have a new
and more humane image of the poor
uh and that includes many
african-americans because we are among
the poor and it's it's all our body
image and it starts with feeling not
only that we can be feel good about
ourselves but that we can be happy when
someone else from another culture or
another group mimics us rather than
threatened i mean when people are
threatened it's because they feel like
something can be taken away from them
you know one of the things i say in
black looks
is that when we love blackness when
everyone loves blackness we won't have
to fear that anything can be taken away
from us we can have our culture shared
and know that it still
is ours in a root sense and until that
happens i think people will continue to
feel frightened or diminished or
defensive silver spring maryland you're
next with bell hooks
i'd like to ask one question
to bell hooks
have you ever
written about matriarchy have a source
or a strong base of resistance
in a patriarchal society
well i'm not i don't see matriarchy as
the answer to patriarchy and and i have
written about it in that sense that i
really believe that the answer to ending
domination whether we're talking about
patriarchy or or race or class is mutual
partnership so i i don't believe i'm not
one of these people who believe that if
women were in charge because women can
be as patriarchal in their thinking as
men and many matrilineal societies that
sometimes people called matriarchal
societies had were based on the same
notions of domination as patriarchy they
were just inverse i mean when women feel
like when women say to me we're more
capable we we're the ones who are more
capable of of giving care and nurturance
i think that that's poppycock that's
just more
of the inversion or it's like black
people saying well white people are bad
but we're really good i mean these are
the inverse ways of thinking about
domination and i'm much more interested
in us talking about what does mutuality
look like what does it mean for us to
honor the female and the male
what does it mean for us to honor
all of who we are
um in our in our holistic selves the
feeling part um the the thinking part
etc and then i think we we don't need
either matriarchy or patriarchy next
manhattan beach california
hi ben
my name is chris i'm calling from
manhattan beach and i've enjoyed
listening to you today
you seem so full of wonder and curiosity
and
full of love for this earth experienced
could you talk a little bit please about
honoring the process of writing getting
past self-doubt getting past judging the
work so that the writer can just let the
process flow well i think you just named
it all you named exactly what i tell
would-be writers and writers in distress
that a lot of people are blocked by
their inability to to just do the
writing without judgment you know one of
the things i always loved about michael
jordan as a ballplayer was that he said
that even though he was enormously
gifted and even though he can play so
well he has to practice and the same is
true of writing that writing is a craft
and a discipline and i write i know
every day um because i have to keep
working with that craft even though i
have all of these books and so you you
said all the magical things that one
needs to do
if you want to write you have to write
the more you write the better you get at
writing and of course it's important to
read that's why i continue to say to
people i read a book a day because i
want them to understand
that you know i'm not just the thinker
writer i am out of my own head it's also
all the wonderful information that i'm
learning from other writers other
thinkers that challenges me and that
causes me to to grow
from your book remembered rapture here's
a quote you say i have not yet found
words to truly convey the intensity of
this remembered rapture that moment of
exquisite joy when necessary words come
together and the work is complete
that was three years ago have you come
any closer to
being able to give words
you know of the ecstasy of writing not
at all and i think that remembered
rapture came close for me um in voicing
some of that sense of of what it feels
like to
to just be given the gift of creating i
mean um
you maybe you'll show audiences my new
book about love for kids homemade love
but um that's sure yeah um because
somehow i tell people a lot of times
things come to me in my sleep
and i wake up and i go to the the desk
and homemade love is my new book
um
about love children's book it's a
children's book but it says you know it
starts with my mama calls me girl pie
her sweet sweet
daddy's honey bun chocolate dewdrop
homemade love and you know i i i that
came to me out of where the that's why i
believe so in the divine it just sort of
came and i thought when i worked with
the illustrator who's a young black man
chain um he said to me you know what's a
chocolate dewdrop and and we were
talking about the power of the
imagination
you know the thinker and and writer even
vance erdema in talking about black
people and white supremacy and
colonization says we're not just
colonized in our minds we're colonized
in our imaginations and tony morrison
recently has been talking about meeting
children that are smart but that lack
the power to imagine so that i think
that partially we have to see how
incredible a force of resistance to any
form of domination the imagination is
but it comes from this place of mystery
you know when this little book came i i
was just
like where are these thoughts coming
from and then in some of them i told
connie i particularly like the one with
the little girl with the dog because i
want there to be images where black
children here it is you know
this is after she says everything i do
cannot be right
but all the time all hurt can be healed
all wrongs were given and all the world
made peace again and i wanted to have
this image of her with her dog um
feeling all good good feeling that that
sense of unity with animals that's so
important to interbeing and to life on
the planet but you said that
african-american children sometimes are
afraid of dogs yeah i think that versus
stereotypes i don't think it's a
stereotype i think that many we have a
psycho history of many hostile white
people using their dogs against us i
live in a predominantly white
neighborhood where i noticed that many
white people chat with other people
about their dogs but if i try to talk
with them they immediately
react with fear and animals are like you
know children if you're the parent or
the owner of the dog and you're showing
fear the dog may respond hostilely so i
think what has happened for many black
people is encountering white people and
dogs where the dog is is being hostile
has increased that sense of fear i mean
you know we all know that owning a pet
is an expensive thing so since many
black people are among the poor people
may not used to be accustomed to growing
up in a home where there are pets or
like me i grew up in a rural world where
we had dogs but they were not they were
hunting dogs they were not necessarily
pets in that
sense of
how many people think of today so i
think there is often that fear
that permeates and it's not just a
stereotype as well as you know there are
many black people who are dog lovers but
we may not necessarily see them
certainly in my neighborhood
there's much more predominantly a white
neighborhood you see people out with
their dogs fellowshipping and
and i think this is this is
a crucial thing for all kids
but particularly for groups of kids who
may not have that who may never have had
a pet and may never have one where does
the feeling of comfort come from
washington dc you're next hello good
afternoon miss hooks um i was introduced
to your works as a freshman at howard
university and now as a 25 year old
woman i just wanted to say thank you for
opening my eyes to
uncovering truth i um through your books
in reading salvation now and i just like
the way that it's helping to challenge
my ways of
challenging just everyday thinking in
society and just bless your heart and
continue to do the work that you were
meant to do
well i think that it's just so exciting
to me to think about how books change
people's lives um and i know that as a
professor
i'm teaching now at southwestern
university in texas i'm the brown
visiting
feminist scholar in residence there and
you know we work together there we're as
faculty as students as staff
trying to think about what does it mean
to teach across boundaries and it's
amazing to think about for me as a
writer i feel an a mental intellectual
who thought you know that
i'd only ever be read by a small group
of academic people to have written both
very academic books and books that are
for a more popular audience and now
children's books i just feel really
uniquely blessed and thankful so i'm
thankful to all of you the readers who
have made it possible you know for me to
write this huge range of
of books albuquerque new mexico
hi bell hoax i'm very glad to have a
chance to speak with you
um
i have a um my my past work has been in
community development where we bring
um
all community members together for joint
planning
for projects that they collectively
design and establish together and
benefit from
as a community and when i read it was
very exciting to repeat teaching to
transgress because it felt like you
apply those same
methods of participation in the
classroom where people overcome uh
previously conceived ideas and
cross boundaries and collectively or
collaboratively learn and grow and and
it's also exciting that these methods as
i as i learned more about where they're
being employed they're also being
employed in architecture and in public
health and so i i just i i would like to
ask if you
feel that
these techniques are
applicable in many sectors of social
life thank you essentially there are
techniques of teaching community at
southwestern i designed a sort of
teaching program that's aimed at
bringing us together as a campus
bringing students staff professors
together and our first theme was
teaching community because in any
organization in part
what people do is they establish
community together you learn how to
communicate you learn how to dialogue
across differences you learn how to
problem solve together so a lot of those
things came
to for me in my own practice of teaching
and
inspired me around teaching to
transgress and it's interesting because
i'm writing more and more about space
and architecture and particularly about
design because i'm interested in how we
bring those principles of harmony
and balance
the same kind of principles in creating
community to how we build buildings do
we build buildings that enhance our
lives i just did a project with the row
houses in texas project row house which
is an art project where a group of
artists black white got together bought
these little houses and made them
which is an architectural form the row
house or the shotgun shack or the the
railroad house
that was used by the slaves
that came originally from haiti and
these are little houses and they created
galleries in those houses and home for
single moms and if your people are in
houston texas they should go to the
third ward and see this project
but it's all about the question of what
does space create because when you see
those houses you see that part of what
that architectural design created was a
way for people to live in community when
you see those little black children who
are coming out of a context of poverty
but who are living in the midst of
wonderful art
who get to have a bell hooks come and
talk with them
i just had ten paintings of shacks
because i'm obsessed with the idea of
the house and architecture i also think
as a feminist thinker concerned about
the planet that housing is one of the
extreme political issues in our nation
and everywhere right now as homelessness
becomes more a norm how will we have
housing for the future and all of those
are critical questions hopkinsville
kentucky
hi bell huh
yes
uh
caller i'm going to ask you to please
turn your television set down because
we're getting feedback
thank you
i was just
calling you're still getting still a lot
of feedback gotta turn it all the way
down and listen to the through your
earpiece okay i was just calling to tell
you that we are proud of you in
hopkinsville kentucky um
i am a friend of your family and i
understand
your surroundings as far as your church
and and how you grew up and i i just
wanted to let you know that we are
really proud of you here well i'll be in
hopkinsville soon i'm all we're all
coming home to see mom for mother's day
and you know hopkinsville
it will always have its special place
for me as that place where i was first
embraced as a young thinker you know i
go everywhere
in this nation to public libraries my
favorite one being the harold washington
library in chicago but i go everywhere
every time i'm on tour to public
libraries because they were the real
center of my growth and development and
i urge everyone in our nation to support
public libraries because if you don't
have the money when people come up to me
and they say oh i can't buy that bell
hooks books i remind them that that's
why we have public libraries in
hopkinsville the public library there
are my teachers and of course the
incredible nurturing african-american
environment that i grew up in has been
really crucial
for me and sustaining to me as a thinker
and a writer i want to pull out two
emails here and i'm going to kind of
try to condense what these folks are
saying because they really go on to
other questions but they both tell two
different angles of your work and how
they're concerned that doesn't touch
certain people one uh emailer says a
good friend tried to introduce me to
your work some time back but i got
turned off to affect to feminism in
college because most of the feminists i
met and read seem to have castrating and
emasculating personalities well you know
that's one of the reasons i wrote last
year last year was a big working year
for me i came out with three books where
we stand class matters feminism is for
everybody and
one of the love trilogy books but part
of why i wrote feminism is for everybody
is that most people have a misguided
notion of feminism and i find it so
funny that you know i am such a militant
radical
um feminist thinker and so often when
people meet me and they see you know
this loving spirit because i think
visionary feminism is always about love
they're surprised and they want to say
but you're not but you're not a real
feminist because they've got some kind
of stereotype in their head and that's
why i wrote feminism is for everybody
connie so people could have a short book
a very accessible book that would really
let them know what feminism really is
and and sort of challenge a lot of those
stereotypes that come at us or you know
we may meet one individual feminist that
is man-hating that is all of those
things but you have to go beyond that
one individual okay let me go to the
second email matthew um and he says that
he's a 36 year old broadcast engineer
lives in a predominantly white area of
the united states he says when i first
read some of your works two years ago i
found your language racist and biting to
me personally but your words on feminism
a fresh interpretation and fresh
interpretation on movies and media never
left me i've since read three of your
books and feel that uh terms like terms
like white supremacist patriarchy tend
to turn a lot of white folk away from
the monumentally insightful perspective
you have of american culture are you
interested in communicating with parts
of the country that do not have a large
african-american community but need to
explore issues of gender and race that
continue to affect us nationally well i
think it's important for people to
realize that the majority of bell hooks
readers actually are not
african-americans they are white readers
so there evidently are plenty of white
people out there who have no trouble
hearing that our nation is founded on
principles of white supremacy and
patriarchy but you know i think you know
i'm a really person who's really
positive about recovery movements i'm
really a positive person for all the
critiques i would bring to bear on a a
or n a i'm positive about it because
it's one of the few places in our
country where people can seek healing
and they don't have to pay anything but
one of the things that anybody who's
dealt with an addiction and tried to
have recovery knows is that you have to
break through denial none of us would go
to a doctor and expect that we would be
healed if the doctor didn't tell us what
was really wrong with us you know if we
had a heart attack and the doctor said
oh but you're you know you've got a
splinter in your toe that wouldn't be
very helpful i think as a nation as
marianne williamson has written so
eloquently in her book you know the
healing of america we have to face the
difficult truths and use the difficult
terms and as you can see both from my
presence here and if you read enough of
my books
i try to use those difficult terms with
the kind of
compassionate insight that is not about
blaming but allowing us to own what is
our reality and change it atlanta
georgia you're next good morning good
afternoon
greetings bell my name is sheazone i'm a
writer for a rolled out magazine we have
the privilege of reviewing your book
salvation black people in love but the
reason why i'm really calling is because
i'm actually a poet and i work in a
collective with a visual artist by the
name of fran we're working with emory
university to do a new project
showcasing the beauty in women um we're
calling it sister flowers and connecting
the beauty of of all women of all
cultures with the beauty of flowers
would you be interested and how can i
contact you about reading some of your
work or sharing some of your
empowering ideas with some of our
our audience well once again you know
we've told uh everyone that you can get
in touch with bell hooks by writing to
southend press or harpercollins any any
book you have will have an address in it
and you can write bell hooks care of
that book
people keep mentioning the love trilogy
and and i wanted particularly to mention
communion the last in the love trilogy
because it's called communion the female
search for love and really is a response
to as all the love books were to
people in our nation being very cynical
about love but i particularly wanted to
to focus on
the way that we seem to be asking too
much of young women and i wanted to read
this particular passage that said when i
first saw the film version of charlie's
angels all i could think about was how
glad i was to be in my forties and not
receiving a cultural mandate telling me
that i must be superwoman in the world
girly girl on the home front and have
the tight flesh of an olympic athlete
while maintaining an ability to
submissively throw myself at the feet of
an all-powerful symbolic daddy named
charlie the contradictions in this
message are obvious no wonder then that
we have a nation of 20 to 30 something
females
addicted to antidepressants angry at
feminism with crippling low self-esteem
no human could measure up to the
standards mainstream culture sets for
them
i mean so much of my writing about love
has been trying to talk
about the way in which self-love
serves as the true basis for
self-actualization
and i say that because i think for this
is particularly crucial for women and
girls of all races let me want you to
hand me the book let me show the cover
to our viewers because we haven't shown
that yet and you explain what it is the
cover is well first of all the cover of
communion is designed by the same
photographer marsha lippman who did
remembered raptor i love her photographs
and you know life is full of magical
serendipity um when i went into a store
everybody knows that for magazines i
write about fashion and i'm a real
fashion obsessed girl and
i went into one of my little favorite
boutiques in soho and they had one of
marsha's photographs on the wall and i
thought wow that's so beautiful do you
know how i can get in touch with the
artist
and the woman was not able to share with
me and i i just looked her up in the
phone book and when i called her the day
that i called her she was reading a bell
hooks book
marcia goes all around the world
taking photos of many things but she's
she's a real many of the buddha images
you see she's taken
the photo on communion is a photograph
taken in thailand
earlier um
a young woman asked about third world
feminism i think that bringing this
particular
image is
to
to the cover i've tried to use my covers
to bring the artwork
particularly of women who have not
received the attention that i feel they
deserve to a larger public and i hope we
can show the work of artist emma amos
who did the cover of killing rage but
that explains that particular cover
but i think that book covers are a
marvelous way
to make people familiar with artists
that they may not know about and of
course
outlaw culture has the very very famous
photo of andre serrano you can tell i'm
a person who likes photographs i have my
own art collection
the bell hooks little eclectic
collection and it's filled with
photographs
um we'll talk more about killing rage in
just a minute let's take another phone
call from this one from charlottesville
yes good morning
i'm a big fan of yours and have been for
a long time and i greatly appreciate
your use of the word feminism
as an african-american and in light of
what you said earlier about having to
have a vision
of where we're going i was wondering if
you would talk about
whether you see some of the racism
within the feminist movement of the
70s and 80s
healing and including african-american
women whether you see a future
of a feminist movement in any way well
first of all i mean i am militantly and
gladly feminist today in part because of
the incredible camaraderie i found with
individual white women within feminist
movement who did indeed challenge their
racism and change and while that may not
have happened for the movement as a
whole i always tell people you know if i
have a choice between 10 white people
that are racist and won't change and one
white person who's divesting of their
racism and helping to create the beloved
community i know who i'm going to choose
and rather than focusing on the the
people that won't change i want to focus
on the person who has changed and who
can be a guiding light and a force for
other people and that's one of the ways
that i see feminism i think feminism is
the only movement for social justice in
our nation where there has been such
profound self-critique where you know
many many white women
many women of color there's been this
exchange and people did in fact change
the way they teach
change the way they write and i think
that we have to praise feminism for for
being able to do that not only that i
think incredible thinkers like myself
notice how i'm not at all modest about
my own uh sense of what i bring to um
bear to the
the table of feminist theory but the
fact is there have been so many women of
color uh who have created
the feminist theory that has been life
transforming for everyone and i think
that that has shifted the direction of
the movement and as i say in feminism is
for everybody i'm looking forward to the
day when we have a feminist movement
that truly addresses everyone i am
deeply concerned about the fate of men
and boys in our nation
i in in all my feminist theory books
i've really talked about men as comrades
and struggles so when i hear people say
oh feminists hate men i think what
feminists are you talking about the
feminists i know
love maleness love men um i want connie
to show this this new book that i'm work
worked on for
boys with black boys at the center
because i would share with people
that it's hard in a patriarchal culture
to write a book that is
loving of boys but that does not
re-inscribe patriarchy and i i worked
really hard with chris rosca who was the
illustrator for happy to be nappy to
create this new book called b-boy buzz
which is all about loving being a boy
and um and here you have a white person
and a black person me and chris we come
together to create these books when i
first chose chris i had gone to
bookstores to look at images i didn't
know if he was female or male
black or white or hispanic all i knew
was that he created images that were
playful that danced on the page and that
was really important to me and
and i think our collaboration is what
beloved community is about
um
and you know i can go to chris i was uh
not happy with the first part of the
book when the book came together because
there wasn't any image of a black boy
reading and i could go back to him and
say you know i want to have images of
black boys reading not just moving and
jumping so there's that image of being
quiet and um there's a connie may find
the image in there where there's a boy
saying hold me close don't let me down
and we're seeing this boy being
emotionally embraced by his dad
and that i think is so important when we
talk about changing the world so that
boys can have love and be loved and be
in touch with their emotional universe
you know the psychotherapist terrence
real has a book called how can i get
through to you which i think is an
excellent book that talks about how we
need
men and boys to be in touch with their
emotional universe now let some teachers
may take
umbrage at
your grammatical use in the first page
ib boy yes this is the playful um but i
think it's very poetic and i think that
it's always important for teachers
connie when a writer uses something that
is not grammatical to put it in context
to put it in the context of poetic
writing
because this this little book kind of
riffs around i'd be boy laughing i'd be
bored crying and you know and it had it
tries to create a universe for a boy
where there is a range of emotionality
because we often don't allow boys that
range of emotionality is this in the
bookstores yet this will be in the
bookstores in a few months auburn
alabama you're next
how are you miss hugs the pleasure is
all mine i was wondering if you could
briefly discuss the impact of the war on
drugs on the black community in
particular if you think that our
government's anti-drug efforts and many
inner city communities has contributed
to that loss of or or that inability to
imagine that you were talking about
earlier well i think that whenever we're
talking about addiction whether we're
talking about drug addiction sex
addiction shopping addiction we're
talking about
the loss of the inability to feel
because we're usually when we're
addicted to anything we're usually
trying to cover up the hurt so first and
foremost i part of part of i write a lot
about addiction and rock my soul black
people and self-esteem because i think
that you know irrespective of what the
government is not doing
to to clean up drugs all around our
nation the fact is we are accountable in
our lives and in the communities in
which we live but partially we can't
begin to deal with the question of
addiction until we can deal with the
enormous
emotional suffering that people are in
and many black people as i go around the
nation express this suffering to me you
know when i first wrote salvation black
people in love it was actually raised by
some people in the industry who would
you know buy this book and i said there
are lots of black folks out there that
are in emotional pain that are yearning
for answers and true enough i can't tell
you how many times black men stepped up
to
me to buy four and five copies of this
books because we're concerned about the
issues and we're concerned about the
addiction issues of addiction and
healing so what i want to see is is you
know more programs for black people in
our communities you know the wealthy
black communities the poor black
communities that look at the question of
addiction in its relation to
psychological well-being because you
know you know many of us we exist in a
world where drugs are all around us but
we don't use drugs so the question isn't
what the government is or is not doing
but what we can do to heal and empower
ourselves
i want you to you mentioned earlier this
book killing rage ending racism and you
mentioned the cover art on it the cover
art is very intriguing it's from the
artist
emma amos and what's intriguing about it
is like me she uses a lot of work from
her family and from one of her uncles
she inherited the photograph this one
right here which is of little girls in
memphis tennessee
and she took that photograph and created
this painting
and
emma is a contemporary of romere bearden
and she was one of the only women in the
group called spiral
she's a fabulous artist who lives in new
york city
and i used this was my first sense of
when i met her i was so concerned that
more people didn't know about her work
and it was my first attempt to use a
book cover to emphasize
the work of an artist but also the image
itself to think of the stars and stripes
in our flag and our nation's flag as
being children as being about our hopes
for the future and you know our hopes to
end racism because the subtitle of
killing rage is ending racism and it's
an incredibly
hopeful book about our capacity to build
the love community now someone might
think think that the title however
killing rage is not very hopeful well
that's why you know killing rage ending
racism because i think the fact is you
know we can't deny our rage i've been
you know i tell this story about
going months ago to a retreat for a
buddhist retreat with chiknow han who
for vietnamese people mainly but he
allowed me to come and i was having an
audience with him and for some reason in
my life uh in the weeks before i had
been experiencing lots of racial
injustice i was angry at my ex-boyfriend
you know and i went into the sacred
space where i was going to meet with
tiknot han and i wanted to be that
open-hearted loving bodhisattva and
instead all i could say was i'm so angry
and i had such a feeling of anger and
injustice and i think that part of why i
titled the book killing rage was that
people can acknowledge their rage and as
tiknot han says to me
hold on to your anger he says
and use it as compost for your garden so
notice that he didn't he didn't say deny
your anger don't say you have it but use
it in a constructive way and so when i
juxtaposed connie that title killing
rage ending racism it's to talk about
let's honor that rage but yet let's use
it in a constructive manner next is
tucson arizona
good morning
can you hear me
oh thank you uh good morning miss hux i
just want to say thank you and a brief
statement i am a 40 year old black woman
who has suffered from depression 30 of
my 40 years
and i'm currently through a healing
process it has definitely because been
because the way i was treated younger
and in my 20s and work and all that but
i have gotten rid of all the medications
and all the doctors and just determined
that there's no other choice but to heal
myself
and i want to thank you for coming into
my living room this morning because you
have been part of my healing process
thank you well i certainly want to write
more and more books that are about
healing that go to people directly where
they live you know i think that you know
when i first started writing the love
books many people said to me aren't you
don't you think as an intellectual this
is kind of like you know
disgusting to write these sort of
popular books and i said no i actually
think it's a high calling to be able to
write books in language that have
complicated ideas but that are in
language that everybody can read and
draw more people in that are more
inclusive i feel really blessed and i
thank you for sharing
your own struggle with depression and
healing abbeyville louisiana
hi hi
miss hooks i wonder if you could expand
a little bit more about the influence of
thomas merton on your life
well thomas merton i think like henry
now and the jesuit priest
are both contemplatives and there are
people who like myself uh were
eclectically concerned with a variety of
issues in the world both spiritual and
political so that you know
if you read my love books you'll see me
quoting merton on love and just you know
merton's challenge around diversity
mertens contacts with civil rights
activists if people read what he had to
say about race and of course i have to
throw in you know that martin luther
king in his later writings on love is a
great great mentor figure as well but
it's that intersection of spirituality
and our attempts to create a world of
love that that engages with the
political that made thomas merton such
an important figure for me
and the fact that merton and now and
bring together that whole sense of what
does it mean to be a contemplative
because you know i i never use the word
public intellectual to describe myself
it was something imposed upon me but not
in a negative way by other people but in
fact in remembered rapture i write about
the fact that true intellectual life is
really
and you're only 40 something i say by
being you know by myself a lot and so
merton
henry now and and the other spiritual
intellectual thinkers daniel berrigan my
favorite book one of them in the whole
world is the conversation between tiknot
han and daniel barrick and then the raft
is not the shore
all have been
teachers which who emphasize stillness
contemplation um you know i give for
example i i don't give very many
lectures in the course of a year because
i like to have time that i'm talking but
then time that i'm really being silent
and and
contemplating the universe and merton
was a real guide and spiritual teacher
for me in that way you make a point of
saying in one of your books that you are
not an elitist
why did you have to make the point first
and and what does it mean that you're
not well i think that
the fact is many people think that the
moment you say that you are an
intellectual
you are raising yourself above other
people that's why i think it's such a
gift i feel divinely blessed to be an
intellectual who who can talk with
people of all walks
of life
because i feel like i try to embody
that spirit of loving-kindness of
oneness
that i think is needed to create beloved
community so i think it's important for
people to see that one can be a powerful
intellectual thinker and at the same
time be in community with others cross
class cri and so that's what i mean when
i talk about being anti class elitism
at the same time that i don't try to be
dishonest about it's a luxury to be an
intellectual you know when people say to
me how do you read a book a day well the
truth is i don't have children i live
alone you know because and if i can sit
for four hours and read that's a very
luxurious kind of life in many ways so
i'm very mindful of that next call san
francisco
hello good morning
um i am coming out of the bay area and i
was a student of architecture at
berkeley when i was a little bit younger
about 10 years ago and i design and
build furniture and do interiors and
things like that
but when i was in architecture school
one of the things i realized i think was
that one of the greatest things i'll be
able to build or help to create will be
children and
i have two daughters five and six
and i'm around a lot of women mothers
things like that and i come from an
irish immigrant mother
who was very very very nurturing but
also a strong woman and
i'm concerned when i see women of my
generation
who i think are not
kind of in touch or acknowledging or
accessing a lot of the beautiful
feminine mother energy that women have
and
um
that's something i wanted to hear you
address
how you feel some of the younger women
of the
last 10 20 years
are
[Music]
connecting what they've learned from
feminism and self-empowerment with being
mothers and are we losing some of that
nurturing energy well in all about love
i talked about the fact that as a
culture we are becoming more
anti-love and less loving so that means
that women are part of that and in part
we define power as against love or
against emotional vulnerability so as
women seek more forms of power
in our nation if women have been the
keepers of the emotional flame then that
flame is endangered but it's not
endangered because of feminism it's
endangered because patriarchal culture
continues to be anti-love
visionary feminism is always about love
and in fact part of what communion the
female search for love
talks about is how younger women have
fallen into the trap
of believing that power is more
important than love power is more
important than the ability to connect
and the passage that i read earlier i
talked about them being very depressed
and very angry and the part of why
they're angry because power can never
replace love
you know
martin luther king said that when he
talked about love he wasn't talking
about some sentimental force he was
talking about a force that had the power
to transform us deeply and utterly you
know he talked about a love ethic so i
definitely believe that in a revitalized
feminist movement we will talk about
visionary notions of love which won't in
fact require of women or men that we
give up our emotional selves but that we
in fact nurture our emotional selves i
mean throughout my love books i tell
people women are not more loving than
men
women give more care but care is only
one aspect of love that love is a
combination of six things care
commitment knowledge responsibility
respect and trust you know many of us
are cared for by women who then are
abusive towards us as mothers and with
maternal sadism so what we really have
to have is a revolution of values like
the kind king talked about where we
understand what it is to be loving more
you know we can't love and dominate so
if we want if women want to be in the
position to dominate others they're not
going to be loving and young women seem
to have been really victimized by this
kind of confusion
you would have been how old when martin
luther king died
ah
still in my teens were you aware of him
at the time oh absolutely what black
person in america was not aware of of of
his charismatic power
and um you know
but i have to admit i was not a big fan
of dr king as a late in my late teens
and early 20s in fact you know i was the
militant malcolm x
kind of girl and it's really been in the
the more recent years of my life where
i've truly gone back and studied
the later writings of dr king
in a testament of hope you can read some
of those writings where he's really
talking about new technologies and
militarism and speaking about this a
revolution of values i i think that dr
king is a far deeper thinker
than many people ever imagined because
we people stop at the i have a dream
speech and they don't really read his
profound critiques of mater materialism
militarism and imperialism which he
calls the three giant triplets that he
felt would put us in danger as a nation
and it's amazing that you can read his
essays and see see him talk
prophetically talking about the
possibility of things like 9 11
happening and so i urge people to go
back to dr king
and really read what he has to say next
call center beach new york
center beach are you there oop let me
push the button good morning hello uh
good afternoon um i guess my main
question is um i'm a phd student i'm
getting my phd in english i just
finished my
women's studies certificate and so part
of the discussion that we have in our
feminine in my practicum is how do we
get students especially female students
to to actually engage with the topic of
feminism is something that they can
accept for themselves for example we
have students who always um say things
like i'm not a feminist but and then
they go on and say something like i
don't think it's fair that men are paid
um
are paid more than women are or so on
and so forth and it's interesting
because in our practicum we actually
read feminism as every is for everybody
and
i think you have a lot of um
insight in there but i'm just curious to
hear what sort of things you would say
to a student who is sort of still
rejecting that label well first of all i
really would want to know why does that
term bother people again when we talk
about going as a teacher going with to
people where they are the important
thing is not to try to push that term on
to people but to talk about what does
that term mean
if feminism is a movement to end sexism
sex is domination and oppression now
notice that that definition which i
first came up with in feminist theory
doesn't say anything about men
it doesn't pit men against women it says
a movement to end sexism and sexist
domination and oppression when i tell
people that definition they usually want
to know especially men what is sexist
domination and oppression so i think
that you know when we look at when
dealing with young people
in classes female and male is to try to
take that definition and talk about what
makes us afraid of it what are we afraid
of losing by that term and i definitely
find in communion the young women i talk
with and i write about the female search
for love is that many many young women
are afraid that if they ally themselves
with feminism they won't have partners
that they will turn off the men that
they're seeking and i know that not all
women are seeking male partners but a
vast majority are
so that um you know this is a big issue
because we have to they have to come to
see as i say in feminism for everybody
is if we want if we yearn for love then
we have to yearn for feminism because
it's only going to be in a mutual
context whether you're lesbian or
straight or whatever that you're truly
going to have an experience of love but
for for many heterosexual women
you know
learn late in life because there's a lot
of testimony in communion from women
over 40 about coming to understand late
in life
the true meaning of love and mutuality
and that many of us find love for the
first time in midlife because we
understand more that partnership and
mutuality is the order of the day and we
look for men who are capable of loving
if we're looking for male partners and i
think that's really crucial to talk to
young women about what is it about
feminism that disturbs them and to also
have them connect with the visionary
parts of feminism that help them
live their lives differently this email
emailer asked were you once a christian
and were there some things within that
faith that prompted you to start
practicing buddhism was i once a
christian i think that uh like many
buddhist christians i would define
myself as a buddhist christian um more
than i would say i was once a christian
and in fact i tease my friends all the
time both within buddhism is that i love
reading my bible and every day i pray
and i say the 23rd psalm and then i do
my buddhist practice you know i think
it's a kind of movement away from the
idea of of religion in that sort of
dogmatic sense to the idea of spiritual
practice and i'm a big fan of the dalai
lama's book ethics for a new millennium
where he defines the difference between
religion which is about institutions and
organizations and rituals and spiritual
practice which he says are about values
like care and love and forgiveness and
respect so i combine
buddhism and christianity that's why i
said my favorite book is the raft it's
not the shore where daniel berrigan and
tiknot han together talk about buddhism
and christianity but at one point daniel
berrigan because it's about the vietnam
war as well
asked not han if he had to choose
between buddhism and peace what would he
choose and take that hand says he would
choose peace because finally
the organization of something is not an
imp important as the spirit of it and
how we're living it in our lives so
that's what i would say about buddhism
and christianity san jose california
hello good morning
i am a community activist
and i was i worked with young women in
brooklyn new york with um at an
organization called the study sister and
i've also worked in brazil salvador
bahia and i was wondering what you
thought about
possibly
connecting popular education
with your with the concept of a love
revolution and how we could promote a
transnational dialogue more towards the
idea of what malcolm x was trying to do
in his last couple of years well a lot
of what malcolm was doing in his last
years was trying to create a sense of
what does it mean to learn cross
differences in community his journey
outside the united states to mecca had
been so revolutionary for him and
transformed his sense of whiteness you
know he didn't stop critiquing white
supremacy but he didn't no longer
associated that with white people in
some kind of blanket sense
so that i think that part again when we
want to bring that teaching of community
globally we have to learn about people i
always tease people you know who come up
to me and they want me to explain
feminism in two sentences or less or if
they want me to tell them about
blackness and you know we have to study
that's why i keep talking about reading
reading reading because you know what
connects me to so many people in the
world
to different cultures that i go into
like i did a big project a couple years
ago in norway with women from around the
world there is reading and studying and
so that when you meet people
you can share together even if you don't
speak the same language i do a lot of
work in italy i have a honorary degree
at the university of ferrara and i work
slowly on my italian but it's not very
good but
we find a way to talk about the
commonalities
of things but also through reading i
learn about people and then i can share
with people myself for example i just
took to the airport i go to the airport
so much in new york and there's a
wonderful woman who waits on me all the
time who's french and she's in mid-life
and has just gone back to school to
study children's book so i just took her
happy to be nappy in french which is for
that song
but um
when was that published it just it just
came out recently is it the only
any of your other books been published
in foreign languages many many of them
in chinese and japanese and croatian
i this is why i feel so endlessly
blessed as a writer certainly an italian
and
you know the european languages i i
don't have any books yet in spanish and
i'm hoping that that will happen and i'm
myself continually studying spanish so
that i can speak it
uh davis california you're next go ahead
hi um i'm a doctoral student at uc davis
and first i just want to thank you for
your work which has meant so much to me
and and just about everybody i know
my question is about eco-feminism you
mentioned earlier that you have a deep
concern for the earth and my question is
are you reading authors like mary miller
val plume wood and vandiana shiva who
also publishes with south end press and
if you're reading these people what do
you think about eco-feminist theory
about the term and about its
relationship to mainstream feminist
theory well i think that we have to
constantly critique any notion of the
ecology that does not take into
consideration
questions of race and poverty um and you
know it's like whether we're talking
about animal rights or or the
environment we have to talk about again
where people live what they're grappling
with i mean um i also i read the very
popular environmentalist people you know
the nature writers and i often find them
to be you know coming often from very
privileged backgrounds where they never
seem to consider race or or issues of
class privilege but that doesn't mean
that we don't have to take those issues
of environment to heart ourselves and to
think about the earth and to think about
what we're doing on the planet when it
comes to wastefulness you know i really
am concerned with recycling i'm
concerned with not using more than i
need and encouraging us to as the bumper
sticker says to live simply so that
others may simply live and and part of
that is thinking of ourselves as being a
part interdependently of a universe that
is the whole world that is the entire
earth and just not the united states so
that we can use our water judiciously
our electricity so that we can be
mindful of our life on the planet and
you know as the gentleman said earlier
if we get too bogged down in critiquing
what is wrong with other people's
thought we don't do enough of the
writing to celebrate our own
relationship to the earth like i've
written a lot about black people as
farmers tending the earth and what that
agrarian experience did towards enabling
black people to feel their full humanity
and you know we can see a link and i
really write about this and rock my soul
between
the focus on material stuff and money
and alluring of black self-esteem and we
can actually look at moments after
slavery when black people were tending
the earth and you know they knew that as
i say my grandfather on my dad's side
knew that white people weren't all
powerful
because in fact when he went out there
intended those crops he knew that the
white man you know no matter his money
or what have you could not make those
crops grow that you know that there was
a force higher and that was a humanizing
spiritual awakening knowledge and and
that relationship to the earth was was
important towards keeping black people
in touch with our organic humanity and
often we've lost that in the pursuit of
of materialism
all of us as a culture but often poor
people and oppressed groups especially
because we come to think of money as our
only hope of salvation did you say
earlier that you enjoy shopping i did
you know but i shop judiciously you know
in fact i just asked you the difference
because you first said you love shopping
and then we're talking about funny
because i was just
i just went to do a talk and it was
really cold and i said to the the
students who picked me up you know is
there a good will around here because i
need a sweater
and they were so stunned because they
and they said to me oh but there's this
wonderful um you know
fancy um store that you could go to and
i i had my fling with the fancy stores i
was a lover of barney's in new york
because before i thought wait a minute
you know there's something more vital to
the planet that i could be doing with my
money and so you know i'm a big fan of
recycling i'm a big fan of supporting
young artists um
who are unknown i just bought a lot of
the work of a young seattle artist tina
randolph that i i found her work when i
was on tour it was in the bookshop that
i was reading in and i'd rather spend my
money supporting her art than you know
buying the kind of fancy gaudier dress
that i did used to buy at barney so that
now you know when i shop i try to shop
judiciously
i try to share and i'm a really big
believer in trading
trading things
you know i like it when groups of women
get together to bring the stuff you've
bought that you don't use and share it
or trade it give it away
new york is a marvelous place for giving
away because you can just sit something
out on your sidewalk if it's not a rainy
day i get really annoyed with people who
sit things out and then they get rained
on but i love it that you can set
something out and someone takes it
someone enjoys it and many a time i have
picked up a book
i just need it and it was just right
there on the sidewalk for me louisville
texas
yes i want to talk to you about the
excuse me turn this thing off
uh
i want to talk to you about how very
difficult it is
between a black woman and a white woman
especially living in the south
to find and uh develop an authentic
relationship between the two i was
running a uh women's resource center at
texas woman's university and this
beautiful young black woman came in and
we did sort of a dance there
for a while not knowing both of us
admired each other tremendously but we
just did not know how to connect with
each other and i went to a meeting of
other professional women and and i was
telling them about how difficult it was
for me to to make a connection an
authentic connection with with this
woman of color
and um
i really got dumped on there it was a
feminist group uh i don't know whether i
didn't communicate correctly or what but
my clumsy efforts in trying to establish
this relationship you know
it was based on my admiring her for her
courage and i knew that there was she
found something in me too you know but
they just misunderstood completely and i
left feeling so bad
and then finally because she kept coming
back into the resource center over and
over again
and i had another friend she said well
don't you know that that black women in
the south are so used to having
boundaries because they're never touched
by white women well absolutely let me
let me just cut you off here to say that
that's so absolutely true and i think
that when we want to bond across
difference the first thing that we have
to know is what people are comfortable
with we have to respect where people are
coming from i had a texas white woman
just tell me last month that she was had
started a friendship with a black woman
but she'd never noticed that everywhere
they went out they went out to places
that were white and finally the black
woman said to her can we ever go out to
some place where there are people like
me and the light bulb kind of went off
in the white woman's mind that oh
i hadn't been thinking that you know i
think that you're so right on in saying
that we've had a hard legacy as black
women and white women and the legacy of
competition between women
remains so strong in our nation as a
whole so when you racialize it it's even
more intense and you know i'm a black
woman who whose very best friends in the
world are two of them are white women
and we struggled a lot with our issues
and i want to share the part of what has
kept us together in our friendship
you know my one of my best friends april
um is a friend of 30 years she was my
friend and freshman year in college and
she just came to new york with her
daughters who were graduating one of
them and her older daughters and we sat
at my table and shared with them what
has kept our friendship going but part
of it has been telling each other the
truth and dealing with something
difficult when it happens not bypassing
it i remember when april had her first
child and i went to this little town she
was living in and her little kid came up
to me and she gave me a hanky and she
said you can wipe the dirt off and she
was talking about my skin i turned to
april and i said you haven't done the
work of teaching your child about
difference
i can't believe this but if i had not
been willing to be honest with her if
she hadn't been willing to own her
you're right i haven't done that i
hadn't been thinking about that you know
we can't expect that we're going to have
friendship
cross these historical divides and
differences without struggle without
pain
and the point is that we make a
commitment to be together and and to
talk about these things this email from
topeka asked you the question i am
seeing an overwhelming number of black
men opting to date outside their race
what would you say to black men who
proclaim to only date outside their race
well you know i think that when any
group of any people are saying i only do
something red alert should go off
because i think that whenever you're
truly loving
you know true love really doesn't make
these prescriptions i'm only going to
love you if you look like me i'm only
going to love you it doesn't mean that
we don't have preferences you know i
might prefer to be with someone who who
is my height my race or what have you
but but what does it mean to hold a
preference and at the same time say that
when love comes in my life i'm going to
open my heart to love no matter who the
person is and so you know what i always
tell people is that there is so little
love happening for most of us in our
lives that if love comes your way i
suggest you grab it
and not think about race or gender or
any of those things at the same time
that we know that we are living in a
society of domination and a lot of times
you know as the poet mary baraka says
what i thought was love in me i find to
be a thousand instances of fear
sometimes people bonding cross racially
appear to be creating love but in fact
one party may never have divested of
their racism or their stereotypes so
just because we see more interracial
bondings doesn't mean that we're seeing
more love the question is you know how
many people in our nation who are white
or
have divested of their racism how many
people of color have divested of the
internalized racism
until we truly create love that is that
combination of care commitment knowledge
responsibility respect and trust we
can't have the love fayetteville
arkansas
uh hello uh miss hooks thank you for all
your good work that benefits all of us
and makes us think and i want to change
the subject though i hate to because i'm
really enjoying what feel free feel free
to change this well i want to get back
to something you touched on earlier and
that was on religion and i wonder if you
could share with us if you could talk
about
religion's power to heal and or torture
and its power to provide comfort and joy
as well as despair and could you talk
about
science and
reality based religion
and ethical culture societies and your
philosophy of religion well there is a
wonderful book by a theologian called
mary gray called the outrageous pursuit
of hope and it is a reading of isaiah
where she talks about how you know in
the midst of babylon in the midst of so
many cruelties and she tries to relate
it to the political
struggles that are happening around the
world today for freedom we can find hope
in spiritual practice in religion i mean
the root meaning of the word religion is
to rejoin to connect
and we know that many writers have told
us that only connect so that i think if
we look to again that definition of the
the dalai lama gives of the difference
between religion and spirituality what
is crucial for the survival of our
planet is that we have a
spirituality that transcends and and
connects us across our different
religious practices and preferences
because we know that all over the world
people are using religion as a weapon of
terrorism and hate but you know no
genuine spirituality can ever be about
hate because it's about joining us and
connecting us and bringing us more fully
you know
king wrote when i speak of love you know
when he talks about that hindu muslim
christian jewish buddhist belief he
writes of love he says it always returns
us to a vision of wholeness of oneness
and connectedness and so i think that
that that's a crucial thing for us to
remember when we think about the
necessity of spiritual life and
spiritual practice which may not require
you to have a religious belief now i
particularly in my life
enjoy religious connection as well as
spiritual practice because of the
fellowship of like-minded souls
but i don't think that we we we have to
see the two as one in the same irvine
california bell hooks
hi this is ellen and bell host i was
first introduced to you by a absolutely
wonderful professor named renata cooper
at
pacific oaks college and i don't even
remember what was the first thing i read
by you but i i am just so impressed with
what a wonderful writer you are
and how you have incredibly grown
through your writing and then the
spirituality that you have created
through your writing is just amazing to
me
i just feel lucky that i was exposed to
you when i was six years ago and that i
have had this wonderful experience of
you
i want i would love to be a part of a
discussion group that fostered
understanding and love between all types
of people
i'm very fortunate in that i do have
friends from many different backgrounds
and one of my closest family friends
is a person who has shared both herself
her family and her culture with me and
my children and i was also very lucky
that in 1970 when many of the
restrictions were lifted in a
neighborhood in irvine where all races
were encouraged to
buy and live together
it makes me cry because my kids were
raised in it
in a situation where they were exposed
to all types of people and religions and
cultures and they are the most
open-minded
giving caring individuals well thank you
for sharing that i'm just going to cut
you off for a minute and say that so
that you can have a moment of calmness
but i truly believe that that's the
community that we all want to live in i
actually don't find when i go i mean
around the nation even though we live in
a really segregated world people don't
always know that because tv makes us
think that people live together but
actually people live in very segregated
neighborhoods what i find is fascinating
is most people don't seem to want to
live in those neighborhoods when you
talk to people about the kind of
environments they want to live in people
say that they want to live environments
of difference so you know perhaps people
like yourself
spreading the word sharing how you've
lived can help create that beloved
community that king
writes about because i certainly write
about wanting to live in that same kind
of world of diversity we haven't shown
this book yet breaking bread
ah breaking bread what is it 11 years
now 1991. that cornell west and i came
together
to create breaking bread what is it
about
it is about the combinations of of
intellectual academic and notice that i
make a distinction between intellectual
and academic life they're not the same i
think it's been a gross um you know mis
information for people to equate the two
because many people are academic and
scholars but they're not necessarily
intellectuals because intellectuals
really our commitment is to ideas
we have to be radically open we can't
take sides we can't speak the dogma of
an institution we can't you know because
our commitment is to that working with
ideas and if i'm working with an idea
and i put it out there connie and then i
find out 10 years later that i was wrong
the requirements to me of intellectual
life demand that i can state that and i
wanted to say you know i chuckled
earlier when a caller said i was nodding
my head when she said your works have
helped us change and i've watched you
grow because i do in fact feel that my
own growth as a thinker as an
intellectual as a loving human being is
mirrored in the progression of my works
and i think it's so telling that i would
come to to publishing those children's
books in midlife
you know to to
a discourse that is playful that is
silly um because that i think that when
we truly open ourselves
we nurture that child within in that
playfulness so
cornell and i began
were colleagues together at yale at the
time and one of the things that i found
in my classrooms especially dealing with
african-american students that many of
them had never witnessed
a black man and a black woman talking
together
disagreeing in a humane way and i i
think if people
doubt these things they have to read
ellis close's new book the envy of the
world where he talks about the gender
strife in black life certainly michelle
wallace has given us many good books
that talk about the gender strife in
black life and the fact is we wanted to
stand before the community in which we
worked and represent for them and embody
for them that kind of collaboration that
kind of camaraderie even though we don't
always share the same opinion about
something and that was the origin of
breaking bread i had the idea and i took
it to cornell and we did it and we spoke
our different words and i think it's
been very important for people to have
that and to see that and at different
times we've given talks together and
people get to see that actually in
action where i'm disagreeing with him
and you know though some people have
written about us that we're just sort of
glad handers of each other it's really
not true we think very differently and i
have the letters that i've written to
cornell arguing with him about you know
one topic sacrificial love because you
know we were just having an argument
about being too busy and his his
defining that as the work of you know
doing god's work and me saying that you
know god never wants us to do anything
that is damaging to ourselves and you
know if people really saw the
dialectical exchange that takes place
they really wouldn't think that we're
just two people who kind of
opportunistically support each other
because we have profound differences and
we have profound commonalities so what
do you think of cornell west leaving
harvard
well you know what i think i was never
very pro cornell west going to harvard
in the first place
i felt that you know harvard and
institutions like it are by their very
nature conservative and cornell was one
of the most
um you know dissident sort of radical uh
thinkers particularly on the question of
class in in our nation and and to some
extent i feel you know the experience of
any institution as i said earlier
whether it's cornell or myself is
frequently conservatizing so i you know
i hope that not so much that you know
i'm concerned about cornell at princeton
or harvard but that i will we will hear
more from the inner cornell the scholar
the thinker the incredibly smart man um
and that we'll have more books and
things from him and less focus because i
think the whole sort of newspaper focus
on this
creates a kind of spectacle where people
forget what is truly important about a
cornell west which is his writing
his work um and not whether he's going
to princeton or harvard or how much he's
being paid and i i think that we're
we're blessed
by our work
um i've had wonderful conversations with
james hillman about that whole sense of
work as spiritual practice and
utilizing the gifts that you're given
and i think that cornell myself we've
been given powerful minds
and again i think our glory has to
always remain with the work itself
i feel so honored
to be on this show today and to hear so
many different voices for so many
different parts of the nation talk not
about me and where i work or how much
money i make but about how how they have
dealt with the work and the impact that
it's had on their lives because that's
the real moment of glory
in the work itself and what it does well
let's continue then carrboro north
carolina you're next yes i'd like to
thank you bill hooks um for
my re-education um i'm a gay black male
and i started reading your stuff about
10 years ago and i started and i read
breaking bread and then breaking bread
you and cornell west talk about
this possible black identity this black
person that could possibly come along
you know having not had a perfect life
and still transcend all of that and be
able to speak for himself and empower
themselves and et cetera and i
appreciate that my point is that um
growing up an african-american male i've
maybe engaged in activity was not
quote-unquote morally correct
okay now i'm at a point in my life in
which you know i've transcended all of
that but i'm not able to leave that
behind i'm not able to leave that behind
more so because of white supremacy who
constantly brings that up about my past
and where i'm not able to defend myself
i'm not able to say well what about
racism etc its impact on my life
it becomes closure for white america but
mine remains open
you know partially i think that we have
to think holistically
i mean anybody who only thinks about
race in relationship to their life is
missing an aspect whether you're you're
a white person who only thinks about
race we are combinations of things and
one of the things i say and rock my
souls black people and self-esteem is
that part of the danger of
life for black americans right now is in
a sense the whole culture encourages us
to only think about race or to only
focus on race and while race is
significant important and racism is real
we have to think about our
self-actualization
and self-realization holistically we
have to talk about all the other things
that may have impacted on you becoming
who you are as a gay black male in this
nation we have to be willing to talk
about our families of origin and do the
work of healing there i mean marlon
riggs the incredible black gay male
intellectual filmmaker and i used to
argue all the time and one of the things
that marlon used to love to say you know
black men loving black men is the
revolutionary act and i used to say
marlon
black men dealing with their childhoods
is the revolutionary act because often
we have to go back to our families of
origin
to find the space
of of healing to find where we begin to
have imprints that took us away from
self-actualization
because any black child or child of
color in this nation
that is has healthy self-esteem
will know how to deal with racism
and any white child in our nation that
is taught to be loving is not going to
be a racist i have never met a loving
white person who is a racist because
love continually challenges us and calls
us to deal with
anything that stands in our way of
connecting with other people minneapolis
yes go ahead ma'am
bell hook
my name is edith washington
and i am an african american 42 42 year
old single parent
and my mother
is in guarantee that's where i'm from
and she told me you were on and i ran
through the house to get to the tv to
turn on turn you on and listen to you
you are one of my mentors
and i want to also say that
life has been
a roller coaster
i grew up in gary indiana in the project
i became
a drug and alcohol user when i was nine
or ten
i
uh was was sexual abuse from the age of
five on
i became chemically dependent on heroin
went to jail times went to prison
and i ended up in minnesota
from an abusive relationship
and in 11 years that i've been here my
life has been transformed
the stereotypical views
of a person such as myself
are untrue
i became the first african-american
female
licensed electrician in the state of
minnesota
well that's really wonderful i'm just
cutting you off for a minute to ask you
did you have a question or did you want
to tell me more just so i would be able
to address it yes i didn't want you to
get cut off i want to say a little more
okay the reason why i'm calling is
because
i speak a lot in colleges universities
elementary schools you name it i've
probably spoken there around this twin
cities
i got a vision that i was supposed to do
something more profound with my life
and i started writing
i am now writing the first of a series
of books on my life
right now it's in my childhood
and i have approximately 170 pages
and i don't know where i have this gift
from i just know that i do
and as i read it to people they say the
same things
even my parents
say the same thing both of them thank
you any advice for her well first of all
i think that you showed courageously to
our audience that part of healing
is about being able to speak our truths
and to connect those truths to practices
of healing you talked about writing as a
force of healing and as a gift that's
helping you become more fully who you
are so i can only encourage you to go
forward and that if you want to publish
your work to think about self-publishing
or to think about sending it to
publishers of books
that are the kind of books you like to
read that are doing what you want to do
i tried to encourage you to get to the
question because we only have so much
time so i hope that that was one of your
questions what you could do if you want
to publish books it's important to look
at the publishers who do the kind of
books
that you're interested in getting
published now you look at some authors
and they've written
all of their books under one label if
you look at your books and you have
perennial al books south end press
william morrow now your new book coming
out and simon schuster how has that
evolved well first of all i begin my
writing life in the world of the
independent press
where there's not
you know i didn't get royalties
you know up front
a world of the struggling independent
press and i continue to publish feminist
theory from
feminism is for everybody was published
with south end press so i feel a deep
loyalty to the independent press in
america
so i've while i've gone on to sell books
for more money to more corporate presses
which we do that because corporate
presses have more greater distribution
so you'll have more readers as a
consequence of publishing often with a
bigger press but part of what i've tried
to do is balance who i publish with
my faithful publishers of many of those
books that you have on the table are
rutledge which is a more academic
oriented press you know they did
teaching to transgress outlaw culture
where we stand so i think i've been
fortunate i i've written about this that
i like to work with people i love
sometimes my change of presses has had
to do with uh
you know going to work with different
people that i've worked with before um
sometimes unfortunately as in the case
of william morrow
who bought all the love books they were
then sold to a larger company so you
know in a sense i ended up at harper
collins not because i had gone there in
fact i had hoped that william morrow
would be my publisher for the rest of my
writing life and so
as you know the publishing industry is
in great
states of flux but i feel very lucky as
a writer i love the people that i i work
with on my children's books um you know
and it's a constant for me sense of
where do you want to place your
um your work in terms of maximizing the
number of people who have access
access to it working with people like
the disney hyperion crew for b-boy buzz
so that when i say
you know i'm uncomfortable with the fact
that we don't have any images of the
boys in this book being still
reading
they say okay let's go back to the
drawing board even if that's going to
cost money and of course the more money
a company has the more they're able to
do that but it's also the collaboration
um with workers and
you know and that's a really really
good thing and so i i've been very
interested in encouraging more black
people to become a part of publishing so
that you know my editor for the love
books was a young black woman
my editor of ed henry holt for
bone black and for killing rage so that
there's a there's a whole sense of
moving to and around as a way of trying
to create an environment that brings
more black people into the pragmatic
parts of publishing and for rock myself
who's your editor rock my soul
uh was bought
by the young black woman who has herself
matured who tracy sherrod who is one of
the leading lights in of black women
editors but then she decided to go on
so i feel a little sad because i went
hoping to work with her and she's gone
but she's still
a part of my life and a part of my
writing evaluation and so you know that
is a that's an up and down thing she's
going to complete her work on rock my
soul black people and self-esteem but i
have now a new editor that i'm getting
to know malayika
at simon and schuster next call
montgomery village maryland good
afternoon ms bell hooks
my name is stacy and i've recently
relocated from california and i just
want to thank you for sharing your
spirit this morning watching you and i
actually didn't understand the whole
point of book tv but now that is giving
me time to really interact with you as
one of my favorite authors and also
begin a dialogue with my daughter about
my 12 year old daughter about my politic
and my feminism i am really really
grateful i was exposed to your work at
uc berkeley working on my undergraduate
degree on socialization deviance and the
role of women and i actually took a
class with trenty minha and remember
some very heated discussions in that
class because i am quite opinionated
about my views
and
i just
i really what i want you to do right now
is tell me those six characteristics of
love one time because i don't write down
my notes okay um you can find them in
any one of the love books but they are
care commitment knowledge responsibility
respect
and trust and let me say that i was
teasing connie earlier behind the scenes
here and saying to her you know so many
people were coming up to me and saying
why haven't you been on book tv
and so i was tickled to death when um i
was finally called because i said gosh i
guess this energy was just created out
there in the universe that said i needed
to be here with connie discussing my
work
here's an email from jeffrey jones in
shrevepoint louisiana and i just want to
read the first part of it to he uh says
something he disagrees with something
you said also we'll let you clarify it
or argue it back while i am a
progressive man for almost every facet
of modern feminism i must take umbrage
at one of your comments today you
commented that one of the goals of
feminism is to change men so that they
don't have to wait until they are near
death to be in a state that you'd prefer
no i actually didn't say a state i would
prefer i said in a state of emotional
awareness and emotional connection and
any man who's a student of patriarchy
knows that part of what patriarchy often
teaches males from boyhood on is not to
feel that's why i quoted
terrence riehl's book
how can i get through to you because he
so brilliantly talks about how men are
encouraged to shut down their feelings
so that's what i was talking about that
many men are not allowed to get in touch
with their feelings to cry to touch to
express emotions until till till they
are old or until they've had their
triple bypass or their heart attack
where they no longer feel they have to
align themselves with that patriarchal
masculinity that says don't feel and
john bradshaw who's another one of my
popular heroes says you know what you
can't feel you can't heal
and i think that you know again in his
book creating love he talks about
patriarchy helping many men to stay
closed down and shut so that's what i
was saying that a truly visionary
feminism will open up
that space where men can feel and be
heroic about their feelings and not be
shamed because we often shame men
males and females shame males for
showing their feelings we shame the
little boy who cries and we often shame
the male who cries does feminism equal
political liberalism
yes absolutely you cannot have a
feminist movement that aims to change
the nature of how all of us live that's
a radical movement it's not just a
reform movement a reform movement is
aimed at just changing for example
feminist reformism was aimed at
equal rights for equal pay that's a
reform gesture
a more radical version of feminism would
say we need to change the nature of work
people need to work fewer hours so they
have more time to read so they have so
men have more time to spend with their
families people need to job share i mean
we have the incredible work of the
sociologist arlie hotsheil when she
talks about the second shift and how
women are now doing two jobs working
full-time outside the home and doing the
work inside the home and how this is
creating a lot of stress
in the home environment and so we need
men and women both to have more time
to create homes to create love and
that's a much more radical vision
seattle washington go ahead
hi i'm recording this for mother's day
so i just wanted to say thank you but my
question is i remember um
sort of a call that you had on
black women to become um art critics and
i was just wondering if you had an
update on the progress of that call
thank you
well you know i haven't seen more black
women becoming art critics and you know
when i first wrote about this i was
talking about there are forms of writing
that that are not really conducive to
making money and art criticism is one of
them you know when i gave
the lead talk at the harlem book fair
last year one of the things i said is
there are books we need to have written
about african-american life and
experience and thought that may not make
a lot of money that means that we've got
to build into our sense of culture what
does it mean to do something that isn't
necessarily about making money you know
there are some books i write connie i
make a lot of money and there are other
books that i don't make a lot of money
and i don't sell them for a lot of money
and i feel really blessed to have the
the option but certainly we won't see
more black
people and black females writing certain
kinds of books until we can have that
sense that as cornell is always talking
about of non-market values of people
feeling that it's important to do
something whether you're going to make a
lot of money or not and this is a hard
thing in our culture right now for any
group is there a misconception
that successful african-american authors
make their success or have a tendency to
write about african-american issues or
an african-american biography or an
african-american in history
is it a misconception is my guess i
think that what
what we have to remember is often what
people write is driven by what the
marketplace will buy
so much of what you see african-american
people writing it's not necessarily what
they have chosen to write but what the
market mutually tells them would be good
for example when a bell hooks book has a
good book on teaching by the way where
blackness doesn't play much
in teaching to transgress the market
then wants me to write another book
about teaching i mean because the market
reproduces that which sells so for
example when the terry macmillan books
were enormous economic success or the
elin harris books for those of you who
don't know him he's a black gay man who
writes
popular fiction then there's more of
that that comes into being it's just
like for example i'll tell you since i
talked about loving fashion i've always
been a collector of techrose jewelry but
right now if you open up fashion
magazines you see lots of turquoise
jewelry all of a sudden you go into
stores and you see lots of turquoise
jewelry that's how the market reproduces
a product and makes people
desire it and then gives them it the
same happens in the world of books now
for example all about love without my
picture on the cover
or
communion you could read those two books
and you could never know that i'm an
african-american woman but the
publishers did raise the question with
me
of are you will there be an audience for
this book because people do often read
along racial lines you know
irish americans will choose irish
american writers or or what have you
though to me the point is to not get
stuck i love the fact that i can write a
book with with african-american um
characters let's say the children's book
but i look forward to writing a book
where there may be no african-american
cultures to characters i mean the thing
is that right now we have such a
market-driven publishing world and what
has proven to sell is memoirs
you know
popular fiction more so i mean tony
morrison for example and i write about
this in remembered rapture winning
the pulitzer prize and hasn't led to
there being a huge body of serious
fiction being written by first time
black writers because there's not a lot
of money in serious fiction tony
morrison did not make a lot of money
when she first started writing her
serious fiction the sula i mean like
right now for example sula is on the new
york times bestseller list
it was not on the best seller list when
it came out years ago so i think that
people have to recognize that
we both have to respond to the
marketplace and resist i love to read
the books that are on the big list
because i like to be a part of what
everyone else in america is reading
at the same time i know that we need
books that may never appear on these
lists that may need to be read for
example gary zhukov's book
seat of the soul when it first came out
it was kind of a flop but then when it
was reissued after the thomas more books
lots of people bought it i didn't think
it was a very exciting book but i think
his other book the heart of the soul is
fantastic but but many people may not
even know much about the heart of the
soul because it may not get the
attention in the the newspapers uh etc
etc next call jackson mississippi
hi axe i'm from jackson michigan
michigan i'm sorry that's okay um i'm a
biracial woman and i have a sister who
has two girls who are have biracial
father and a nephew who has a
african-american father and they're
treated quite differently my nephew has
been diagnosed with some attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder but he
also appears to have an undiagnosed
learning disorder we just celebrated his
14th birthday yesterday and he had a
very difficult time even reading his
birthday cards but his mother is quite
defensive regarding getting him a tutor
or any kind of help he's very
intelligent he's
had a dedicated interest in animals
since he was a toddler and he wants to
be a zoologist and my concern
is that
regarding his education and his
self-esteem
this is
clearly a major obstacle to both of
those and yet he has all of the gifts
necessary to succeed and i was wondering
bell hooks if you might give me any
advice regarding how i might turn my
sister around in terms of getting him
help thanks can i just add to that an
email thought that came in that somewhat
parallel to that from christy pryor in
hopkinsville kentucky from your hometown
i've been working as a substitute
teacher in the public schools and it
seems all too often that young black
males and other minorities are dismissed
as behavioral problems in the classroom
marginalizing them what are your
thoughts on public education and making
it a place of opportunity and learning
for all students well let's begin by
saying that most gifted children
of any race
tend to go against the grain in their
behavior
and may be seen as
problematic but if you have a gifted
child from a privileged class background
they may go to a school where the
teacher understands what it is to be a
gifted child the poor you are the more
you have anything against you people
won't see it oh he's particularly gifted
they'll say he's dumb he's a problem you
know my my own god daughter when she was
in in grade school she's enormously
gifted but she was told that she was
dumb that because she had difficulty
reading but in fact the books she was
trying to read were so so beneath her
level of understanding and i think that
one
one thing you can do in this child's
life is be an affirming presence because
again and again today we've heard people
talk about how they want to change
someone
it's hard to approach anything with the
idea that you're going to change someone
else because really the only person we
really have the power to change as
ourselves unless other people want to be
changed by us but what you can do is be
the person who offers the positive input
be the person who says by the way here's
someone you can talk to
about the this with your child you know
when when my friend came home and said
the teacher says um you know our god my
god daughter is dumb i said that's
ridiculous you know but she's not doing
well on these tests i say come on this
they're not the judge of everything so
having that alternative view can be
crucial to turning a child's life around
with what psychoanalyst alice miller
called an enlightened witness someone
who's there and particularly for black
boys there's often no one there to tap
into that smartness that creativity to
channel it in the right direction and
you can be that witness to any child
anyone out there and that can be the
life-saving mechanism even if heart
parents are not willing to open up or
you can still have that witness
i talk about that in bone black when i
talk about my grandfather being a
witness to my life and telling me that
one day that all the broken bits and
pieces of my heart
would be healed and i would be whole and
just having that witness was crucial to
my survival and and and my coming to
that place of self-love
you're watching book tv's in-depth
program it's our monthly series where we
sit down with an author and talk about
their complete body of work not just
their latest work and uh this month our
guest is bell hooks she has over 20
books and we're going to be showing
before we go uh your newest book coming
out one more time but let's take a try
to get a couple more calls in before we
leave bowie maryland
hello bill how are you fine uh good i
live in bowie maryland as you said and
i'm a
single mother of an african-american boy
who had to look for three schools before
i found a school that could provide the
nurture and the affirmation that has
allowed him to thrive so i understand
what the previous caller was talking
about the second thing and i have three
things i want to say the second thing is
i want to say to you how much i enjoyed
breaking bread particularly the piece
where you talked about how when you
would say your pieces in church and the
deaconesses would so affirm everything
that you said and i remembered how much
an important part of that was to my life
and it changed my approach in dealing
with children and i commit myself to
being affirming of all children but can
you kind of
extend what you were talking about
because i have noticed this feminization
forgive that use of the word i know you
may bristle to it of the classroom that
affects black boys disproportionately
but all young male boys it seems that
there is a hostile environment towards
the energy of boys in classrooms that
really does marginalize them
well i think all of the theorists that
have been writing about the education of
boys point out that the way we structure
classrooms where people have to be still
may not be conducive to learning for
either boys or girls or anyone who's
very active i want to just say that you
gave all our callers an important
practice that they can do to tend to the
hearts and souls of their children
particularly black boys which is if
they're in a school where they're having
lots of problems that you seek for the
right environment for them the right
learning environment for them and that
you don't give up but you know i think
that we we have to talk about when we
talk about the feminization
i think that this is a misunderstanding
because you know we want boys often to
be disciplined and the fact is children
can learn discipline in montessori
schools people don't need rigid
modes of behavior i'm always telling
audiences that i never hear anyone say
we need more montessori schools for
black boys but i do think we need more
alternative schools for children in
general that adapt the learning
environment to the needs of the child
and one of the difficulties for poor
people is the public school system is
often one where the child must adapt to
a crowded environment where there is one
model and keep everybody in line and
often black males fall through the
cracks of such an environment we just
have a minute left couple questions are
you politically active
i'm totally politically active in the
sense of of calling for a complete
challenge in changing of the culture
that we live in
working to end domination in all his
form we haven't talked a lot about
homophobia but i think that's crucial um
to end in our society um
through the government through through
the traditional governments
i try to work on behalf of the things
that i feel are vital but i get really
annoyed as in the case of the last
election when as um michael
moore tells us in stupid white men when
you know ralph nader could have
encouraged everyone to vote for gore and
he did not so
but i do feel primarily that ours is a
government of the ruling classes so i
tend to encourage more alternative
notions of government and
self-responsibility
democratic socialism
because i think that if we work more
within communities people can bring more
change
emily dickinson
emily dickinson my girl
what does she mean to you emily
dickinson you know means so much to me
because she was one of the first writers
that brought together for me
that sense of
being a bit odd
being a reader being unworldly because i
think that i was an unworldly
child i was very sheltered
in in a religious home environment and
emily dickinson was my light telling me
that i could be a thinker and a writer
you know when i read her this is my
letter to the world that never wrote to
me
that sense of invitation in her work and
i continue to you know be an emily
dickinson reader in my life today
to work with the artist ronnie horn who
who i met who's a white woman artist but
who also had emily dickinson as her
mentor and we're born on the same day so
emily dickinson is a constant thread
poetry you know is important i read
poetry as much as i can i recite it it
was recited in my home i think it's
important for children especially to
make poetry a part of daily life
we are out of time
it's been a fast three hours
thank you very much for joining us this
is her newest book coming out when
in a few months too block my soul rock
my soul black people and self-esteem our
guest for the past three hours bell
hooks on in-depth thank you very much
it's been fun to be here and i just
feel grateful to have so many readers
from so many different places
you've been watching in depth with bell
hooks if you missed any portion of this
three hour interview you can see this
program again at 5 p.m eastern and later
tonight at midnight
american writers series is focused this
week on civil rights activist and author
james baldwin
recently we sat down with author bell
hooks to find out how she was influenced
by baldwin's life and writings
this interview is about a half hour
bell hooks when you hear the name james
baldwin what's the first thing that pops
into your mind
incredible daring thinker
why
because baldwin
thought against the grain and he covered
a lot of territory i think it many
people don't realize that because they
typecast him
um as either a gay writer or they don't
read the range of his work this is a man
who was you know a novelist an essayist
in many ways a cultural critic before we
had the term
for example his book on film lots of
people don't even know that baldwin
wrote a book on film so he was doing
really what we now today call a cultural
critic covering a wide range of topics
writing some social
theory essays but really looking at
culture and how
culture shapes people particularly
looking at race and sexuality within
culture let's break apart what you said
then first take the thinker part
what was he what was his focus as a
thinker and what was his strength as a
thinker a primary focus
for baldwin as a thinker was what makes
us human
what makes us able to tap into
essential goodness
he thought against the notion that
we are born
to dominate
so he was interested in how does that
basic essential goodness get perverted
by racism by homophobia by anything
and how do we how do we restore our
sense of well-being
you know when he has that letter to his
nephew where he's saying you know you're
born black into a world that expects
nothing of you so you have to
expect excellence of yourself and that
was the quintessential baldwin that call
for excellence that call to push against
the boundaries
um and to be willing to do whatever it
took to get where you needed to go
what did the period of time that he
wrote how did that influence what he
wrote and how he wrote i think it was
one of the most
exciting periods in our nation's history
i often think if i was imagining a time
in which i should have been born because
my two literary mentor figures in my
life
were of that period lorraine hansberry
and james baldwin
and in you know the opening to to the
book young gifted in black it's baldwin
that she first evokes as part of her her
her last statements before her very
early death in her 30s is her
relationship with him
and his sort of challenging her to to
to make those leaps and thought in
action i mean here were people that were
political
they were very concerned with
colonization in africa
he was so concerned with what was
happening in harlem and with the fate of
harlem all of those things taking place
before
our culture had really come to grips
with racial segregation
so that they were really the avant-garde
i think of of
james baldwin as leading
that avant-garde thinking that was
challenging a lot of what we take for
granted today
you know we take for granted certain
challenges to racism or to sexuality
they're just a part of
what many people feel is is the accepted
way to live now they were there when
they were on the edge lorraine hansberry
james baldwin but particularly baldwin
because he did live so much longer than
lorraine hansberry and he lived to see
shifts and changes in a way
that few scholars thinkers
do and he lived to write about those
changes and to to also
let us know what didn't change what he
felt wasn't changing enough
set the scene for us in his early
writing on what it was like for him to
go up against the ideas that were so
pervasive at the time
well when we talk about setting the
scene we have to talk about first and
foremost a scene of you know that is
urban that is new york city that is
people trying to be hip and cool
because again think about those words we
use them with complete nonchalance but
in those days those were loaded words
hip
cool you know
it was really almost like saying you
were communist or
i mean because to say that you were
trying to be bohemian you were trying to
be hip and cool was to already be
placing yourself outside the mainstream
you know to to live in the village the
it's the west village that i live in now
which was the place where baldwin and
others came to be transgressive
i mean the world of the west village i
live in now is so
calm and complacent but that world was a
world where black people and white
people were getting together men were
getting together to be sexual with men
people were being bisexual a whole world
was happening then that was
a subculture a true and genuine
subculture and baldwin was a part of
that
how did his writings reflect that then
well we started with giovanni's room we
see him dealing in that first book
you know what black writer before him
had openly taken on the issues of
gayness the fact that there isn't any
real sense of racial identity
in giovanni's room so he's challenging
that whole idea of what is
acceptable for a black writer to write
and think about it's all there in
giovanni's room now i have to tell you
that i am not a fan
of baldwin's fiction i am truly much
more a fan of essays i love essays
um of course i am also a writer of
essays and fiction is not as crucial to
me so the baldwin that i kind of worship
is the baldwin that is dealing with
analyzing the culture we live in the
conversation list the conversation with
margaret mead audrey lord he was a
consummate conversationalist
and i tell people all the time that
learning
takes place more than in schools more
than
through reading people learn through
conversation through what they're
sharing with others in the dailiness of
life and so
everyone who knew baldwin talked about
how he was constantly talking
he was constantly engaging you
challenging you forcing you to think and
i think seeing him as a literary mentor
in a sense i've patterned a lot of my
own essay writing my cultural critic
around that provocative sense of
make people think and that's what he did
he made people think
did he
know he was doing that at the time
oh i think he was totally
you know in the sort of best spirit of
what it means to be a queen um as a gay
man um what it that is to to to it
excite and insight and he knew that he
was doing both that he was inciting
people to disagreement to to challenge
and he was very much an agent
provocateur and he enjoyed that role he
enjoyed throwing the idea in that was
going to upset everyone
that was going to make everyone feel
what are you talking about
and that that was a very much a chosen
role for baldwin what was the reaction
of people and readers as his writings
started to come out
well there were you know a lot of
different reactions because on one hand
the again he was celebrated by the
dissident thinking world that said ah
here is a intellectual uh black man
because i think of baldwin as an organic
intellectual that is what do you mean by
that that is to say he didn't get phds
he didn't go to universities and and
study in in in the way that the
contemporary intellectuals were talking
about because much more than say a
cornell west today baldwin was truly a
public intellectual because he came to
be known
through his
activism for different causes within a
public setting and he was a thinking
reflecting person but not in the
university world not in the the sense of
being
taught
and schooled in having a phd writing a
dissertation but when i say organic is
the schooling of himself the teaching of
himself his travels to other cultures
i mean i think for example of his
traveling to europe and writing you know
those profound words that so many
cultural critics of race used to today
the world is white no longer and it will
never be white again i mean this was
baldwin cracking open the whole
relationship between
imperialism work and immigration that
would change the nature of europe i mean
i tell people today we see all these
movies where england is white but in
fact whenever i'm in london and other
places i'm astounded by the incredible
cultural diversity there's never
anywhere where you are where you're not
seeing it and baldwin was prescient that
is prophetic and that he foresaw this is
the way the world was going
did
his
what was more prevalent for him
his blackness or his homosexuality well
i think what he would say is neither of
those things it was his humanity it was
the idea that we're always more than our
pain we're always more than whatever
socially constructed identity is posed
upon us and that was his great i would
say
sadness
um an anguish of spirit that in many
ways by identifying with causes whether
of race or sexuality one risk that
people would lose sight of your overall
humanity that here was a man who was
very interested in aesthetics and style
and yet often when people saw him they
solely saw him as a spokesperson of race
or later on a sports person of sexuality
and you know one of the later interviews
of before his death with glenn o'brien
he's actually talking against just that
kind of narrow
sense of what it is to be an
african-american person in the world
that we want to have our full humanity
that we don't don't want to focus solely
on race and that's what he felt europe
offered him
the place where he
could forget
race as the predominating factor
of his existence
you know that he could go there and
people might want to know what do you
think of uh you know agriculture and
you know such and such a place whereas
here so often especially
in his day in and
one only was allowed to speak about race
not to speak about all the other issues
of your that might you know challenge
and excite your imagination has that
changed
i think it has changed tremendously
and
it has changed more in the world of what
we can
teach speak and write about than in the
world of publishing i think baldwin was
would be shaking his head
head sadly knowing that it's still
difficult for black writers to do
non-fiction work
to do non-fiction that is taken
seriously that is not journalism
because i think that sure we have
the world of journalism has opened up so
wide i mean we have black journalists of
all
different perspectives conservative
progressive writing when we come to
non-fiction books particularly books
that are not memoir
or biography we're struggling still
struggling to have that space
where african-american thinkers
can say whatever they want to say and
take on the topics that they want to
take on you know baldwin was someone for
example who wrote a lot about love he
was very interested
in the question of love
and yet in his time and in his day
he probably could not have written a
book on love that would have received a
great deal of attention
because i think in his day people would
have said well what does this you know
homosexual black man from harlem have to
teach us about love
how did his
his thoughts on love impact your three
books online completely and utterly i
mean when he talks about the whole idea
of he says that if you can't suffer
you can't grow up
or you know my favorite baldwin quote
that i'm telling people all the time
he defines sin to mentality and this is
baldwin and his most queenly and lavish
sentimentality baldwin says
is the ostentatious parading of
excessive and spurious emotion it's the
mark of dishonesty the inability to feel
and and that's baldwin saying that if we
want to do the work of love we've got to
get past
shallow sentiment we've got to be
willing to do the hard work
and he does it in his writing he does it
to illuminate
you know what does love really mean he
tried to elevate the relationships
between gay men
past the sexual and to really get to
that place of the emotions
of how can people be humanized in the
act of loving how can be people be
transformed through erotic and romantic
connection and that's a very different
baldwin from the early baldwin writing
about race it's the baldwin baldwin of
of longing of yearning for his own space
of love and wholeness
and i took all of that as something that
inspired me in writing salvation black
people and love he's there from the very
beginning because he was one of the
thinkers who really put that on the
table are black people
going to allow
themselves to be so dehumanized
by the impact of racism and other forms
of domination that we're going to miss
out on love he raised that question
again and again and again
calling us to always protect our
essential humanity our essential
goodness
what was the reaction in the gay
community at the time to his writings
i don't think baldwin had a huge
audience in the gay community because we
have to remember that baldwin like his
white male contemporaries was really a
part of a kind of elite literati he
wasn't even so much being read by you
know middle class
black people of of gay or straight it
was very much about this particular
new york city based group of thinkers
who thought they were
you know
the
sort of
thinkers of our time the avant-garde
thinkers that were going to sort of give
us a new way to think and live but in
fact they had very little impact
on masses of people for example
baldwin's fiction had a much wider
readership than the essays that were in
fact so provocative so so prophetic
around race those things were primarily
read by the the elite classes of people
who were thinking about race and
sexuality and gender because he also had
a lot to say about gender and and
challenging the the sort of
standard gender roles you might say he
he is one of our first really
contemporary black male advocates of
feminism because he certainly advocated
for a shift
in black male roles i mean he advocated
a critique of religion which i think
black communities in america have yet to
live up to
that he was both deeply religious deeply
spiritual but constantly
cognizant of the evils
of religion when it's used in a fascist
way to discipline and punish people and
to rob them of their self-worth and he
really wrote a lot about that
when he was writing
do you do you know you you mentioned
that he was writing essays both and the
fiction and you preferred the essays or
at least that was where you like you uh
uh enjoyed it most do you know what kind
of questions he went in and out of in
making the determination on whether to
write fiction or whether to write essays
well i think like most of his
contemporaries he was a very
you know market driven writer because we
have to remember that baldwin once again
not like myself or other people today
black cultural critics who were housed
in the university getting salaries he
was many times trying to make his living
as a writer and it was that force that
often led him you know to cut deals and
begin writing things and be incomplete
or in in writing something i mean you
know i think you can contrast him with
someone like truman capote where you see
that same kind of both
writing at times very seriously but at
other times writing in the direction of
the marketplace
when did you when do you first remember
reading james baldwin i first remember
reading james baldwin when my working
class
father
would come home from his his work as a
janitor at the post office and he would
open the glass bookcase that was his
special bookcase and in that bookcase
were the cheap paperback books of james
baldwin
the fire next time and i remember you
know
you know reading that little statement
god gave noah the rainbow sign no more
water the fire next time and that was my
reading of baldwin and i remember that
thin newsprint paper
that was so compelling to me you know
because remember i'm
i'm in my teens i mean when i say teens
i mean early teens 12 and 13 and i'm
reading james baldwin and i'm trying to
connect james baldwin to my stern
conservative patriarchal father they
couldn't have been more different
but there he was in the bookcase and
therefore to be valued and learned about
did you even talk to your father ever
about james baldwin absolutely not
because in fact i used to have to sneak
into that bookcase
oh books and read them because my
parents did not feel that they were
age-appropriate
what is it about the style of james
baldwin first of all what is the style
and as a literary mentor have you also
taken on or looked at his style in terms
of influencing you one of the best
aspects of baldwin's essay style
particularly was its clarity and in fact
it's so funny because you can contrast
that with the over wordiness and novels
i go telling on the mountain and
that the essays were clear they were
concise they had a crispness
and i think i have definitely tried to
have that readability but that that
crispus that you don't
let anything go you don't leave anything
out but you make it something that can
be read by people and you use language
in a way that is
is enjoyable
and so that you can read baldwin aloud
and you can see
how he is putting those words together
to enchant us
i mean when he he goes on and on about
the idea of suffering
and growing up and he puts it together
in a way that's magical
you have i've read in an interview that
you've self-criticized yourself saying
that your sentences are too long what
were baldons like baldwin's sentences
were much shorter partially because
he came out of the world of journalism
and you know as in fact part of how i
trained myself to shorten my sentences
was to begin to write for magazines and
newspapers because the kind of long
sentences that i had been encouraged to
use in the academic world
have no place in the world of of
journalism and magazine writing so i
think he honed that craft and that skill
in that world of being told you've got
200 words and you've got to say it
and you've got to figure out a way to
say it with with meaning and substance
and he was really great at doing that
how did he influence the civil rights
movement
he was constantly there
as a force mediating
between the conservative factors
and the more radical factors i mean
he was you know enchanted by
you know both martin luther king and
malcolm x and and and yet he understood
the place of
militant rethinking
because in a sense part of what made
malcolm x different from martin luther
king is malcolm x was calling on us to
really rethink
our perceptions of ourselves
king wrote very little
about how black people should feel about
themselves
much of his his writing was outer
directed it was directed at what should
we do in relationship to white people i
think baldwin
was kind of
in adoration of malcolm because malcolm
was so much concerned with what should
we do in relation to ourselves
and you see baldwin's real concern for
his his nieces and nephews his family
in that autobiographical writing where
he is concerned in a concrete and
practical way
how can we save the lives of these black
children and other poor black children
how can we make it possible for them to
educate themselves you know he had this
phrase he used all the time
don't make peace with mediocrity
and i think that we we need to listen to
that phrase today because there's a lot
of writing happening there's a lot of
sloppy thinking happening
that is
you know reproducing the mediocre if he
could see today you mentioned the
writing the publishing world he wouldn't
be too
keen on but what about life in general
in terms of race relations
i think that he would really just grieve
that
you know you know in a sense so much of
the thinking about race today
is
less sophisticated than it was then
because the real vision that everyone
had
was of beloved community it was of
ending racism and we're living in a time
where people are very cynical about the
possibility of ending racism or creating
community and that europe that he loved
and that he sought as a haven has
changed so completely so that it's not
the sanctuary for the person of color
fleeing
the united states that it once was
because of you know immigration and how
and work
so that i think he would be stunned by
the europe of today
you know because the europe of the day
today has become more like the united
states was back then the world that he
was fleeing
so i think he would be in a state of
grief
as you um as you go through your life
with him as your literary mentor and
study him talk about him i presume in
your classes absolutely i teach a whole
seminar on james baldwin what is the one
thing that is not brought up
in the books about him in the histories
about him what don't we know about james
baldwin or what isn't talked about
enough in your opinion i think it's not
talked about enough that he was
concerned so much with the well-being
of black family life because i think
that people have such a tendency the
moment they hear that a writer is gay
to assume that in fact they're not
interested in families and by that i
mean nuclear families families
interaction between fathers and sons and
mothers and sons and all these things
were tremendous
issues for him he tried hard to be a
parenting
figure
for his nieces and nephews and i think
that we don't talk enough about the gay
men and women in our culture who in fact
are there as those enlightened witnesses
that psychoanalyst alice miller talks
about that every child should have a
kind of guardian angel
that is not so much in the primary
family structure but that is a sort of
outside observer who can come in and
help rescue and transform and he was
that he was deeply deeply concerned
about the stability of the black family
in our times and i think he would be
deeply grieved
at what has happened to black family
life in the united states is there any
part of him you didn't like
or you don't like well for me you know
the thing that was really sad about
baldwin was the the
place of addiction in his life of the
drinking and the the loss of of
that sense of himself as someone who had
value and worth
because i think we have to remember that
his own woundedness at the hands of his
father the the physical beatings that he
sustained the shame around his
homosexuality those things were never
healed and alcohol was very much that
force that
that soothed that pain
and so that was something that i felt
saddened
when i first began to study baldwin that
he never
had the opportunity to drink at that
well of healing and self-recovery so
that that we would know that he had made
the journey
um
from that internalized self-hatred to
full-on self-love and self-recovery that
he inspires so many of us to make was
that
community or life of
of alcohol part of the intellectual
group that he hung out absolutely i mean
one of the things let's think about
lorraine hansberry she dies of of of
lung cancer and every picture that you
see of her she's smoking a cigarette
you know that whole world of the beats
of the whole sort of literary world of
of a certain period of our culture was
about
drinking drugs cigarette overeating it
was about excess and hedonism and many
people were victims of it and in fact
you know we're really lucky that baldwin
lived as long as he did because he was
definitely out there
transgressing in the life taking risk
you know being that hedonistic consumer
of fine wines and
all of that you know did it impact his
writing
i think it always impacts writers um
because it makes you sloppy and i i
think that
some of his fiction was simply sloppy
james baldwin's semi-autobiographical
first novel go tell it on the mountain
was published in 1953.
goucher college marked its 50th
anniversary with a symposium featuring
this keynote address from author bell
hooks
it's about an hour 20 minutes
good evening everyone bell hooks is one
of the most consistently challenging
caring and perceptive american cultural
critics with an uncanny ability to speak
to the difficult meanings in literature
film
photography and contemporary culture
she is a critic who demands that we link
feminism with radical black
consciousness and an openness to diverse
genders and sexualities
she is also a writer who challenges
institutions
and the class systems that delegate
power and powerlessness
she is one of the most heartfelt
advocates of consciousness raising among
african americans as she writes about
self-love and self-esteem
bell hooks was born in hopkinsville
kentucky on september 25 1952
she earned a ba in 1973
from stanford university her m.a in 1976
from the university of wisconsin
and her ph.d in 1983
from the university of california santa
cruz
her critical awareness of power
powerlessness and social conflict was
born early during her childhood in the
southern segregated environment
but it was also in this environment that
hooks learned from the ingenuity of her
family and of the black community around
her
when she began constructing a public
identity as a cultural critic
hooks decided to use a pseudonym both to
honor her grandmother whose name she
took and her mother
both hooks also realized that her birth
name gloria watkins was associated with
an identity that was not completely hers
by using bell hooks she was able to
build a critical voice and public
identity
rather than valorizing the author the
decapitalization of her pseudonym was
originally a means to focus on the
critical content of her writing
in addition to her doctoral work on tony
morrison her study ain't i a woman black
women and feminism broke ground as an
early assault on biases and literature
she wrote that book when she was 19
years old
over the last 20 years her works have
ranged from a noun classic treatment of
film and mass media representation
called black looks and to work on
radical black feminist pedagogy called
teaching to transgress
bell hooks is also known for her
collaboration with scholars like cornell
west
most of all bell hooks teaches us to
empower ourselves with a fearless sense
of critical inquiry
love for others and love for self
and so we welcome bell hooks to
celebrate this symposium in honor of mr
james baldwin
[Applause]
thank you
first of all i want to thank
kelly brown douglas
and angelo for all the work they did to
make sure that i would be here the many
phone calls their kind and considerate
care
i can't think of any writer
i would most
want to represent
than james baldwin without him
there could be no bell hooks
to educate us the practice of freedom
we need educators who embrace global
consciousness
a transnational literacy
it is the convergence of the will to
learn with a vision
of the world as classroom that is
embodied in the life and work of james
baldwin
hence our celebration of his intellect
his genius
his wit
his joy in living
the broad sweep
of his prophetic imagination
as an intellectual cultural critic
writer
i follow the reckless wild renegade path
cleared by james baldwin
a visionary
a man of faith
a troubled spirit
a brother who was not ashamed to declare
that he just wanted to be an honest man
and a good writer
race
gender
class
nationality
imperialism
religion
sexuality homosexuality
the global struggle for freedom
these were the topics baldwin seized
upon
understanding that we could not get to
the universal
without first confronting the specific
location of our origins
home
family nation
these issues
placed on the agenda by james baldwin
are the issues that have created a
revolution in our culture
a revolution in our classroom
i just would like to begin as many
people have today reading some
incredible
quotes by baldwin one of my favorite is
when he talks about a right in the
church called pleading the blood this is
from one of my favorite baldwin books
the devil finds work
there was a right in our church called
pleading the blood
when the sinner fell on his face before
the altar the soul of the sinner then
found itself locked in battle with satan
or in the place of jacob wrestling with
the angel
all of the forces of hell rushed to
claim the soul which had just been
astonished by the light of the love of
god
the soul in torment turned this way and
that
yearning equally for the light and for
the darkness
yearning out of agony for
reconciliation and for rest
for this agony is compounded
by an unimaginable unprecedented
unspeakable fatigue
only the saints who had passed through
this fire the incredible horror of the
fainting of the spirit
had the power to intercede to plead the
blood
to bring the embattled and mortally
endangered soul through
the pleading of the blood
was a plea to whosoever had loved us
enough
to spill his blood for us
that he might sprinkle the soul with his
love once more
to give us power over satan
and the love and courage to live out our
days
tonight
it is my hope that my words
will stand to plead the blood of james
baldwin
to carry on the spirit of courage and
joie de vivre the fullness of life
dolores williams talked about earlier
that was so much a part of his effort
when contemporary progressive educators
around the nation begin to challenge the
way institutionalized systems of
domination
race sex nationalism imperialism
have shaped schooling
reinforcing dominator values a
pedagogical revolution began in college
classrooms
exposing the conservative covert
political underpinnings shaping the
content of material in the classroom
as well as the way in which ideologies
of domination inform the way teachers
teach and act in the classroom
this revolution opened a space where
educators could begin to take seriously
what it would look like to teach from a
standpoint aimed at liberating the minds
of our students rather than
indoctrinating them
imperialist white supremacist capitalist
patriarchal values were taught in all
our schools and in the all black schools
of my and james baldwin's childhood even
as those values were at times critiqued
in those days black teachers who were
themselves usually light-skinned
since those were the individuals the
color cast hierarchy allowed to be
upwardly mobile and receive higher
education
definitely showed favoritism
giving respect and regard to fairer
students thus reinscribing white
supremacist thought
you know that we've alrea we have
studies now that show that children are
treated better depending on whether
teachers think they're pretty or not and
since racism informs who we think are
pretty
often
children who are dark
are the ones who get the worst treatment
in this
space
which was itself set up to reinforce
dominator culture
there were always teachers
who managed
to teach us about the white enslavement
of black people
who praised anti-racist rebellion and
resistance
in this space where they offered
alternative ways of sinking
a student could engage the insurrection
of subjugated knowledge
hence it was possible to learn
liberating ideas
in a context that was meant to socialize
one to accept domination
to accept one's place in the race sex
sexual hierarchy
certainly for
the
institutionalization of black studies
provided a space where the hegemony of
imperialist white supremacists thought
could be challenged
in the late 60s and early 70s students
myself included were radicalized in
classrooms via coming to critical
consciousness about the way dominator
thinking had shaped what we knew
james baldwin was among those first
writers that i read who revolutionized
my consciousness
as a girl i had simply initially
believed white teachers who told me we
didn't read black authors because they
had not written any books or any good
books
as a critically thinking college student
i learned to interrogate the source of
information
in 1969 june jordan published the essay
black studies bringing back the person
arguing for black students
that we needed a counter-hegemonic
location for decolonized black people
she wrote black students looking for the
truth
demand teachers least likely to lie
least likely to perpetuate the
traditions of lying
lies that deface the father from the
memory of the child
we request black teachers of black
studies
it is not that we believe only black
people can understand the black
experience
for us there is nothing optional about
black experience and or black studies we
must know ourselves
we look for community
we have already suffered the
alternatives to community to human
commitment
we have borne the whiplash of white
studies
therefore we cannot insanity
pass by the potentiality of black
studies studies of the person
consecrated to the preservation of that
person
tonight's it's my hope to to think of
baldwin
as that symbol of transnational
literacy who will reawaken in us that
sense of urgency about the need for
black studies african studies
this was a powerful message
about the decolonization of ways of
knowing
liberating knowledge from the chokehold
of white supremacist interpretation and
thought
in this essay jordan raised the vital
question
is the university prepared to teach us
something new
from the onset
the presence of black studies
created a context for a counter
narrative
one in which learning could take place
for everybody not just black students
that did not reinforce white supremacy
it's so important that we recognize at
this historical moment in our nation
the power
that black studies had
and then in in its wake feminist studies
to revolutionize
how we think and how we learn
in 1952 i was born
baldwin was writing in 1952
i was in america
just in time for the mccarthy era
i had never seen anything like it
if i had ever really been able to hate
white people
the error of that dim-witted
good-natured flamboyant representative
of the american people would have been
pure heaven
for not even the most vindictive hatred
could have imagined the slimy depths
to which the bulk of white americans
allowed themselves to sing
noisily
gracelessly
flatulent and foul with patriotism
though cowardice was certainly the most
vividly recognizable color
in the tapestry
it was not mere cowardice one was
watching
but something much worse
an absolute panic
absolutely infantile
i think that's such a powerful passage
when you bring it to our contemporary
moment that we're in
i mean transpose that
[Applause]
i think it's important that we just not
come here and act like baldwin was this
easy read kind of kickback reach or
novel baldwin was a serious
militant
seeker after freedom and justice
and powerfully like many of the heroic
gay men who have been our visionaries
marlon riggs essex temple he was not
simply concerned with gay rights if you
really study baldwin baldwin was
concerned with again the specific and
the universal let me start with gay
rights if i'm a homosexual but let me go
on to the real issue is
sexual freedom
people having the freedom as he puts it
to find their love wherever it is
and i think that we have
this wonderful challenge in baldwin
which is not to be
to embrace identity but to not be
limited by it
like many of you in this room
my love affair with books begin with
reading not with writing
long before i ever begin to write books
that
long before i ever began to write
books were changing my view of the world
telling me information and painting
pictures way different from the narrow
confines of life i lived within
transforming me
i am where i am today
not because i'm a writer
but first and foremost because i am a
reader
in the biblical book of revelations
there is a passage which declares
blessed is one that reads
in the fifties
when i was beginning my life as a reader
it was a struggle to find works by black
writers
and when i found them i read whatever
they wrote
devouring these writers feeding my soul
hunger let's remember that the heartbeat
of love is recognition
i was nurtured as both thinker and
writer
it didn't matter how many awesome and
wonderful non-black writers dead white
men
and all that i read and loved
i needed that mirroring that came from
knowing there were other black writers
out there
not to become a writer and a thinker but
to be comfortable with myself as a
writer a thinker this foundation of self
love and self esteem
emerging from the
profound respect
for the historical legacy
of black writers
and black thinkers
in no way kept me from continuing to
love and respect all great and
meaningful literature
or stop my reading and learning from the
work of many writers who were at their
core white supremacists racist sexist in
thought and vision
one of the first books by a black writer
i read came from my father's bookshelf
a consistent reader a critically
thinking working man
it was james baldwin's the fire next
time
i could not have asked for a better
literary mentor than baldwin
witty
radical transgressive a sexual renegade
he embodied it all
and there he was writing to his nephew
telling him that the heart of the matter
is here
writing quote you were born where you
were born
and face the future that you faced
because you were black and for no other
reason
the limits of your ambition were thus
expected to be set forever
you were born into a society which
spelled out with brutal clarity
and in many ways as possible that you
were a worthless human being
you were not expected
to aspire to excellence
you were expected to make peace with
mediocrity
my talk tonight is has the title against
mediocrity
because this is the warning that baldwin
was putting forth to his nephew
and that we as students of
african-american experience
culture and thought must put forth that
we must not make peace
with mediocrity
how many of you have read baldwin
not just one paragraph
one essay but read and studied james
baldwin
how many of you have heeded his reminder
that our striving for excellence in the
world of words and readers as readers
students
writers
is itself an act of political resistance
it took james baldwin 10 years to
complete the writing of go tell it on
the mountain
in remembered rapture the writer at work
i remind readers again and again that
our right to read and write as black
folks is a legacy of liberation struggle
people died for this
now it doesn't amaze you sometime to
remember that that people died so that
we would be able to read and study
african-american writers and thinkers
in a world where we understand the power
of words to set us free
or to bind us forever to the mediocre
the sub-standard
the junk food trashy stuff that will
nourish ours never nourish our souls
we must
as readers and writers be ever vigilant
as students and professors
we must demand our right to study
african-american experience the global
black experience in the diaspora
we must demand a diversity of work
work that is serious and playful
work that is trashy cheap vulgar like
zane addicted to love
i don't know if you read the zane books
okay there's somebody out there that
knows what i'm talking about i don't
have trouble with zane
you know my concern is when black
students know who zane is and white
students but they don't know who
du bois is
when they haven't read their you know
september clock
this is the real crisis that we're
facing
i want to see more black mystery writers
more tacky romance more outrageous
erotica
i want
black folks to be free to write and
think about whatever we want to write
and think about
but i do not wish to live in a world
where trashy pulp fiction
cancels out all the meaningful writing
that is our legacy that is our history
that is being done today
we do not want to allow unenlightened
market forces
the mindset of imperialist white
supremacist capitalist patriarchy to
determine the nature of what we read and
write
in a world and study
in a world where white writers often
gain great status
and are taken seriously when they write
about race
many black writers and scholars are
still worried that if we talk about
stuff having to do with race
we will still be seen as not good enough
not serious
for even liberal white writers and
scholars cannot resist imposing on black
writers this weight
receiving the jerusalem prize at the
international book fair
susan sontag a writer
i read study admire
endeavored in her talk to speak to the
necessity of writers not getting bogged
down in propagandistic political polemic
urging us to maintain the integrity of
vision and craft
she declares it's it's one thing to be
voluntarily stirred by the imperatives
of conscious or of interest
to engage in public debate and public
action
it's another to produce opinions
moralistic sound bites on demand she
tells us
the writer ought not to be an opinion
machine
yet the example she offers of the
denigration
of writerly craft
evokes the issue of race
she states quote
as a black poet in my country put it
when reproached by some fellow
african-americans for not writing poems
about the indignities of racism
a writer is not a jukebox
while her point that writers should
never write on demand playing the tune
anyone wants to hear
is a useful insight
this thinker cultural critic
writer
who in the vast majority of her work
never mentions reading any black writer
notice that the black poet she refers to
has no name
manages to use an analogy that implies
black writers who write about
racism
about black experience are not the real
writers
and racism is maybe not a real issue a
serious issue
this writer
susan sontag
is giving her talk in jerusalem
a place where the politics of white
supremacy
imperialism
colonialism continue to rule the day
reading her words
in a new millennium
i'm struck by the use that she makes of
this anonymous black poet who has no
gender
no name
only a racialized identification
only a few paragraphs later she quotes
roland barth
he is not a white european man he's a
writer with a name
whose witty comment
she quotes
is no more substantial than the words of
the anonymous black writer
but it's so amazing that she feels no
need to give that black poet a name
and that's part of why we have to take
the study of our experience
our writing our history
every aspect of our culture seriously as
black people
we have to give
ourselves names
and we have to remember our names
we are in a new millennium
and we we are still fighting for our
right to become
and be seen as serious writers and
thinkers
we are still fighting as james baldwin
fought to have our words taken seriously
no matter our subject matter
and yes we are still fighting not to be
denigrated
not to be seen as mediocre
when we write about race and racism
i wonder when i read sontag's words
who the black writers are she reads
studies and takes seriously especially
the writers of non-fiction
how many of you in this room read black
writers who write non-fiction
i mean one of the things that's so
amazing about baldwin is that he wrote
so much non-fiction
across so many different genres i mean
his writing about film i just have to
pause and read you this incredibly
wonderful quote
where he says
it is said that the camera cannot lie
but rarely do we allow it to do anything
else
since the camera sees what you pointed
at
the camera sees what you wanted to see
the language of the camera is the
language of our dreams
baldwin was one of the first black
writers in our nation
to write film criticism that is amazing
in its conversions of race
sex
gender
how many of you read that criticism
many
of the white readers i know read no
black writers
many of the asian readers i know read no
black writers
or when they read one or two they read
novels
for we are still living in a world that
does not take the work of black writers
seriously enough
or they can take our word seriously only
if we strip ourselves of any racial
awareness
if we write from the perspective deemed
universal
you have to read baldwin talking about
why he had to return to harlem
why he had to return to that place that
was so specific so local
in order to embrace that transnational
literacy that sent him off to live in
exile that sent him a way to think about
this country from a from a distance but
if you read him talking about why he has
to return to the united states why he
has to grapple with the local in order
to understand more fully the global
there is still so much
that we need to read about black
experience
so much that we have yet to study
there's so much that we need to hear
from black folks about every subject
imaginable that has yet to be written
everything that we need to read and
write and study about is not a book idea
that will bring vast sums of money in
advances or sales we need to be mindful
of all the work that is not yet
available to us
books for teens
more memoirs that tell the truth
biographies of writers and other folks
that are slow to come we're still
waiting for a biography of lorraine
hansberry
for audrey lord's biography pat parker
essex hempel marlon riggs
if you know these writers they're all
black gay writers
we're still waiting to hear the story of
their lives
in our reading and our writing and our
study
we must refuse to make peace with
mediocrity
institutionalizing
the study of african-american experience
of black experience is in the diaspora
is one way that we bring a demand for
excellence
prophetically
james baldwin tells us
we should certainly know by now
that it is one thing
to overthrow a dictator
or repel an invader
and quite another thing really to
achieve a revolution
time and time again
the people discovered that they have
merely betrayed themselves
into the hands of yet another pharaoh
who will not let them go
let us be ever vigilant as professors
students readers as writers
let us recognize as james baldwin did
that we are living in an age of
revolution
you know sometimes i'm just amazed at
how much the things i write about were
already there
in the prophetic imagination of james
baldwin have you noticed when you read
him how amazingly prophetic he is on the
subject of love
he writes love
takes off the mass that we fear we can't
live without and we know we cannot live
within
i use the word love here
not merely in the personal sense but as
a state of grace
not in the infantile american sense of
being made happy but in the tough and
universal sense of quest
and daring and growth
think about the fact that james baldwin
so rooted in a love of blackness
was also able to extend that love out in
a global world to everyone and to write
to encounter oneself
is to encounter the other
and this is love
if i know that my soul trembles i know
that yours does too
and if i can respect this
both of us can live
neither of us truly can live without the
other
a statement which would not sound so
banal
if one were not endlessly compelled to
repeat it
and further believe it and act on that
belief
my friend was quite right when he said
so we must be careful lest we lose our
faith
these
are times in our nation
where people are not only losing their
faith but they are losing their hope
i just finished a new book
on teaching called teaching community a
pedagogy of hope
and in it i tried to write about the
question of spirituality in education
what does teaching to the spirit
allow and there again we go back to
baldwin as this person who never
hesitated to bring up the question
of the spirituality in life and in
education not the spirituality as you
heard so much today his critique of
christianity
and yet his consistent embracing of the
need to take spiritual life seriously
to take
not
nurturing one's
emotional and spiritual growth seriously
we are living in an age of revolution
think of all the baldwin books you have
not read
think of all the books all the subjects
having to do with black experience that
you want and need to read think about
and study
think about what it means for us not to
just have one book on a subject relevant
to our lives
written by one black writer
but to have many books
with diverse perspectives on the same
subject
imagine all the books you want to read
where black thinkers write about any
subject
if we want to be part
of an age of revolution
if we want to resist the tyranny of
mediocrity
then we must see excellence
the striving for excellence in our
reading and writing in our teaching in
our study
of black experience as essential
critical political resistance thank you
[Applause]
we have
thank you much we have lots of time for
questions
um
say your name loudly
speak quickly
because there are lots of people in this
room even though there are lots of empty
seats it's just a big room
if you're going on too loud long i will
maybe ask you with loving kindness to
stop
but who is prepared
with a question
go ahead stand up it's hard the lights
are dim over here so be
daring over there
[Music]
i don't know if that strategy is going
to encourage speakers but walk on over
to the microphone but maybe it will
since we're such a celebrity culture
tell me your name
welcome
i'm just reading over your
um your biography here it says you're a
writer who challenges
institutions such as the class system
that delegates power and powerlessness
we have a group here called now or never
which is from towson university and
we're an anti-capitalist
anti-imperialist group i was wondering
if you have any recommendations any um
advice for us as far as
getting the word out about capitalism it
seems our
society is completely obsessed with
money what do we do about that i think
one of the best ways that we teach about
capitalism is to teach young people to
work in high schools to tutor i mean i
just recently i was telling the students
that i spent time with earlier that i
was with you know a bunch of 12 year
olds asking me to explain imperialist
white supremacist capitalist patriarchy
and you know it was one of those moments
that you know where you're you're
looking for all the kinds of ways to
help them understand the system that we
live within
not so they can be against that system
so that they can have a true
articulation of what that system is
and so i think that working to educate
young people about our system is really
important because it's really hard
when when people have gotten something
in their mind about how our nation works
and they're like 30 years old and you're
trying to tell them you know it's like
when i ask my students how much money
does a single parent getting welfare get
and they have no sense
of what the actual amount is and yet
they have this hostility
where they believe that this person is
getting all kinds of money and ripping
off the the nation so that i think it's
really important to provide people with
facts people of all ages
to compare i like rhian eisler's book on
partnership culture and when you look at
the the statistics that she has in there
just like there's a whole page of just
facts about money
that are really important i like the
book your money or your life
i think sharing books with people
sharing information i think xeroxing
stuff and handing it out to people is
because you know how hard it is to
convince people sometimes without them
having some facts that are right in
front of them i think that's really
important
and i think it's truly important i love
that bumper sticker that says live
simply so that others may simply live
i think that right there we begin to do
the work of living in a more communal
way in the universe because you know
people really are not convinced with by
people who talk about ending capitalism
who've got their riches
hoarded up in the bank or you know
who are living their own brand of of
luxurious life so that living simply is
really important what we embody in our
presence
your name over there
i'm very pleased and happy to have you
here
my question is
i wanted to know if you could comment a
little bit about
i think we all know the importance of
words and especially written word if you
could comment about
the evolution if you will of the word
[ __ ] and how it plays a role in
society now with literature music and so
on
well you know i don't have a lot to say
about the word [ __ ] it's not a word
that i use very often and i've been
really fascinated because it was a word
that my mother taught us not to use but
i noticed how she's using it more and
more and more and i thinking about how
much media and we talked earlier today
about rap and the influence of rap gabby
brought up a lot of
of issues around her own interest in get
rap and then as she began to critique it
more and see what was happening in it i
mean it's very interesting this sort of
use of the the word you know i wanted to
call my new book i've written on black
masculinity you my [ __ ] because um but
as a kind of joke because it seemed like
so tragic to think that we have taken on
these words
as though we can give them sheer
new life as though we can take from them
you know the years i mean think about
dying think about lynching think about
all of those implications that are
behind that word and the notion
that we can give it some new sexy cute
meaning is just incredibly false
you know it will always carry with it
the mark of degradation
and shame and wounding and to me it's
really not a word that i need in my life
you know i'm not really sure that
anybody needs it i mean you know
when i went out
to
do
my tour for salvation black people and
love
i was astounded by the number of black
people who said to me we can't even get
to the question of love
because we're still dealing with basic
questions of self-esteem
and this really shocked me because in
the love books i know many of you today
have talked to me about the love books
and baldwin is constantly talking about
love as a choice that we make as a will
and an action
but if people don't have a strong sense
of self-esteem they cannot make that
choice
so if you think about here we are as
african-americans and as people in
general in dominator culture having a
crisis of self-esteem
you know why do we even want to waste
our time with the word [ __ ]
when we have to
invent so many new words
that begin to articulate our realities
the the kinds of words that draw out our
humanity that draw out our sense of
well-being and we haven't done that so
you know
i did i really didn't want to give
you know much energy when when that book
came out because i just find it
interesting that we're still dealing
with the basic questions you know but
james baldwin had all of these
incredible conversations with lorraine
hansberry
and one of the things they both were
fond of saying was the shame that we
should feel
as black people
that we have changed so little for our
children
that this discredits us
and i want to say about baldwin
baldwin was so concerned with the fate
of black children deconstructing that
whole notion that if you're gay you're
not somehow concerned about the
well-being of children especially if
you're a gay man
i mean if you study him and you you see
that concern i read you that letter he
wrote to james his nephew that constant
concern of what are we doing for the
welfare of our children and in a nation
where
many black children
are not even learning to read and write
especially black males black males are
increasingly among the most illiterate
group in our nation
do i care about the word [ __ ] hell no
you know
i told people earlier
that when i wrote
my little b-boy buzz book that's outside
which is illustrated by a white male
author that when it came to the pages
where the little black boy was supposed
to be sitting still and thinking there
was no image on the page
and i had to go back to the corporate
structure that publishes my work and say
wait a minute what happened to the
little black boy
you know this white man who created
these images has a little boy who sits
quietly and reads
i said we can't have this book where
black boys are doing nothing but running
and jumping
and do you realize that baldwin wrote
about this as well that many black men
never learn to be still until they go to
prison
malcolm x wrote about this
so if you go out there and you see that
anti-patriarchal black boy boy-loving
book you will turn to a page where there
is a black boy happily reading his book
now that concerns me
not the use of the word [ __ ]
you know the fact that my little nephew
doesn't want to read that concerns me
that at five years old he's already
adamant that he is not going to read
where is he getting that from
so let me have another question and i'll
try to keep my my answers shorter so i
don't take up all the time your
thank you name coming
um
i think at goucher we try to address a
lot of the issues these huge issues that
you're talking about here this evening
and i wanted to know what you thought
was the first step that educators should
take towards addressing students with
these issues and also what you think is
the hardest step that happens in the
classroom especially at college
i think the hardest step for all of us
in the classroom is remaining open
being willing to listen to new ideas
being willing to
to think about things i um
in my new book on teaching i write about
the fact that i did a commencement
which i don't normally do
and i was booed
very viciously booed by the masses of
white people that i was talking to
and i had spoken about 9 11 and i had
spoken against war
and i was teaching a core group of
professors and we were analyzing this
egg moment
and i said that i thought that part of
the issue this was in texas
was that i was speaking to hundreds
of white people
who've never had to listen to a black
woman talk
before let alone lecture them
about something that is against their
beliefs and principles
and immediately a white male english
professor said you're playing the race
card
and i thought to myself this is a good
teaching moment here
because it i live the life of a very
upper-class person in our nation i live
in a very ritzy neighborhood
in the west village of new york i don't
get to have chats with black women every
day there are very few black women in
the immediate blocks of my house if i
want to talk with black women i have to
make an effort to do that but here is a
white male that the moment i say most
white people are not used to black women
especially ones with braids
giving them lectures
he immediately objects
and says i'm playing the race card and
one of the things we worked with in that
core group
is why didn't
people pause and think about what i said
why didn't they ask themselves how many
black people do i really listen to
how often do i listen look to black
people to guide the direction of my
thought and action in my life
we know black folks that black folks are
half the time i'm looking to black
people to guide the direction of their
life
but the group had to learn how to pause
and think about things rather than
immediately defending and that's i think
something that we face in our college
classrooms and campuses when we try to
shift the the direction of people's
thought dolores williams defined for you
early what a paradigm is when we try to
shift a set pattern that people have
become wedded to it's often hard
it took us days and days in that
classroom which was composed of
professors let me be clear that the
students didn't have trouble knowing
immediately that they didn't listen to
black women lecture them about difficult
topics so often we find a greater
openness in students particularly white
students than in white professors but i
think it's that question of openness
and willingness to dialogue
i lost some of your question i apologize
maybe i'll come back to it what's the
next question there
okay your name
from gastric college i was wondering if
you would comment on black exploitation
slash hip hop culture and the
stereotypes it presents
well you know i think the stereotypes
are so obvious again the question is why
are we as black people so enamored of
them and the rest of the culture we
talked earlier have you seen that
preview of the new movie steve martin
movie with queen latifah where she is
like mammy [ __ ] hoe rolled into one and
we were like talking about why would
queen latifah at this point in her
career
and her consciousness choose to play
such a role if you haven't seen it you
know it's just like the joke is that
steve martin's character is looking on
the internet for you know
a date and he comes up with this black
woman and that that's the whole riff
but she's playing the usual you know
mammy you know [ __ ] hole role and it's
just really interesting that this is how
blackness comes through pop culture but
we have to hold her accountable and i
was telling people if you notice in
biographically right now
autobiographically she's been arrested
several times lately for drunk driving
and you have to think about what is the
connection between addiction and the
culture of addiction and dominator
culture and so many black people who
already have a lot of money like those
black people in monsters ball moe's
death puff daddy halle berry you know i
tell my friends every host says i did it
for the money but these people didn't
even have to say they did it for the
money or for fame because they already
had money in fame and yet they portray
these roles
that are so
degrading to the spirit
i felt as a black woman watching
monsters fall my spirit so degraded
so assaulted you know as i've been on
the road with rock my soul black people
and self-esteem i've talked about the
whitney houston interviews um as
something that really assaulted many
black people's self-esteem it affected
many black people psychologically
traumatically just to be watching that
just to be watching diane sawyer in her
role as slave mistress
saying you know does your husband beat
you
does your husband love you
and then for as i and this is i'll riff
on this for a minute in the spirit of
baldwin with wittiness
what about the moment when the man she
says to bobby brown something about do
you love her and he slaps whitney
houston's thigh and says this is mine
and i talk with my students about that
image
what is the image in white supremacist
culture of black people being slapped
or branded
this is mine
remember that shahrazad ali wrote a
second book called are you still a slave
so that we can talk about how the slave
mentality you know is is so deep right
now in pop culture
you know that this man can sit next to
whitney houston and he doesn't talk
about her gifts
he doesn't say anything about her spirit
he says this
i was like okay this is like a pimp
you know saying this hoe is mine
but i want you to think about the impact
on young black women who witnessed that
who were able to deconstruct what they
were seeing who knew that what they were
seeing was toxic and painful
it's like telling them you know no
matter how talented you are at the end
of the day you are [ __ ]
and somebody is going to say you are
mine
and you and why is this being brought to
us
isn't it deep isn't it profound to think
about somebody made the decision that we
needed to hear that when the most
powerful thing that whitney houston said
was that there was something missing in
my soul
hello
there is something missing in my soul
and does the slave mistress say
wait a minute here's something we could
talk about here is fame and wealth and
get talent
and yet this person is telling us that
she has a crisis in her soul now
wouldn't it have been interesting for
young people to hear
that fame and wealth
and notoriety will not save you if you
have a crisis in your soul
i mean is it wouldn't that have been
amazing
because i don't think that we can we
can't just knock mass media because mass
media can be an amazing tool for
consciousness raising that interview
could have been an amazing tool for
consciousness raising about
addiction
about soul murder
about what's happening to children
when grown-ups
usurp their childhoods and exploit them
for their own ends okay another question
over here
we're here at goucher
i'm currently taking a psychology course
a relational psychology course in race
and i'm finding it um very personally
troubling and so is my class we have
found this this barrier the racial
barrier between the white students and
the black students i'm having a very
hard time getting past that not sure who
should move first
i was wondering if you had anything to
say about that
well you know i think that
to me what's really fascinating is is
the question of loving justice because
in this new book i've just written i did
i
wanted to talk about the white people
who are fundamentally anti-racist who
are they
where do they learn
to be anti-racist so i have this essay
called what happens to white people who
change and i interviewed all of these
white people and i was so struck by the
number of white people cross-class
religion sexualities who talked about
learning about justice in their
childhoods
i interviewed one of the big executives
at disney who has been really central in
publishing
liberatory books for black children and
with black representation and she talked
about the fact that she was a child of
the 50s and her mother was divorced
and she was forced to sit after school
with the other little divorced kids and
they were black
and one irish girl and there she began
to formulate her sense of i must stand
on the side of justice i must stand on
the side of people
who are different and i must do my work
i mean what is so marvelous is that like
my books children's books are published
by disney hyperion and is that i can go
to to these enlightened group of people
that i work with
who make mistakes and say there is no
boy reading
and they go back to the drawing board
when i bring them those statements about
black males and reading but this is
because this woman has cultivated her
anti-racism
from day one and so part of what i
wanted to do in this book was to give us
images that are of hope of how people
transform their lives and their thinking
and so i think for places places so many
liberal arts colleges are battling with
the question of difference
as people feel afraid people hunker down
into the familiar so once again i mean
we have to tell our stories to one
another i mean in my classrooms we often
start with the telling of our stories
because that is one of the things that
helps us begin to do the process of
making community and one of the things
that you have to see baldwin if you
haven't seen him in documentary films
because one of the things you'll see is
that he was a great storyteller
and story has that power to captivate
people and to draw us in
i want to you tell you to forgive the
the vagueness of my
my answers because tiknot han the
vietnamese buddhist monk who's one of my
teachers always
makes me remember that you can learn
first from something that may approach
something indirectly
but you need all of you here at goucher
to look with compassion at what is
happening here the
legacy of this institution and what is
needed because it's hard when speakers
come in to have some kind of strategy
because every change is a very specific
thing
i mean one of the things i do in in
texas
i teach for a month in texas at a little
white liberal arts college and part of
what i do with the faculty staff and
students
is teach them about their location about
how to how to live more humanely more
justly more in community in the location
that they're in and here's just one
example when i arrived at this
institution white people would say well
there just aren't any people of color
here
and i would think about the fact that
the cafeteria was full of black folks
and hispanic folks waiting on them
i was like well wait a minute
let's start right there
it
isn't our is in our academic community
everybody
everybody who makes our institutions run
smoothly
and let's just start there
and begin to look differently at the
frame
and then we can talk about why are all
the people of color on the bottom
you know but at least we change our
perception of the frame so partially in
drinking of how you heal wounds of
separateness in a specific location you
really have to have the specifics of
that location i mean i know that part of
kelly brown douglas and other people
wanting to bring africana studies here
in a more
firmly institutionalized way is to have
that academic base that affirms you know
our struggle for change i think that as
a feminist i think feminist movement has
been amazing
and one of the places where it's been
amazing is in the classroom think of all
the male professors around our nation
who are teaching a work by a woman
who 20 years ago
would not have considered putting a
female
on their syllabi
that is an amazing revolution to me we
talk so badly about feminism that we
forget what happened for many of us as a
as a consequence the next
a feminist political movement for
justice in the academy
another question over here i'm going to
hear questions maybe a couple of
questions and answer them together your
name
my name is toy jackson i'm a sixth grade
teacher
welcome
thank you so much we like those sixth
grade teachers girl because you're doing
the hard work
i was privileged enough to see the chuck
davis dancers and sweet honey in the
rock recently and it brought back to me
the importance of healers
uh as as art as healing and i wanted to
thank you for being one of those healers
to kind of free up some of those
heartened spaces of going day to day
doing the same things and sprinkling
some some rain on the the desert of
um
status quo so i wanted to say that to
you thank you for being a healer and my
question i'm not quite sure what it is
but it has something to do with
black people going to other countries as
james baldwin did i'm considering
relocating to thailand because i taught
english there last year and the idea
that for black people to really know how
beautiful and powerful they are
they need to be outside of this country
for at least a limited time and so i'm
i'm asking you to speak to that in in
what place um black folks deciding to go
into exile has
um for our community and for individuals
i don't think that we have to leave this
nation to claim our self-esteem to claim
our power
now we may choose to leave to be able to
live in a different environment that's a
different question altogether but we
have to my people my people we have to
claim our self-esteem right here you
know when i was reading all the baldwin
stuff and you know i was thinking about
baldwin and and i i was pained
because we all know that baldwin
struggled with alcohol addiction his
entire life
and i thought about the sense of being
that's why i
said in my early part of my talk that he
was a troubled spirit
so that what we see that not even
leaving and living in exile really
allowed him to tend to the wound the
traumatic wound
i mean one of the things that i write so
much about and rock my soul is the
post-traumatic stress that many black
people are experiencing from loss and if
you studied your bald when you know that
he had that early feeling of loss
the early emotional violence i just want
to read you a passage where
in creating love psychotherapist
bradshaw
highlights the reality that the abused
child often enters a trance state
one of hyper-vigilance
and in such a state a child may
experience panic attacks
over reactivity or excessive worry
he further states a child with
unresolved trauma is frozen in time
when any experience resembling the old
trauma occurs the old trauma is
activated
according to bradshaw
abuse survivors learn that relationships
are based on power control secrecy shame
isolation and distance
these traits accurately describe the way
many black folks female and male think
about relationships
anger and rage are often the primary
emotions that are expressed in intimate
relations between black people thus
intensifying and normalizing black on
black emotional violence now i read that
because i feel that we see in baldwin
this incredible intellectual mind
that still had soul healing that he was
not able to accomplish in his lifetime
so i think that for black people who
seek to live elsewhere the important
thing is that you have to do your soul
healing
wherever you are
and that we have to make this country
a place where our soul healing can occur
whether we change the system of
imperialist white supremacist capitalist
patriarchy or not you know we
sang that song in church
is it well with your soul are you free
and made whole well i'm thankful that i
can be here as a child of baldwin as a
daughter of baldwin a spiritual daughter
who is whole
who is self-loving
and who did not have to go somewhere
else
to move away from the trauma the
reenactment trauma i mean i was so
struck re-reading baldwin because i went
on this orgy in preparing for here how
much he talked about the pain of being a
black man in this nation
how much he talked about not being able
to get away from the pain
of dehumanization and the brutality
and how everywhere he turned sometimes
he was it was squeezing him
and and feeling that whiplash that he
talked about
you know of whiteness
and he was able to relieve that pain
by living in exile but he was not made
whole
do you hear me
he was not made whole
and it is to honor his legacy that many
of us are striving to create the
conditions right here right now as
buddhist teacher pima children says
right where we are for we as black
people can recover our souls
and be whole
so i think we have to go wherever in the
world it delights our spirit
but the work of whole making
has to be done wherever you are you know
that was a long-winded thing i'm going
to take a few questions and then we're
going to close
i know it's getting time for me to close
kelly so i'm mindful of that
come on up honey bunny
hi my name is heather pax and i am an
educator as well i teach sociology
and when i teach about issues that you
um bring up in your books white
supremacist capitalist patriarchy a lot
of students
a lot of my students who come from very
privileged backgrounds have a really
hard time
listening to those kinds of ideas and
when i talk about it i can't i just
can't bring myself to talk about in a
removed fashion because i live in a
world that breaks my heart and i don't
know how to sometimes deal with my own
emotions about the political climate
that's going on in the classroom without
turning people off so i don't i'm
wondering how you challenge your
students without alienating them well i
think that goes back though to pima's
challenge to start with where people are
i like to ask students i i in this new
book i've written about teaching i
talked about the fact that i've been
working a lot in the public school
in the last few years and working with
you know because of these children's
books i do like classrooms that now have
like 43 and four and five-year-olds and
thinking about starting where people are
it's like really meaning that we we go
to our students in the places where they
live and think and dream
and that's what we have to work with and
a lot of time those of us who are are
progressive educators we want to jump in
and we want students to come where we
are
we want them to get it get it quick and
be where we are rather than in fact go
to where they are
that is to say thinking about what is it
about the life that you lead that you
hold dear
what is it important to you i find this
often in dealing with men teaching men
about sexism and patriarchy that a lot
of times when you try to tell them what
it is they stay in the space of
resistance
but if you start going into the space of
how do you want to be treated
what what makes you feel good in life
how do you feel when someone is yelling
and screaming at you
what do you think about if you think
about yourself being raped
you know what do you think about when
you think about yourself you know these
heterosexual men what do you think about
when you think about having sex in the
ass you know does that seem cool to you
there's a great essay by cat um karen
finley
about where she does this whole riff
about all of these straight men who want
to have sex with women and and you know
have anal sex and she says hey i'm all
for it let's start with me giving you
anal sex
you know let's see how open you are to
it
and it's like there again is that
challenge of people where they are if
you think this is maybe painful or
dangerous for you then maybe you have to
think about maybe it's painful anal sex
without i'm not anti-anal sex let me say
that um
anal sex without you know
protection is one of the quickest ways
to spread hiv and i say this because
there have been a lot of epidemics in
our nation of hiv among teenagers in
certain pockets in college campuses
because of people having unprotected
anal sex that males want to have
heterosexual males
you know so i mean i just that that was
like throwing out there that sense of
going where people are rather than
trying to convince them
you know this isn't something you want
rather than saying you know how do you
feel about this relation in relation to
your body
what do you want to have happen to your
body that's what i mean by going to
people where they are your question
your name
education and
the nature of my program is the students
come out of school
to do this program one day a week they
miss about a half day of school many of
these students are seriously deficient
in one or more of their subjects and one
thing i struggle with is is this the
best thing that for these students
is it the right thing to take them out
of school and miss this time to do do
these activities and so
i think that if we give care you know my
one of the things i said consistently in
the love book and rock my soul
you can give a child care
or love
and that may be the catalyst one moment
of someone believing in you i can't tell
you how many times somebody comes up to
me and says i was the little girl that
you took the time to speak to in the
airport at such and such a place and you
you know spent that moment with me so i
think that part of what i've learned
from buddhist practice is that teaching
moments
happen in so many ways i mean you may be
teaching with the strength of your love
of justice
it may you could be playing ball with
somebody who doesn't read very well but
if you are inspiring them to have
greater self esteem you may be
empowering them to seize the opportunity
to grow when it comes there again it's
so hard for us in in the culture of
quick change you know make everything
right right away to be able to think
that something you're doing like the
work you're doing may have far-reaching
consequences and when i
have so much opportunity to
to sit and listen to tiknot han in the
dalai lama two men who live in exile
who've known great holocaust
and to see them talk about
being being able to glory in small
things and in small revolutions because
we are such a nation that wants the
splash
we want the big thing we want the big
change we don't want to
enjoy that the work you may be doing may
be having meaningful consequences and
that's remember in teaching to
transgress i talk about that that
sometimes we do work that may not appear
rewarding or exactly right at the time
we're doing it and then later we find
out it has such incredible ripple
effects for people in their lives
you know even that image of the black
boy reading it has had such an
incredible effect on lots of black boys
but there was a part of me that didn't
want to go against the system to get
that image there
the last couple of questions and then
i'll close
yeah
be quick hi and i'm going to take all
those questions quickly i want to hear
them all in all of these and then i'm
going to close okay good evening my name
is martina callum
and it's been a long time since
i was a college student i'm a physician
and my specialty is family practice
you touched on so many things
tonight you know just starting off with
refusing to make peace with mediocracy
but the thing that really grabbed me
was um your mention of your book um
spirituality and teaching and developing
a sense of community now as a primary
care physician
you're going to be quick with oh okay i
often
i often have to teach
medical students young physicians um in
training and you know i have a strong
belief in care of the soul and the
bottom line is i want your book so i can
see how i can use it and what i do
okay
thank you
come on everybody i'm just going to go
here this row and i'm going to go to
that row
i'm a freshman at goucher and i was
wondering if you could speak to
racial guilt i don't know if that
do you understand what i'm saying like
because i'm i'm not black i can't
understand the struggles that african
americans have gone through and sort of
okay okay that's a good one
my name is ben vallas
a musician and my question is kind of
about music
i listen to a lot of hip-hop uh a lot of
stuff like that was too cool keith nwa i
started to think like wait i'm this
white guy sitting here
listening to this stuff is there more
subconscious things going on
with that in my you know just
it's warping your spirit or yes or
exoticizing an internal other but um
that's why i was so happy when i
discovered dead prez and i was wondering
if you could speak to dead prez as sort
of an antidote to the misogyny and the
total just self-hatred that seems to
consume a little bit of the hip-hop
scene in this country okay and so i
won't be able to answer all of these but
at least we get to hear them go ahead
hi my name is vanessa lopez and um
i'm latina i grew up in this country and
for a long time the dualistic black and
white mentality actually helped me find
myself but lose myself within it and
i wanted to see
how you yourself have been able to
both accept it be realistic in it but
move beyond it to a universal human
level
notice how we're getting all the deep
profound questions when there's no time
this is probably definitely too broad to
go into with the clothes but um i just
wanted to know my name is candice
williams i just wanted to know if you
could comment on how stereotypes and
degradation of certain cultures have
been embedded into like the persona of
like minority cultures to the point
where like it's almost like the
preferential identity like
women black women prefer straight or
hate or even to the point where like
like women prefer taller men than them
and stuff like that you know okay
good evening this is my name is linda uh
my question is that um we um we're we're
all aware of the fact that the children
are our future and i was wondering how
do we trans trans
sorry transcend the racial stereotype
when racism is seen in everywhere for
example in disney the only place in
which you see black people is when
they're portrayed as animals i wanted to
know if you could comment on that well
first of all i want to say to the
everyone here at galter you must be
doing something right because many
goucher students have gotten up to
boldly and courageously ask their
questions and you know i do this a lot
so i know how often students hesitate so
congratulations to all of you
who are clearly
educating as the practice of freedom
because people feel like it's okay to
make their voices heard some quick sound
bite things
i think one of the most vile
representations of imperialist white
supremacist capitalist patriarchy is the
film harry potter and the chamber of
secrets i think that if the harry potter
books had been written by a white man
people would have been all over those
books critiquing the sexism i mean think
about the fact that hermione appears to
be a lot smarter than harry but she is
kind of an untouchable she's never going
to be able to be
one of the truly chosen think about all
the politics of who is chosen and who's
not think about the fact that the chosen
people and and kind of you know
put harry together with george bush the
chosen people
get to kill and do whatever they want to
in the name of being good and chosen so
that there's a tremendous amount of
violence think about the fact that the
incredibly
the self-hating character looks like
gandhi from the neck down and within
buddhism because we believe in the value
of all sentient beings think about how
you have in that character that brown
dewy character the intersection of
animal and human so we have the
disrespect of animals yet again of that
which is deemed not human it's so deep
you know and i'm not trying we talked
earlier the students and i about how we
can hold our enjoyment of of harry
potter at the same time that we can have
critical awareness so that i think i
throw that out as a text because
don't you find it interesting think
about harry potter books and think if a
white man had written them
how critical
people would have been but somehow
because they can just be thrown out that
this woman has written them people have
not been as critical of the enormous
violence in the film
because i think it's one thing to read a
book where people are being hit and it's
another thing to visually see that um i
wanted to go back to that whole question
of the the fact that we are bombarded
every day i mean one of the things
tiknot han teaches us in buddhist
practice is we really have to be
vigilant about what types of images we
take into
our our imagination
and and people who are watching
television all day in this nation
are taking in
the images of imperialist white
supremacist capitalist patriarchy and
being affected by it
whether you whether you want to be or
not
and this is especially poignant when it
comes to children the teaching of
violence to boys through mass media
my next two books
are about masculinity
because i've been very very concerned
that feminist theory dropped the ball
where men were concerned that we didn't
go far enough
that we we didn't really offer men
liberatory visions of masculinity
and that now we're seeing the resurgence
of a very virulent dangerous patriarchy
and it's reminding us that we didn't do
our work as feminist theorists i mean
i'm talking about men and women
and it's just very difficult to imagine
beyond the patriarchy they're going to
close just by saying that tony morrison
wrote something recently about the fact
that she's working with a lot of
children who are incredibly smart
and they can do anything on the computer
but they lack the power to imagine
and when i think about you know books
that have changed my life i think of
viktor frankl's book man search for
meaning
and i think about how much he talks
about how the imagination
helped him survive
holocaust
experience
you know when he talks about the
imagination
of the face of his wife
and the tenderness that they shared i
mean you know how when you have those
books that have raised your
consciousness and you go back to them i
go back to that book periodically in my
life and you see him writing about love
in a very similar way to james baldwin
the power of love
to transform our lives to heal us
i mean think about martin luther king
saying it's i'm not talking about love
as a sentimental force i'm talking about
love as that force that leads us to be
act on behalf of our survival and our
connectedness and so that i think about
the prophetic imagination because i do
want to close with baldwin again
talking about the prophetic imagination
what we cannot imagine will not come
into being i want to share in closing
that i think particularly because as
intellectuals as academics it seems we
have been particularly guilty
of we love to focus on what's wrong
we love deconstruction
we can talk about what's wrong from sun
up to sun down
we have a real problem
when it comes to the imagination of
what's useful positive what we might use
to change things i found that in writing
the new book i wanted to theorize the
positive what has worked but i found it
was a lot easier to talk about what
doesn't work than to actually talk to
people about what has worked in your
life
to ask my aging fundamentalist christian
parents what have they learned from me
you know what have i taught them
have they been able to let go their
ageism and their autocracy in parenting
their discipline and punish
to receive something from me as a
thinker and an intellectual
what we cannot imagine cannot come into
being so that in part it is crucial that
we identify what is troubling what is
wrong but it is also even more crucial
that we begin to imagine the worlds that
we want to be in the worlds of peace
and happiness and joy that the llama
writes about in the ethics for a new
millennium i thank you so much
for allowing me to celebrate the life
and work of james baldwin
[Applause]
bell hook's talk was part of a symposium
hosted by goucher college marking the
50th anniversary of the publication of
james baldwin's go tell it on the
mountain
visit goucher.edu for inform